foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones video
in this video I want to go over what I
think should happen in the new Jon Snow
show that's getting developed by HBO as
you all know HBO and Game of Thrones
actor kid Harrington are developing a
new show about The Life and Adventures
of Jon Snow this is a show they have
been making ever since Game of Thrones
ended over three years ago ever since we
all found out they have been developing
this show hundreds and thousands of us
fans have been wondering what would
happen with Jon Snow after the events of
Game of Thrones at the end of the
original series we last Saw Jon Snow in
his direwolf ghost heading north of the
wall with their wildling friends as of
right now there really isn't anything
interesting happening in Westeros as far
as we know the night king and the white
walkers are dead Danny Cersei and even
euron Greyjoy are dead not only that but
even drug-on is flying across the narrow
sea with dany's body with all of that in
mind what would Jon Snow actually do if
they made another show like I said there
is a very much happening in Westeros
right now so it doesn't seem like the
Jon Snow show would be very interesting
well in this very long video I will let
you know about all the things that I
think could happen that would make this
a great show Not only would I have
Daenerys and drogon come back but I
would also bring back the night king and
the white walkers as well I believe I
have found a great way of making all
this happen that does actually make
sense based on everything we have seen
in Game of Thrones so far now before I
get into all of that I have to let all
of you know about this amazing new offer
I want to thank the sponsor of today's
video brilliant brilliant is an
Interactive Learning tool that uses a
Hands-On approach to teach you a wide
range of stem Concepts like math science
and computer science it has been perfect
for me as a Hands-On learner the most
efficient way to learn is interactively
while testing yourself along the way
brilliant offers simulations to
manipulate in quizzes to master any new
subject you can find everything on
brilliant from the foundations of math
all the way up the college level content
such as cosmology and quantum mechanics
and there are new exclusive lessons
added each month brilliant is the best
way to learn something new every day and
learning a little every day can have a
huge impact on your brain's Health and
Longevity I like to spend 30 minutes on
brilliant in the mornings while I drink
my coffee it is a much more productive
way to stimulate my brain and get ready
for the day rather than scrolling
through social media now the best part
is you don't have to spend a fortune or
four years in a classroom either the
first 200 people to sign up with my link
brilliant.org talking Thrones will get
20 off an annual premium subscription
don't miss out on this amazing offer
once again I would like to thank
brilliant for sponsoring today's video
since there was so many fans who did not
like how the show ended I thought this
new season I made would make for a much
better ending and now I also think this
would be a very interesting way to start
off the new Jon Snow show I think this
is how they could make Jon Snow and Game
of Thrones great again so shall we begin
the sun is just now beginning to set as
we see Jon and ghost still traveling
with a small group of wildlings John and
tormen are up front leading all of them
through the dense forest you should
start back torment giant Spain said as
the woods began to grow dark around them
the white walkers are dead the wall is
still broken at East watch there is no
need for a Night's Watch anymore there
are no longer any threats living out
Beyond the Wall John said I don't intend
on staying at Castle black ever again
besides I had to swear I would never
ride South they can have the Seven
Kingdoms I'm done fighting with a slight
grin on his face torman says I knew you
had the North in you boy the real North
if you're staying with us we should stop
soon I will make you a fire I know how
you saw the nurse get cold in the night
I can make my own fires John said half
smiling himself then he says we will set
up camp soon we're almost there in the
following scene we're back in Winterfell
where Sandra Stark is now Queen of the
North the scene begins as we see her and
the maester walking around the grounds
of the castle Winterfell is still in
shambles there are dozens or even
hundreds of men and women running around
and working in several different areas
we can see there are men working on the
exterior walls of the castle there are
woman butchering me there are men and
women carrying in large stone blocks it
will be years before the castle looks
like it once did we follow sons of Stark
as she walks out to the godswood alone
she sits down under the werewood where
we have seen her and so many other
Starks sit before Sansa sits there in
silence as she looks around at all the
red fallen leaves on the ground soaking
up the white snow underneath it looks as
if she is in deep thought as she most
likely thinks about everything that has
happened to her and her family at after
a few more moments of Silence she looks
back at the face that's on the wirewood
we can hear her take a deeper breath
when she looks at it the face now looks
slightly different than it did before it
still sort of looks like bran but
somewhat darker there's something about
it that makes Sansa feel very
uncomfortable because she immediately
looks away from it then abruptly stands
up to leave the godswood as she begins
walking forward she steps on something
making her look down to see what's under
her foot she bends down to brush away
some of the snow whatever it is she sees
is stuck because she has to yank at it
to rip it free from The Frozen Ground
she stands back up while holding the
object in her hands Sansa isn't sure
what she's looking at but she can feel
it's made out of some sort of metal
suddenly she drops it back in the snow
then she begins rubbing her hands
together hoping to warm them back up
whatever Sansa was holding was so cold
she could even feel it through her thick
gloves Sansa doesn't realize it but she
had found the symbol the night King war
on his armor it must have broken off
when Arya stabbed him we now see the
maester walking to the godswood when
Sansa sees him approaching she says what
is it the maester says your grace there
is something you should see as Sansa
walks away the scene ends as it focuses
on the metallic symbol laying in the
snow in the following scene we go down
to King's Landing where Sam Gilly and
little Sam are finally getting settled
into their new living quarters inside
the red key we see Sam as he sets down a
large stack of books on the table we can
see some of the books are about
different subjects like language history
medicine and even magic Gilly asks what
are all those for they just arrive from
The Citadel says Sam bran has made
arrangements for me to continue my
studies while we stay here with a big
grin on his face he says they will send
me new books whenever I need them I may
have been chosen as the new maester but
I still have so much to learn speaking
of books I should send them back the
ones I I stole Sam walks across the room
and grabs another stack of books he
opens one of them up and we can see it
shows arya's dagger inside this is one
of the books Sam stole the same one he
was looking through when he discovered
the dragon glass in season seven he
looks at the dagger for a few moments
then says I guess we really didn't need
all these books in the end the dragon
glass helped but it was Valerian steel
that killed the night King he slams the
book shut then grabs another one this
one says Legends of the long night we
saw this book in season 7 as well when
Gilly was reading it Sam focuses on the
front of the book which looks like it
has a skeleton on the front this
skeletal looking creature is standing on
the moon while the sun is hiding behind
him but that's not what Sam is focusing
on he looks at its hands in one hand it
has what looks like one of the white
Walker's ice swords but in the other
hand it's holding what looks like a
dagger Sam looks very confused right
before this scene ends we see him
suddenly grab add the other book he
opens it back up then finds the image of
the dagger again he looks at Gilly then
says I will need to write a letter in
the next scene we're on the beach just
below the red key we can see Braun Davos
and Tyrion walking along the shore we
also get a great view of King's Landing
from here we get a good look at just how
much was destroyed by Daenerys and
drogon we begin following them as they
are walking on the beach why are we here
there are some young ladies waiting for
me in the city you can have them
afterwards when I'm done with them Brawn
seditarian with a Sly look on his face
you can have your fun later says Tyrion
we still have work to do this entire
city needs rebuilt from the ground up
now he looks at Davos and says you and I
both know this city has its weaknesses
even without dragons cities have Rose
and fell for thousands of years it
nearly fell the night you and Stannis
came across the Blackwater Westeros is
on its knees right now recovering from
years of Bloodshed with a large enough
Force this City could be easily overran
Again overran by who says Braun the only
reason this city needs rebuilt is
because of your lovely Dragon Lady she's
dead we have no enemies right now the
unsolid and Dothraki are gone you saw
them set sail the same as I did the
Seven Kingdoms are actually working
together are they not it's not the Seven
Kingdoms I worry about says Tyrion have
you spent much time across the narrow
sea he says to Baron only a little the
wine is good but I prefer our brothels
said Bron Daenerys had her foes
everywhere she went but there are those
across the narrow sea who still love her
I have seen it with my own eyes says
Tyrion the Seven Kingdoms are wide open
right now the unsullied and arthraki
aren't the only armies who have been
decimated look around here do you see
armies in the thousands guarding this
city no says Braun who now looks annoyed
we see Tyrion look out across the water
I'm afraid of what might become coming I
don't think I need to remind either of
you drogon is still out there somewhere
he now looks at Davos again and says one
day we might look out across this water
and see a new Army on the horizon who's
on its way to take this city I just hope
we're ready when that happens in the
next scene we go across the narrow sea
to essos in the city of Atlantis the
scene opens up as we see a large Banner
flapping in the Wind on this Banner as a
Burning Heart the symbol of relore it
sits atop one of the largest buildings
we have ever seen we are now at the red
Temple of the Lord of Light it is
sitting high up on the hill the temple
is a hundred different Hues of red
yellow gold and orange it looks as if
the stone was made out of fire itself at
its base just outside of its walls is an
army of what looks like a thousand men
this is the fiery hand an army of slave
soldiers who guard this sacred structure
they're all holding back a crowd of
thousands of followers over lore at the
very top of the steps there are several
high-ranking members of relore each of
them are dressed in red silk robes with
hoods covering their faces each of their
red silk robes are covered in the same
symbols we have seen on melisandre's
necklace one of the men even has the
symbol branded on the center of his
forehead they're all standing in front
of the entrance which has very large
doors that have the Burning Heart
engraved into them in front of them is
the largest and deepest Brazier we've
ever seen with a fire burning inside
that reaches 100 feet into the sky these
high-ranking members are standing in a
circle around the fire chanting
something in high Valeria as the chance
get louder and louder men and women in
the crowd below begin weeping the fire
starts reaching higher and higher into
the sky it begins burning so bright
everyone in the crowd has to Shield
their eyes swirling around inside this
massive fire is what looks like the head
of a dragon
the chanting and high Valeria continues
to get louder and louder as the fire
keeps reaching higher and higher into
the sky the fire is beginning to burn so
hot the army of slave soldiers has to
take a step forward to move away from
its heat one of the men in the red robes
faints falling to the ground as soon as
his body hits the ground his hood falls
back revealing his face we can see his
eyes are rolled back in his head with
blackened blood running out of his nose
suddenly all of the high-ranking members
of relore Falls silent right as everyone
in the crowd begins looking at each
other wondering what just happened they
hear a sound unlike anything they have
ever heard before it is the sound of a
dragon its screeches so loud everyone
gathered outside now has to Shield their
ears those who were once frightened now
have a look of Happiness as a shadow of
very large Wings flies over their face
the dragon slams down right on top of
the red Temple of her lore as it lets
out another thunderous scream
the dragon flaps its wings again then
lifts off the top of the building now
Landing Below in front of the main
entrance where the members in the red
robes are gathered in a circle by the
large fire we see it as drogon who
gently lays dany's body down on the
ground someone in a red robe begins
walking forward over to her body when
they're standing over dany's lifeless
body they remove their Hood revealing
who they are the scene ends as we see a
smiling canvara looked down at Daenerys
in the following scene we are back in
Winterfell only now we're down below in
its Crips we can see there are men and
women working down here as well they are
doing everything they can to restore it
to what it once was we can also see
several men Wheeling down a new Statue
of Ned Stark as you all know most of the
statues were shattered on the main level
during the battle in Winterfell not all
of them were broke due to the dead
breaking out of them however some of
them were simply knocked over and
smashed from everyone running around
down here trying to flee from the attack
it does look like most of the crypt has
been fixed now we begin to follow sons
of Stark and their maester as they walk
further into the Crypt Sansa says it
feels strange being down here again I
usually don't go any further than my
father and Aunt statues it has been many
years since I have went this far my
sister and all my brothers loved hiding
down here when they were little I hated
whenever they would ask me to join them
in a game of monsters and maidens or
comment to my castle I was always so
afraid of wandering around these lower
levels don't you worry your grace there
are guards all over this Castle ready
and willing to die for you we're almost
there now it's just up ahead says the
maester it's beginning to get colder and
colder as they walk further and further
into the Crypt there aren't as many
candles down here either on the main
level there are several candles at each
statue but down here there is maybe one
for every other Statue the faces on the
statues are also beginning to look more
and more Stern as they go deeper into
the cavernous Vault finally Sansa is
able to see a few of their men standing
just up ahead when she reaches them she
says what's wrong why did you have me
come all the way down here we are sorry
your grace but we needed to ask you a
question when does it end said one of
the men when does what end as Sansa the
Crypt Your Grace we have been down here
working for nearly a fortnight we wasn't
sure how far we should go because it
doesn't seem to to end well the statues
end but the Crypt does not do you know
how far it goes or where it leads said
one of the men my father always said
there are many many levels down here but
I've only been on a few when I was
younger he would never allow any of us
to go to its deepest level as soon as
you reach that you won't be able to go
any further anyway because he always
said the ceiling was collapsed down
there we found the collapsed ceiling six
days ago your grace we had several men
remove some of the large Stones then we
dug out the rest that is where the
statues end the last few days we have
sent men further than that they say the
entire ground is frozen once you go
deeper into the darkness it doesn't seem
to end your grace Sansa says I don't
know no one has ever gone that far
before not even my father the maester
says I will look at all the records
maybe there is some mention of it there
is one other thing Your Grace said one
of the Stark men there are drawings down
here on the wall they look old mayhem's
thousands of years old drawings of what
says Sansa this scene ends as the man
says it would be best if you had to look
for yourself your grace
in the next scene we are back out Beyond
the Wall we're not exactly sure where
this is because everything out Beyond
the Wall almost looks the same the one
thing we will recognize is the werewood
it might even be the same location where
bran Hodor Mira and jojin stopped once
before we spend a few moments as we
watch some of the wildlings set up their
camp for the night some of the wildlings
are also skinning animals for later Jon
Snow makes a large fire for everyone to
gather around then he takes his seat
right in front of the werewood Leaning
his head back against it everyone looks
like they're in good spirits the
children fall asleep almost immediately
while the adults break out the good ale
for a night cap John says you know this
might be the first time I will be able
to sleep out Beyond the Wall without
having to worry about being killed in my
sleep torm and giant Spain laughs then
says if you don't hand over that drink
you won't have to worry about anything
ever again now they're both laughing you
know I'm glad you're here with us know
but we have some long days ahead of us
we should all get some rest while we
still can everyone begins muttering as
they walk away from the fire John says
you're right as soon as I finish this
drink Jon takes another big gulp of his
ale then leans his head back against the
werewood as he closes his eyes we see
everyone else getting under their Furs
around the fire we see ghosts snuggled
up right next to John's feet the
reflection of the fire is glowing inside
his red eyes now we see Jon again who
looks like he's already fallen asleep as
we look around the fire everything
slowly Fades to black but only for a few
moments we suddenly hear the sound of a
soft old voice that says look for me as
we see an image of the massive werewood
above the three-eyed Ravens cave
look for me
only it's not his voice it's the voice
of someone else now we see the night
King on his horse holding the baby while
they're heading to the ice castle and
the lands of always winter we see Jon
reuniting with Bran Stark we hear John
say look at you you're a man then we
hear bran say almost
look at you
you're a man
almost
we see John again but now he's bending
his knee in front of bran he says I'm
sorry I wasn't there when you needed me
brain says you were exactly where you
were supposed to be
I'm sorry I wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
we see the mass of where what above the
cave again we see the night King's
creation we see Arya stabbed the night
King with her dagger we see bran in the
old throne room of the red keep speaking
to a man we have never seen before the
man has a hideous looking scar on his
face now we see Daenerys burning
everything in King's Landing then the
scene Fades to Black again the very last
thing we see is a massive fire burning
was smoke all around it after only a few
seconds the fire goes out we see a
silhouette standing within the smoke as
the silhouette steps out from the smoke
we can see their nude with a large stab
wound in their chest when they lift up
their head we can see it's Danny
stepping out from the smoke Jon Snow's
eyes fly back open as he begins gasping
for breath everyone who was sleeping
around their campfire is now awake
holding a weapon in their hand wondering
what's happening the scene ends as Jon
looks over at tormund horrified okay now
before before I go to my final scene in
the episode let me just explain one
thing some of you might be wondering how
this happened to John he was able to see
all of these different things because he
fell asleep while his head was laying
against the werewood now what I did was
very different but something like this
does happen in the book Jaime Lannister
has a very strange dream while he's
laying his head on a werewood stump
Johns was different he's in the north
out Beyond the Wall this where wood
hasn't been cut down like the one Jaime
fell asleep on not only that but Jon
also has the blood of the first men as
well as a direct connection to Bran
Stark who has won with the werewood net
now I don't want to explain any more
than that otherwise I might reveal too
much information right now just make
sure you remember all the things he saw
from my final scene in the episode we
are out at Sea on one of the Stark ships
we can see men working around the ship
grabbing ropes moving the sails carrying
things and much more we will see arya's
Stark emerged from below the ship with a
man who looks like he might be the
captain we hear them discussing the
route she wants to take as they move
west the man says it has been days since
we left sunspear my lady we will have
nothing but the summer sea ahead of us
before we see the arbor good caesaria I
can't wait to leave Westeros behind me
the Man tips his hat then walks away we
follow Arya back below the deck as she
heads for the main cabin as soon as she
enters she shuts the door behind her at
first she doesn't notice there is a man
standing behind her door in the shadow
we're not able to see his face but we
see the light glimmer off his small
dagger when the door shuts he slides the
boat over locking them inside the room
Arya hears the bolt lock shut as soon as
she spins around to see what it was she
sees the man is already lunging at her
they both fall down to the floor as they
struggle for control of the man's dagger
Arya finally gets a glimpse of the man's
face but it doesn't look like she
recognizes is who it is it's obvious
this isn't the Man's first fight Arya
isn't able to gain control of the
situation as fast as she'd like what she
does notice is he has a nasty looking
scar that stretches across both sides of
his face after rolling around on the
ground for a while Arya finally subdues
the man's arm that's holding the dagger
while she uses her other hand to free
her own Dagger from its sheath Arya now
has the man in full Mount holding his
arms down under her knees she brings her
own dagger up to the man's throat
demanding to know who he is the man
doesn't answer Arya shoves her dagger
into his neck just far enough to get him
bleeding Arya then says I will let you
live if you tell me who sent you the man
still doesn't answer she shoves her
dagger into his neck a little further
while also using her other hand to apply
pressure to his throat who sent you the
man is now gurgling there is some blood
coming out of his mouth who sent you she
says again while struggling to breathe
the man's says it was the king
Arya is stunned she lets go with the
man's throat he immediately grabs at it
while gasping for air Arya can't believe
what she just heard it feels like her
head is spinning why would my brother
want me dead Arya says she looks down at
the man shocked almost as if she forgot
what just happened he says let me up you
said you would let me live Arya slowly
gets up feeling somewhat dizzy
she says it again why would my brother
want me dead
I don't understand the man stands back
up then heads for the door before he can
grab the handle Arya spends him back
around then slashes his throat Arya just
stands there for a few moments still
stunned by what the man said she drops
her blood-soaked dagger to the floor the
episode ends as it focuses on the
Valerian steel dagger
the first scene of the second episode
begins in the middle of the night we can
see there is what looks like seven men
walking along the beach away from their
ship six of these men are holding
something very large as they slowly
shift their feet across the sand we
follow them for a few moments before
they finally walk under the full
Moonlight allowing us to see who they
are and what they're holding these men
are all dressed in their unsolid
uniforms the six men are holding a
casket as they are following gray worm
who approaches another man waiting for
them at the end of the beach this
Unknown man also has several men of his
own standing behind him as greywar moves
forward the unknown man raises one of
his hands signaling for them to stop
greyworm and his men ignore the request
the man then shouts out what business do
you gentlemen have on the island of
North Gray worm Waits until he is
standing right before him then then says
fulfilling a promise the other unsullied
Men set the casket down in the sand gray
worm looks at it and says this is
misande this is her home this is where
she would want to be this is where she
belongs the unknown man says missande is
not a name we are familiar with who was
she greyworm looks back down at the
casket and says My One True Love
the unknown man says I see well in that
case allow me and my men to help you we
shall lay masande of north at rest
during the following dusk follow me
there is somewhere you must stay while
you're here gray worms men grab the
casket then lift it back up from the
sand they began following the men over
to a small building made out of stone
when they reach the building the unknown
man swings the door open and says this
is where you and your men must stay for
the evening gray worm examines the small
Stone structure he notices there aren't
any Windows he also notices there is
only one door and this door opens only
from the outside greyworm says what is
it why do we stay in this the man says
this is our shelter for our special
visitors greyworm has a confused look on
his face he says shelter a shelter from
what the man smiles and says you're not
very familiar with the island of North
are you there are over a hundred
different kinds of butterflies on this
island and they're the only thing that
stop soldiers like you from slaughtering
or enslaving everyone that inhabits it
we are not known for our skill on the
battlefield but the butterflies are the
messengers of Our Lord you're lucky you
and your men arrived here at nightfall
you must stay in this shelter until you
hear a knock on the door if this door
opens while the sun is in the sky we
will be needing more caskets on the
morrow you understand gray worm nods his
head then him and his men step inside in
the following scene we are back out
beyond the wall where the wildlings had
settled for the night everyone is now
awake gathered around the fire looking
at Jon Snow who is still sitting beneath
the werewood Jon looks visibly shaken as
he takes another long sip of his ale
ghost is now sitting next to Jon the
albino direwolf is glaring into the eyes
of the werewood we can still see the
reflection of the fire in his own
glowing red eyes Ghost and the werewood
have a striking resemblance they're both
white as bone with eyes as red as blood
some of the wildlings look frightened
when they notice the hair is standing up
on the direwolf's back as he begins
sniffing the ground around the werewood
Jon Snow finally looks back at the
werewood himself wondering if what he
saw when he closed his eyes was real or
only a dream as Jon focuses on the
werewood he notices something red is
running out of its eyes it almost looks
as if it's blood he looks away when he
sees tormen as walking over with morale
he sits down next to Jon then fills his
cup back up what's wrong snow did that
Dragon Lady of yours come back to kill
you in your sleep said tormen who now
has a smirk on his face Jon doesn't find
that amusing he says maybe she is before
he takes another long drink of his ale
torman throws his arm around Jon's
shoulder then says you have nothing to
fear snow my dreams have been haunting
me for years none of my enemies have
ever killed me when I'm awake Jon
doesn't respond right away he looks Into
the Fire for a few moments then says
this wasn't a normal dream something
felt different about it I Heard a Voice
Now tormund takes a big gulp of his own
ale and says half of the wildlings here
have voices in their heads now what of
it I'm serious says Jon it wasn't my
voice that I heard a wildling woman
suddenly stands up then walks over to
sit down next to them she looks at John
and says I would like to know what the
voice said well says John it said look
for me did you hear anything else what
did you see said the wildling woman John
looks over at the werewood again then
says I saw that only this one was bigger
much bigger it looked like it was out
here somewhere beyond the wall the where
would set on a hill overlooking the
snow-covered ground the wildling woman
Smiles as she says I know where that is
I have seen it before good says John
make sure everyone is ready at dawn you
will lead the way the woman stands up
then gives a nod in agreement before she
walks away Jon now looks over at ghost
who is still sniffing around at the
ground under the werewood he kneels down
beside him as he runs his fingers
through his white fur Jon examines the
ground looking for whatever it is that
ghosts can smell he doesn't see anything
but dirt and leaves but he suddenly
notices the same thing ghost does John's
eyes go wider as he looks over at
tormund do you smell that says John the
only thing I can smell is this Burning
Fire says torman who now walks over by
Jon and ghost he also watches ghost as
he sniffs around at the ground what does
he smell snow I don't see anything Jon
looks back at the wirewood and stares
into its blood red eyes this scene ends
when Jon says it smells like death
in this next scene we are back in
Winterfell below the castle and its
Crypt We are following Sansa the maester
and a few of the Stark men as they head
further and further down into the
darkness the look of fear can be seen on
sansa's face she has never gone this far
before the faces on the statues are of
men she does not recognize the dead
Starks look meaner and meaner the deeper
they go we're almost there your grace
the statues end just right up ahead said
one of the Stark Guardsmen we can start
to see where this level of the crypt was
once blocked off by the Fallen Rubble
there are large stones and mounds of
dirt stacked up along the side of the
wall where the Stark Guardsmen had moved
it when they reached the last statue
Sansa stops right in front of it she
says this is the farthest any Stark I
know has ever gone my father said it had
been blocked off for many years even
before he was born Sansa holds up her
light as she looks around the cavernous
Vault this isn't only where the statues
in your grace this is where the candles
and and the stone ends as well said the
Stark Guardsmen what do you mean this is
where the Stone's end said Sansa
thousands and thousands of stones were
set down here all throughout the ceiling
and the walls to stop everything from
collapsing in on itself whoever made
this [ __ ] stopped here this is as low as
it goes this is where the stones end
said the star Guardsmen Sansa looks at
the last statue then says maybe it was
him she holds her light over the statue
as she looks at its face Sansa is
suddenly startled by what she sees the
statue's face seems oddly familiar but
there is something unsettling about it
as well Sansa feels as if its eyes are
looking through her into her soul the
front of this statue looks like it's in
Fairly good shape considering how old it
must be however some of it is missing
the entire back half of the statue is
now gone Sansa forces herself to look
away we can now see there is a name
engraved into the bottom of the statue
it says Brandon Stark and right below
the name It also says the king of winter
Sansa grabbed something that was laying
across his lap she holds it up into the
light for them to see it's the handle
from a very very old sword sanza says my
father always used to say swords were
laid across the laps of each statue to
help keep the vengeful Spirits locked
within the Crypt the iron from this one
must have rusted away many years ago I'm
not sure it would be of any use now she
drops the broken handle onto the ground
then walks forward the Stark Guardsman
holds up his light Illuminating what
lies ahead he says the drawings we found
are right this way your grace Sansa
looks down into the dark abyss whoever
made the underground passage Must Have
Spent years digging it out you really
can't see much ahead but it looks like
it goes on for as far as the eyes can
see Sansa says is it safe you said there
are no stones in here supporting it from
falling in what if it collapses while
we're in there I wouldn't worry about
that your grace the walls and ceiling
feel Rock Solid everything moving
forward is frozen Sansa the maester and
the Stark Guardsmen move ahead the scene
ends as they begin fading away into the
darkness in the following scene we are
back in King's Landing the sound of
Steel hitting steel can be hard from
inside the red key we see swords Clash
then spring apart then Clash again as
Brienne and Podrick dance across the map
of Westeros on the floor Brienne moves
to the right but Podrick blocks her with
a quick sidestep and drives her back the
other way Brienne now grabs the sword
with both hands then rushes forward
aggressively she brings the sword up
over her head then brought it back down
hard and fast as Podrick began to
backpedal he brings up his own sword but
her blow easily knocks it away he sucks
in a deep breath then charges ahead this
sent Brienne staggering as she went
railing on her heels she raises her
sword but Podrick knocked it away then
slashed at her again
as Brienne regains her footing Padre
lifted his sword high above his head but
he suddenly brings it back down again
when he notices Samoa is in the room
watching them Sam is looking at them
with a big grin across his face holding
a book in his hands Sam says you know
from over here it looked like he was
winning that makes Podrick smile from
ear to ear Brienne looks annoyed and out
of breath she says he wasn't winning I
was only giving him a chance to know
what that feels like he's good but he's
not that good Sam then says well when he
does finally beat you you will only have
yourselves to blame I agree says Berean
he got all those moves for me Sam then
says I am looking for King bran there is
something he should see he's in his
Chambers right now says Brienne follow
me I will take you to him Sam Smiles
then gives a head nod we follow Sam and
bran as they walk across the painted map
on the floor the attack from Daenerys
and drogon has still left a large crack
on the floor splitting Westeros in half
when they each what was once the stairs
that lead to the king's Chambers we can
see they are now smooth in the fashion
of a ramp this makes it easier for them
to maneuver brain around the castle when
Sam and Berean reach the door she knocks
loudly before she says your grace bran
doesn't answer bran knocks again then
again louder than before there's still
no answer your grace is everything all
right says Sam there is no sound coming
from inside the chambers Brienne now
looks worried so she opens the door
herself they see bran is sitting there
in silence facing the fire in the Hearth
his head is leaning back slightly with
his eyes rolled back when he hears them
in the room his head snaps forward and
his eyes roll back down I'm sorry for
barging in here like this your grace but
I thought something was wrong bran looks
over at them acknowledging that they're
there but he looks back at the fire
without saying anything Sam walks across
the room while still holding the book in
his hands he sits down next to Brian and
says the there is something I wanted to
show you your grace he holds out the
book so Brian can see it Sam says I
found this book on the legends of the
long night while I was at the Citadel at
first I didn't think it had any useful
information but I noticed something
interesting on the front of it I was
hoping I could find out its origin I've
already wrote a letter to the Citadel
asking them if they know how old it is
and where it's from or who wrote it
would you be able to help me your grace
Sam holds the book out even further here
look for yourself what do you think your
grace bran finally looks down at the
book he grabs it from Sam's hands then
studies the image on its cover he looks
at it for a few moments but then he
starts running his finger along the book
outlining the skeleton looking figure on
the front does that look familiar Your
Grace do you see the dagger in its hand
bran still doesn't say anything Sam
looks back at Berean somewhat confused
bran looks like he's in deep thought as
he runs his finger along the dagger on
the book Samson says what do you think
your grace is there anything you can
tell me after a few more moments of
Silence bran now looks up at Sam with
his glaring eyes bran says no then he
throws the book in the fire
Sam and Brienne are shocked they know
Brian was a little strange but they've
never seen him show any signs of
aggression before Sam looks Into the
Fire horrified as he watches the book
Burn the skeleton looking figure on the
front of the book gets consumed by the
Flames why would you do that your grace
that book wasn't mine it belongs to the
Citadel it might have been their only
records of the long night bran doesn't
say anything right away he just sits
there watching as what's left of the
book disappears into the flames and
smoke Brienne steps forward and says are
you okay your grace bran looks at both
of them then says you said it yourself
Sam that bulk had no useful information
but your grace that was until I saw bran
doesn't let him finish his sentence
because he suddenly says that will be
all for now I would like to be left
alone you are dismissed
Brianne and Sam look at each other they
are stunned by what just happened the
scene ends as they're walking out of the
room in the following scene we are back
out at Sea on one of the hell Stark's
ships the scene opens up below the deck
in its main cabin
the dead man who was sent to kill Arya
is still laying on the floor surrounded
by dried blood Arya Stark is standing
over his body she's discussing what
happened with roughly a dozen Stark men
as well as the captain and others who
work on the ship do any of you recognize
this man do any of you know his name do
any of you know how long he has been
with us get a good look at him he has a
very distinctive scar across his face
surely someone must know who he is all
eyes are now on the dead man laying on
the floor
now that Arya is getting a good look at
the man she notices he's much older than
he first appeared to be most of the hair
on his head and face is gray although he
is larger than Arya he looks frail he
looks like he might be 60 years old the
captain says I do not recognize him my
lady I am responsible for every man and
woman who board this ship yet I don't
remember ever seeing this man a few of
the Stark men speak up as well each of
them say they don't know who the man is
either Arya shakes her head still
somewhat in denial of the circumstances
what did he want my lady says the
captain did he say anything Arya says he
wanted me dead he was hiding behind my
door waiting for me to be alone he said
ah
Arya takes a deep breath then exhales
before she finishes her sentence he said
my brother Brian sent him here to kill
me
one of the Stark men spits on the dead
man's body then says I'm sorry my lady
the man is a liar why would your own
brother or King want you dead it doesn't
make any sense I know caesaria I don't
want to believe it myself the captain
then says maybe someone else sent him
who else would want you dead do you have
any other enemies my lady with a slight
smark on her face Arya says they're all
dead my sister Sanja said bran sees
things now he has Visions he knows
things he's not the same brother I grew
up with he's different now but I still
don't think he would want me dead the
captain says what should we do now my
lady Arya says I need to speak with my
brother right away I have to find out
what's happening
should we stop somewhere soon and send a
raven my lady said the captain Arya
shakes her head and says no I don't want
anyone in King's Landing knowing what
happened on this ship not yet if my
brother bran really does want me dead I
don't want him to know I'm on my way
back the captain nods has had an
agreement then says very well my lady no
Ravens he looks down at the dead body on
the floor and says what do you want us
to do with him Arya says throw his body
into the sea the fish can feed on him
four of the Stark men left the lifeless
body from the floor each of them are
holding either an arm or a leg we follow
them out of the cabin and down the
hallway until they reach the main deck
the men swing his body up onto the
railing then they roll him off the ship
into the sea below they stand there
watching and waiting for a moment until
they see the man's body fully submerge
under the water the men walk away back
below the deck we now see one of how
Stark's banners flapping in the wind
high up on ship right before the scene
ends a raven lands on the Stark Banner
its eyes are as black as obsidian but
then we see them flash white then black
again
in the next scene we are back out Beyond
the Wall We are following Jon Ghost and
the group of wildlings as they are now
heading out further north through the
haunted forest the wildling woman is now
riding on the back of John's horse as
she guides them to the mess of where
wood he saw while he was sleeping as
they're moving through the forest John
looks over at tormund who is only a few
feet away on his horse and says you were
right about what you said back there
right about what says stormin about
Daenerys coming back to kill me John
said the werewood wasn't the only thing
I saw while I was sleeping I did see
Daenerys in my dream
she was inside a massive fire just
standing there with a hole in her chest
it felt as if she was looking right at
me dreams are a funny thing snow some
folks say they've had dreams of all of
us living inside the blue eye of a giant
named macumber says tormund they don't
mean anything the wildling woman says I
have had dreams of me flying on the back
of an eagle maybe you're right says John
maybe it doesn't mean anything this
didn't feel like only a dream though it
felt like something else you said you
stabbed her in the heart you said you
saw her die then her Dragon left with
her body I bet she was dropped out at
Sea says tormund John looks over at him
again and says that doesn't mean
anything either you and I both know that
dead don't always stay dead the night
King raised the dead by the thousands
Jon then sets his hand over his own
chest and says I was also stabbed in the
heart yet here I am we watch as Jon
Ghost and the wildlings continue to move
forward deeper into the haunted forest
we then see a raven circling around in
the sky just up ahead right before the
scene ends in the following scene we are
back in Winterfell below the castle in
its Crypt Sansa the maester and the star
Guardsmen are still walking further into
the Crypt into the dark abyss their
flickering light is Illuminating the
walkway we can see the ground is frozen
there are icicles and ice crystals
hanging down from the ceiling we can
also see what looks like white and red
veins running along the ceiling when
Sansa notices them she says what are
those the maester says those are the
roots of the werewood Your Grace the
drawings are right up ahead said the
star Guardsmen about 100 feet in front
of them there are three more Stark
Guardsmen holding candles in their hands
as they examine all the drawings on the
wall when they finally reach the three
Stark men one of them says we are sorry
you had to come all the way down here
your grace but we knew you would want to
see this for yourself Sansa raises her
arm to hold her light up near the wall
we watch as our eyes scan back and forth
studying each of the images we see Sansa
taking a deep breath when she notices
something that does look familiar the
first drawing shows a castle that looks
sort of like Winterfell only smaller
than what it is now there is also a man
in front of that castle who looks very
similar to the statue in the Crypt Sansa
says that looks like Brandon Stark the
old king of Winter the Maestra says I
think you're right your grace he does
have a striking resemblance to the
Statue right next to this is another
drawing of a large werewood with a man
in front of it surrounded by what looks
like a dozen members of the children of
the forest there is another drawing next
to that this one shows one child of the
forest shaking hands with what looks
like the night King only this one has a
beard like the one we saw on Dragonstone
the next drawing shows a very large
Grove of where Woods all in a circle
facing inward in the center of this
large Grove of where Woods is another
werewood only this one is much bigger
than the rest it looks like it might be
the biggest werewood in Westeros now
this next drawing shows a beheading
there is one member of the children of
the forest who looks very old he has
long white hair with a very long white
beard in his hand he is holding the head
of what looks like another member of the
children of the forest Sansa holds her
light up higher then moves it along the
wall a little further there is one final
drawing on the wall this one shows a
skeleton looking figure holding what
looks like a nice sword in one hand with
a dagger in its other Sansa lets out
another deep breath it's so cold down
here you can see the Mist in the air as
she exhales I don't know what these mean
says Sansa she looks at everyone else
standing there and says do any of you
know what these are I'm sorry your grace
but we do not says one of the star
Guardsmen the maester says do any of
your men know how to draw I'm sure we
can find someone who can said the Stark
Guardsman why I want someone to make a
sketch of these images I will send it to
the Citadel maybe they can decipher the
drawings there said the maester Sansa
looks at the maester and says do you
understand any of these have you seen
any of these drawings before the maester
lifts his arm and holds his finger out
to one of the images he says that one
Your Grace the large werewood surrounded
by The werewood Grove there is only one
location in Westeros that I know of that
would have a werewood of that size the
scene ends right as Sansa says where now
in my final scene of this episode we are
back across the narrow sea in essos in
the city of Atlantis the sun is just now
beginning to set as we see an even
larger crowd gather below the red Temple
of Allure the streets of the city are
now flooded with thousands of followers
of the Lord of Light drogon is sitting
Atop The Building overlooking everyone
below
the dragon lets out another thunderous
Scream It's equally exciting and
frightening because everyone knows that
they are witnessing a historic event the
high-ranking members of relore who are
all still dressed in the red robes are
all gathered in a circle around
daenerys's body they have her laid out
across a stone block in front of the
massive Brazier they're all chanting
something in high Valeria their chanting
grows louder and louder as dark clouds
begin to form in the sky above everyone
in the crowd Ducks down when they hear a
ear splitting crack of thunder in the
distance violent flashes of lightning
begin emerging in the sky the crowd
below grows frantic as the chanting gets
louder and the storm above grows
stronger the ruby necklace on kinvara's
neck is glowing so red hot it starts
burning the symbol into her skin a red
bolt of lightning strikes down into the
middle of the Brazier which causes a
small fire to begin burning inside of it
again
suddenly the chanting stops all of the
high-ranking members of relore remove
their hoods then they take a step
forward all of them reach their hands
under daenerys's body then lift her up
into the sky they walk over to the
burning Brazier the crowd below erupts
into chaos when they realize what's
about to happen daenerys's lifeless body
is thrown into the Flames now all of the
red robes Gather in a circle around the
Brazier they remove their necklaces then
throw them inside we watch as the rubies
burst open into a red liquid that almost
looks like Blood Fire and Blood the
small Flames are now several different
shades of red and orange kenvara looks
up at drogon her eyes are now glowing
red as well in a loud voice kenvara
shouts dracares drogon spreads his wings
and lets out another deafening Scream
the fire unleashes from his mouth into
the Brazier below there are men and
women in the crowd who are Weeping with
Joy the Flames reach high into the air
as they are licking at the night sky the
storm begins to settle as the clouds
begin to move they reveal there was a
full moon hiding behind them a Blood
Moon everyone is now staring into the
fire the reflection of the Flames can be
seen in canvara's glowing red eyes
everything is silent except for the
crackling of the fire suddenly we hear
the sound of thousands gasping for air
as they see a black silhouette emerge in
the Flames as the fire dies down we can
see a nude body standing in the center
of the Brazier there is a large stab
wound in their chest there is some black
smoke rising out of it the episode ends
as Daenerys emerges Through the flames
and smoke
the first thing we see is a glimpse of
the night King's creation as Leaf
inserts the dragon glass dagger into the
man's chest then we're back inside to
three-eyed Raven's cave this was when
bran realized the night King was made by
the children of the forest we will once
again hear why they did this Leaf says
they were at War they were being
slaughtered and their sacred werewood
trees were being cut down now this is
usually when the scene ends but now we
get to hear what else was said during
the flashback after Lee said why they
created the night King the three-eyed
Raven then says
fearing Extinction the children combine
their powers for one last spell that
would save their people and their land
from the Invaders by themselves the
children were too few to resist the
onslaught
but if they could turn men's numbers
against them
now we flash to something else we see
the night King standing in what looks
like a crypt while holding a newborn
baby boy the night King is then seen
handing this baby to a child of the
forest this child of the forest is one
we have never seen before we watch it as
it walks away from the night King now
holding the baby until they fade away
into the darkness now we flash to
something else we hear the Mad King say
burn them all as we see Daenerys burning
down King's Landing
burn them all
then we see Brian Stark the moment he
becomes the new king of Westeros we hear
him say why do you think I came all this
way
you wear the crown
why do you think I came all this way
[Music]
now we flash to something else we see a
man who looks sort of like the same man
who became the night King only this man
is standing in front of a castle as it's
being built gathered around this man is
a few members of the children of the
forest ones we have never seen before it
looks like they are helping this man
build the castle now we flash back to
the three odd Ravens cave we see Brian
sitting there as the three odd Raven
goes into more details about the first
men of Westeros the children of the
forest and why they made the night King
after hundreds of years and Untold death
and destruction the wisest heads of the
children and the first men finally
prevailed
the children couldn't win this war and
the first men didn't want to win fearing
the costs of Victory Heroes and rulers
on both sides met upon an Isle in the
God's eye to form the back
now we flash to something else we see a
massive werewood surrounded by what
looks like a Grove of more where Woods
all facing inward the massive wearwood
in the center has an enormous face
carved into it the face on this where
wood is so enormous we actually see its
mouth open and when that happens a child
of the forest walks out of it this
unknown child of the forest is holding a
newborn baby that has bright blue eyes
now we flash to something else we see
Arya Stark as she is standing in front
of Jack and agar we hear Arya say Valar
morghulis
foreign
now we flash to something else we see a
few men with very long beards standing
in the forest they are chopping down a
giant wirewood then throwing its
branches into a fire as the where wood
burns in the fire the crackling in the
flame sounds like the screams of a
thousand children dying When the Smoke
Rises up from the fire we see it form
the shape of what looks like the face on
a werewood but none of the men standing
there seem to notice it now we flash to
something else we see the massive
werewood again surrounded by what looks
like a Grove of more were Woods all
facing inward there are seven members of
the children of the forest all standing
in a circle around the giant werewood
they're all watching as one of their
Elders who has long white hair with a
very long white beard walk forward he
stops when he is standing in front of
another child of the forest who is
kneeling in front of the werewood we see
this elder behead the kneeling child of
the forest the lifeless body falls to
the ground but the Elder is still
holding the head by its hair we see the
enormous mouth on the where would open
up the Elder member of the children
throws the head inside the mouth right
before it shuts now we flash back to the
three-eyed Raven's cave we see Brian
sitting there as the three-eyed Raven
goes into more details about the first
men of Westeros the children of the
forest and why they made the night King
children gave up to all the lands of
Westeros save for the Deep forests and
the first men swore that they would no
longer cut down the werewoods
thus ended the dawn age
can
yet after the dawn must come the night
great evil that the children unleash
returned centuries later now we flash to
something else we see the massive
werewood again surrounded by what looks
like a Grove of more were Woods all
facing inward only now we see what looks
like the shadow of a dragon flying over
the were woods now we flash back to the
three-eyed Raven's cave we see
brainstark sitting there as the
three-eyed Raven goes into more details
about the first men of Westeros the
children of the forest and why they made
the night King
the great evil that the children
Unleashed in the war returned centuries
later and only an alliance between the
children and Men defeated it
now it comes again
when the children are a shadow of what
they were
and Men
are long forgot
forgot but the trees remember
and Brandon's Stark must learn
or as we watched the first men
so we will watch The Lost
[Music]
everything now Fades to Black Bran Stark
snaps out of his Visions gasping for
breath he looks over his shoulder at the
door worried someone might have walked
in while he was gone
there's no one there as he slows down
his heavy breathing he looks down and
notices both of his hands have a firm
grip on his chair these are the most
intense Visions he's ever had bran
finally begins to gain his composure as
he gazes into the fire in front of him
we can see there is a note Laying across
brain's lap most likely something he was
reading before he went into the Visions
as brain lifts it back up we get a
glimpse of it we can see it has the
broken seal of Hal Stark we're not able
to make out what it says but we do see
there are some rough sketches of a few
different images one of the drawing
shows what looks like a beheading as
well as a very large wearwood surrounded
by other were Woods before we can see
anything else bran crumbles up the note
in his fist then throws it in the fire
now we see the opening credits and the
theme song
like with all of my flashback scenes
they foreshadow some of the major events
that will happen in future episodes the
flashbacks have answers to some of Game
of Thrones greatest Mysteries which will
be revealed by the end of my season so I
hope all of you are digesting all of
this information
after the opening credits are over we go
to our next scene in the episode we're
back across the narrow sea in volantis
there are still thousands and thousands
of people gathered Below in the city
streets the red Temple of Allure sits
high on its Hill looming above all those
who worship its Lord of Light kinvara as
well as the other high-ranking members
of velor are dressed in their red robes
standing in front of the massive doors
to the main entrance all of their eyes
are locked on Daenerys Targaryen as she
steps out of the enormous Brazier the
bottom of her feet are now blackened
with ash gray and black smoke can be
seen rolling out of the large stab wound
on her chest Daenerys looks up at drogon
who is still sitting Atop The Red tempo
of her lore when Dragon looks into our
now opened eyes he lets out a scream
that can only be described as a cry of
ecstasy in anguish the sound of her
Dragon makes Daenerys fall to her knees
kenvara rushes over and throws her red
robe around on daenerys's naked body
kenvara slowly helps her back on her
feet she says walk with me Daenerys
Stormborn we should speak inside four
men who are also wearing the red robes
opened the massive doors that have the
burning Hearts engraved on the front of
them the red Temple of velor opens up to
a great hall of its own there are over
100 different braziers burning inside
lining all four of the walls there is
also a very large Burning Heart hanging
down from the ceiling in the center of
the Great Hall kenvara helps Daenerys
sit down on a stone bench inside what do
you remember Daenerys Stormborn do you
know where you are do you remember what
happened Daenerys glances around the
Great Hall but nothing stands out to her
none of this looks familiar
she then looks down at the large stab
wound in her chest her eyes begin
filling up with water as she remembers
Daenerys says I was murdered by Jon Snow
the man I loved and who I thought loved
me
that's right says canvara you and Jon
Snow were brought together for a reason
you were brought together to fight
against the great other but you allowed
yourself to be consumed by not only the
force you have while you're on the back
of your dragon but the fear you have in
your heart the fear of losing what power
you still have
I don't know what happened says Daenerys
I mean I remember what happened but I
don't know why
it felt like something evil was inside
me I never wanted things to end like
this but it was as if I could not stop
it from happening as if something was
moving me in that direction it felt like
something had its grip on me and would
not let go
the Lord of Light has brought you back
just as the Lord of Light brought back
Jon Snow says canvara you have been
reborn in the great flames of relore his
fire has clenged your soul Daenerys
Stormborn now you must never lose sight
again you once said you wanted to leave
the world better than you found it now
you have another opportunity to do that
neither of you know it yet but you and
Jon Snow still need each other no he
doesn't says Daenerys if he needed me he
wouldn't have murdered me the night King
and his army of the Dead have been
defeated Cersei Lannister is dead the
Iron Throne is for the taking I'm sure
Sansa Stark got exactly what she wanted
by naming Jon Snow the king kinvara says
well you are right about one thing
Daenerys Cersei Lannister and the night
King are dead but you haven't defeated
all of our enemies the great other still
looms over Westeros threatening our very
existence what do you mean the great
other says Daenerys with a slight grin
on her face canvara says there is still
so much you don't know Daenerys
Stormborn did Bran Stark ever say who
made the night King I don't believe he
did says Daenerys kenvara helps Daenerys
back on her feet she walks her over to
one of the burning braziers kenvara
glares Into the Fire and she says like I
was saying you may have defeated the
night King and his army of the dead but
they weren't working alone they have
never worked alone Daenerys has a
confused look on her face when she says
Melisandre never said this why wouldn't
she warn us about other threats kenvara
says Melisandre was but one small
instrument of the Lord of Light there
was only so much he could do when
Melisandre lost her faith she lost her
ability to see everything that lies
ahead the Flames only gave her glimpses
but we can see far more Daenerys
Stormborn our faith has never wavered
and the Lord of blight has rewarded us
for that canvara looks deeper into the
Flames burning in the Brazier she brings
Daenerys in closer then says have a look
for yourself Daenerys looks into the
fire the reflection of the Flames is
glowing red in Orange in their eyes
canvara says do you see what I mean
Daenerys do you see what lies ahead this
is why you and Jon Snow still need each
other
Daenerys has a horrified look on her
face as she realizes what she is being
shown Daenerys says what do they want
the same thing they have wanted for
thousands of years says canvara
all men must die the scene ends right
after kinvara says this is why the new
king of Westeros has all of us worried
in the following scene we are back in
Winterfell Sansa Stark the maester and
several Lords and Ladies of the north
are all gathered below the castle in its
crypt the lowest level has been brought
back to life now that there are hundreds
of more candles lined up down here along
the walls Sansa Stark and the maester
are showing the Lords and Ladies their
recent discovery we hear Sansa Stark say
we weren't exactly sure what all of
these drawings were maester walcan had
sketches of these images drawn and sent
to the Citadel we're hoping they can
help us figure out what they are we are
expecting a response from them soon we
have also sent word to my brother bran
down in King's Landing he does have the
ability to see things others can't if
anyone will be able to shed some light
on their significance it will be him one
of the northern Lords says just how big
is this Crypt Your Grace it seems like
it goes on forever and ever well that's
just a thing says Sansa we don't know
one of our Guardsmen said he doesn't
know if there is an end we sent a few
more men ahead so we can see where the
underground passage leads the northern
Lord says you sent a few men down there
as he looks blindly into the darkness
that's only a hundred feet in front of
them they must be braver men than I am
your grace I wouldn't want to find out
what's on the other end I would have
sealed this back up immediately we may
do that says Sansa but not until we find
out how this got here she holds her
light up higher Illuminating the
drawings on the wall maester walcan says
this drawing of the large werewood
surrounded by The Grove of where Woods
is in the South near harrenhal do any of
you recognize what these other images
are the Northern Lords and Ladies study
the drawings for several minutes
examining them one by one this one Your
Grace I think I know what this one is
says the northern Lord that looks like
the children of the forest Your Grace
the drawing of the beheading are you
sure says Sansa why would the children
to another forests behead each other
Sansa looks at maester wulcan and then
says are you familiar with this story
the maester shakes his head back and
forth know your grace I am not there are
legends of the children of the forest
fighting with the Giants and going to
war against the first men but I don't
recall ever hearing anything about them
killing one another all records state
that after they fought the first men
their numbers were extremely low many
would say that's why they're no longer
around now and others would even say
they never existed at all I don't know
why they would be fighting each other
but if they did I suppose that wouldn't
make them that much different from us
your grace men have been fighting and
slaughtering each other for thousands of
years Sansa says I must speak with my
brother bran he will know what to make
of all this the scene ends after the
maester says if these drawings are
accurate Your Grace I fear of learning
what drove these small creatures to such
violence in the next scene we are back
on the island of noth there are roughly
100 men and women gathered on the beach
under the light of the full moon during
the end of missande's burial ceremony
most of the men standing on the beach
are gray worms men who are all still
dressed in their unsolid uniforms as is
gray worm there are some Island natives
that are attending the ceremony as well
as The Men Who greeted greyworm on the
beach the night he arrived everyone is
standing in a circle gathered around
masande's casket while holding a white
rose in their hands the smell of salt
water is thick in the air there is a man
that has brown skin and black hair
sitting next to the casket singing what
sounds like a very beautiful song in a
language we have never heard before
after the man finishes his song The
Unknown man who has been helping
greyworm walks over to him and says I am
sorry for your loss I did not know
missande of north but I am glad you
brought her back home she must have been
someone very special for you to bring
her all the way here from Westeros she
was and still is says gray worm I don't
know what I will do now that she is no
longer here with me I thought I would
stay here with her for the rest of our
lives but it will not be the same
without her I don't think the rest of
your men want to stay here says the
unknown man it wouldn't be very safe for
all of them either unless they all want
to squeeze into that shelter with you
that won't be necessary says gray worm
right over his shoulder we can see he
brought about one dozen ships with him
from Danny's Fleet the three-headed
dragon can still be seen on their
banners and sales the rest of greyworms
men are still on the ships waiting and
watching as the ceremony nears its end
well where will you and your men go next
says the unknown man gray worm looks out
across the summer sea and says I don't
know but we will be gone before the sun
rises have you ever been to volantis
says the unknown man it's not far from
here it's right on the other side of
this sea a few of our silk Traders just
arrived this morning I overheard them
discussing something they said they saw
while leaving volantis now the man was
drunk so I doubt he can be believed but
I heard him say he saw the shadow of
what he thought was a dragon flying over
the city as they were boarding their own
ship gray worm's eyes lock on his as he
grabs him by the arm a dragon says gray
worm are you sure that's what he saw the
unknown man says no I can't be sure
because I wasn't there with him but
that's what I heard one of them say the
man was drunk his words were a slurred
you know how men are they swear their
Journeys are far more dangerous than
they actually are I heard all of the
dragons are dead I doubt the man saw
what he says he saw gray worm lets go
with the man's arm he walks over to some
of the other unsolid men who are
standing on the beach greyworm says
drogon is across the sea in volantis get
our men in our ships ready we will be
leaving soon in the following scene we
are inside the Library of the Citadel
the arch maester ebros whoever saw
samwell's studies while he was there is
sitting alone at a desk reading a letter
we're not able to see who wrote the
letter or what it says but it was sent
from someone within the red keep of
King's Landing because it has the broken
seal of the three-eyed Raven after the
arch maester finishes reading the letter
he rolls it back up then slides it
inside his sleeve he stands up then
walks across the library to the other
side when he reaches the Gate of the
restricted area he sticks his hand
inside of his other sleeve then removes
the key the arch Master unlocks the gate
walks inside then shuts it and locks it
behind him the arch maester walks over
to the Bookshelf that sits along the
back wall in the middle of the Shelf
there is a book on where Woods when he
grabs this book it causes the whole
shelf to slide over revealing there is a
hidden room behind it even though
restricted area has a restricted area
when he steps inside the hidden room the
bookshelf slides back behind him there
is only one shell inside the hidden room
as well as what looks like a metal lock
box that has more books inside the
archmaester opens up the book about
where Woods then flips to the back where
another key is hidden he opens up the
lock box then removes the stack of books
the first book has an image on the front
of it it looks like a member of the
children of the forest standing next to
an unknown man right under that image it
says the origin of but we can't see what
it says after that because of the
artemaster sets another book down on top
of it on the front of the next book it
reads a detailed history of the Lord
commanders at Castle black the next book
The archmaester sits down has an image
of a werewood Grove on the front of it
this one says the Mysteries and legends
of the Isle of faces he sits down
another book that just says the birth of
dragons the next book says the works of
Brandon the Builder it looks like there
may be an image of Winterfell as well as
the Citadel on the front of it when
archimaster ebros grabs the next book he
has to wipe the dust off of it before he
can read it himself we don't get to see
what this one says but it must be what
he was looking for because he grabs the
other stack of box then locks them back
inside the small metal box he stands
back up while holding the book he wants
down at his side he walks over to the
wall then knocks on it three times this
makes the bookshelf slide back open
again allowing him to leave the hidden
room as we see him walk away the
bookshelf slams shut again ending the
scene in the next scene We are following
Samwell as he walks through the red keep
he walks across the old throne room
inside the Great Hall there is still a
massive hole in the side of the red keep
where drogon had blew out a hole in the
side of the building there is what looks
like over 100 Ravens walking around on
the floor sitting on different Ledges
and flying in and out of the Great Hall
Brian Stark has definitely made himself
at home Sam walks out of the old throne
room and we keep following him until he
reaches the new chambers of the hand of
the king he stops in front of the door
then knocks softly the door is opened up
by Tyrion Lannister who says hello
Samwell how may I help you in a low
voice Sam says do you mind if we speak
inside not at all says Tyrion would you
like a drink no thank you say sam as he
walks in the room then shuts the door
behind him before Sam sits down he
notices one of the windows is open he
walks across the room then shuts it as
well Tyrion has a Sly smile on his face
when he says uh yes I see you are now a
man of secrecy Samwell now I know I am
living in King's Landing again I suspect
you must have something good to say
otherwise you could have said it earlier
during the small council meeting Sam
sits down next to him then says I do
kind of but I'm not sure good is the
word I would use for it I'm a little
concerned says Sam have you noticed bran
has been acting a little strange lately
well stranger than usual no I don't
think I have says Tyrion
the boy has seemed a little off since I
first met him but that doesn't come as a
big surprise to me we've all been
changed by what we have been through
over the years I'm sure he's fine all
things considered besides this is his
first time living in King's Landing I'm
sure he will adjust I still remember
when I first moved here I hated it but
this city does have a certain charm to
it when it's not always consumed by
death destruction deceit and
backstabbing actually now that I think
of it King's Landing has no charm
whatsoever I still hate it here but we
will have to make do this is our home
now as it is King Brands what makes you
say this Samwell did he say something to
you well not exactly says Sam it's not
what he said it's what he did I was
looking through one of the old books
from the Citadel and I noticed something
interesting I was hoping bran could help
explain what it means but when I handed
him the book he threw it into the fire
then he just sat there watching it burn
before he made Brian and I leave his
room well that certainly doesn't sound
like something brain would do says
Tyrion I have never seen him act like
that before did he say anything else he
did says Samwell he said the bulk had no
useful information we see another smile
come across tyrion's face before he says
oh I see well he might be right about
that what do you mean says Sam you and I
both know brain can see things that have
already happened somewhere deep inside
that mind of his he has access to the
entire history of Westeros he must have
thought the book was no longer needed
since he may already know the answers
you were looking for well that's just a
thing says Sam he never gave me any
answers it was like he didn't want me to
know that book wasn't mine it belongs to
the Citadel we can't go and destroy all
of its written history otherwise it will
be lost forever if something were to
happen to bran I understand your concern
says Tyrion let me go speak with him
thank you sir Samuel he stands back up
then he heads for the door when Sam
opens the door Tyrion says now before
you go I want to ask you something you
said there was something interesting you
discovered in the book
what was it
in the final scene of this episode we go
out Beyond the Wall John Ghost and the
wildlings are still moving through the
forest as they search for the where wood
he saw while he was sleeping the Moon is
a crescent thin and sharp as the blade
of a knife a murder of Ravens or
following them in the sky the sound of
leaves are whispering in the wind we're
almost there says the Wilding woman who
is still riding on the back of John's
horse ghost is leading their pack he's
been sniffing at the ground as he moves
forward almost as if he's following
someone or something sent
go stop Suddenly at the bottom of a
steep stretch of unbroken white snow the
direwolf looked back at Jon sniffed the
air then snarled where here said the
wildling woman about 80 yards in front
of them was a massive wirewood sitting
on a hill above the three-eyed Raven's
old cave that's it says John that's what
I saw in my dream when they reached the
front of the werewood John says we will
set up camp here for the night have some
of the men find wood for a fire I want
to go have a look around inside the Cave
the rest of the wildlings wait outside
while John goes tormen and the wildling
woman go inside they follow the roots of
the werewood which look like dark white
snakes slithering in and out of the
Earth around them ghost is leading them
once again as if he knows where to go as
if he has been here before Jon runs his
fingers along the roots of the werewood
when he looks at them his fingers are
blackened by the ash he says someone
must have lit a fire in here it looks
more like like something exploded in
here says the Wilding woman there are
thousands of bones all over the ground
notices some of them don't look as old
as of the rest when the cave opens up in
the center they all stop when they see
what looks like a throne made of
werewood ghost is still sniffing the
ground moving around some of the bones
with his nose Jon sees the skull of a
bear and the skull of a wolf there are
dozens of human skulls and near as many
giant skulls that have been crushed all
the rest were small and oddly shaped
they are the skulls of the children of
the forest The Roots had grown in and
around and through them everyone a few
Ravens are sitting atop them watching
them enter the cave with their bright
black eyes that are full of secrets do
you think the White Walker stayed in
here says tormen I don't know says John
I don't think so ghost begins rubbing
himself against Jon's leg when he looks
down at his direwolf he notices he now
has something in his mouth at first Jon
thought that it might have been a bone
but on the second look he notices it has
a metallic shine to it he Yanks it free
from ghost He studies it for a moment
but then his eyes go wide when he
realizes what it is the wildling woman
says did he find something what is it I
think this was my brother Brands says
John he holds it up by the Light so the
others can see it has this sigil of
House Stark on it bran used to wear this
around his neck says John this must be
the same cave he mentioned before bran
was here now ghost begins snipping at
Jon's fingers trying to get his
attention what is a boy says John what's
wrong ghost eyes are glowing red John
bends down as he is about to say
something else but then go starts
forward into the darkness that lies
ahead we should follow him says the
wildling woman the sound of flapping
wings can be heard echoing off the cave
walls they go deeper then deeper not
knowing how far it goes the scent of
blood and smoke is still in the air do
you hear that says John
it sounds like there is Rushing Water
below us I can hear Too says tormund it
sounds like an underground river they
keep following the glowing red eyes
further and further down until some
flickering light can be seen bouncing
off the cave walls ahead someone or
something is down here with them
I'm afraid of what we might find says
the wildling woman whatever is down
there is leading me here says John once
again the cave opens up into a larger
chamber there are candles burning down
here along the wall there are also large
mounds of melted wax all over the ground
it looks as if there have been candles
burning down here for hundreds of years
even with their added light it's still
hard to see what's inside the chamber
it's not until they all walk into the
center when they can finally see what's
there waiting for them in the shadows
there are three white werewood Thrones
flecked with red fashioned out of the
living roots with dead branches woven
through them they look exactly the same
as the one the three odd Ravens set in
on the main floor of the Cave the only
difference is there is something else
sitting on these werewood Thrones there
are three small creatures all staring at
John snow they are three little wise men
of the children of the forest who have
nut brown skin dappled like a deer's
response in large ears they could hear
things that no man could hear their eyes
are big as well great golden cat size
that I could see in the dark where a
man's eyes only saw Blackness their
hands only have three fingers and a
thumb with sharp black claws instead of
nails there are Ravens walking up and
down their little arms ghost walks over
by them then lays down in front of their
Thrones who are you said Jon Snow
some men call us the singers While
others call us the children of the
forest said the one sitting in the
middle we are as you see us and now you
will understand why we could not come to
you except in a dream we have been
watching you we have seen your birth in
your fathers before you
we saw your first step and heard your
first word and now you have arrived at
last Jon Snow though the hour is late
just as it was late for Brandon Stark my
brother says John
so he was here he was said the child of
the forest and that's why you are here
now we're afraid your brother is in
grave danger he needs you now more than
ever Jon Snow I I don't understand says
John
what do you mean he is in danger how the
night king and the army of the Dead are
gone why would he need me now
did he ever say how the night King was
created said the child of the forest you
should know Jon Snow we showed you in
your dream John sits down then inhales a
deep breath as he shakes his head
remembering what he saw when he leaned
his head against the werewood and shut
his eyes he finally says the children of
the forest made the night King the
wildling woman and tormund unsheathed
their weapons and step forward wait says
John
he gets back up then stands in front of
them
before any new bones get added to this
cave I want to hear what else they have
to say they brought me here for a reason
I want to find out why give us the full
story why was the night King created
why are there bones all over this cave
why are you hiding out here Beyond the
Wall why is my brother bran in danger
I'm sure you are familiar with some of
our story already said one of the
children of the forest thousands of
years ago Westeros belonged to us those
you have named the singers and the
children of the forest this was our land
this was our home until your ancestors
invaded it when the first men arrived in
Westeros thousands of your ancestors
began to settle in our lands it wasn't
long before they started settling in
more of our lands further and further
north until we had to leave our own home
they began destroying everything that we
held sacred all that was left for us was
the deep forest the first men had
brought with them New Gods horses and
even weapons of bronze that we could not
match they were also bigger and stronger
than us threatening our very existence
we had Warriors of our own who your
ancestors would name the wood dancers
but even with our secret Arts of dark
magic we could only slow down the
advance of the first men
are grain Sears and skin Changers even
binded direwolves and monstrous snow
bears cave lions and Eagles and serpents
and more to their will but the first men
had us outnumbered they slaughtered
almost everyone we knew we were on the
brink of Extinction unfortunately it
drove us to act out of desperation we
felt like we had no choice if we were to
not only save our own kind but our
beautiful lands as well that's when you
made the night King said Jon Snow
he sits back down
the wildling woman and tormund sheath
their weapons and sit down as well
we fought as fiercely as the first men
did to defend our lives yet it wasn't
enough said the child of the forest who
is sitting in the middle Throne one day
we discovered there were some first men
living among a few Children of the
forest in the north the children who
came before me did not like the idea of
the first men and the children of the
forest laying together especially when
we were at war with one another we
captured and sacrificed one of these
first men who would become the night
King it was this act that shifted the
battle back into our favor it wasn't
long before the first men gave up and
began fleeing from the north Opening Our
lands back up this was all we wanted
we wanted the fighting to end and we
wanted the first men to stop chopping
down our sacred were Woods the first men
finally agreed the wisest of your race
and ours met upon the God's eye and this
is where we negotiated your ancestors
would get the open lands while ours
would get the forest the first men would
stop cutting down our were Woods while
we would end the night King's reign
but that never happened said John if you
ended the night King's Reign thousands
of years ago then how did he come back
we did end his Reign said the children
of the forest the night King that ye saw
us create in your dream wasn't made of
ice like the one you fought this night
King was only a man by light of day but
the night was his to roll
when we agreed with the first men to end
the war we brought the night King down
on his knees before a heart tree in the
north where he was from a bronze sickle
was hooked around his throat right
before it was slashed I watched as his
feet drummed against the Earth
afterwards his body was thrown into a
stone cell deep beneath the ground this
is when we entered what you men call The
Age of Heroes this was when the children
of the forest and the first men lived
amongst each other for many many years
but there was a new storm on the horizon
not all of our ancestors were happy
about our new living arrangement with
the first men the gods gave us long
lives but not great numbers even in
those days we were few yet in this new
world the first men had built there
still wasn't room for us this is what
led to the war between the children of
the forest you won't find this in your
books of written history this is the
story that's forgotten in the North but
the werewolves remember
some of us were willing to coexist with
the first men but there were others who
still wanted the first men dead there
were others who still wanted all of our
lanes back in the South there are
children of the forest who are wrath in
the South there are children of the
forest who hate and swear of bloody
Vengeance in the South there are
children of the forest who fight and
kill they began slaughtering and
sacrificing any of us who would not
stand beside them this is what fractured
the children of the forest as well as
our secret Arts of dark magic this is
when the long night fell over Westeros
this is when the night King returned for
our own Survival we had to leave our
homes in the South and flee here to the
far north our race has been split ever
since that winter lasted for an entire
generation they nearly succeeded in that
war but with the aid of another man from
the north we were able to push the white
walkers in the 19 back into the lands of
always winter I think I know this part
of the story says John that's when you
built the wall so you could keep the
night King and his army in the north
under your watch did you see all of the
bones when you entered this cave Jon
Snow the small ones are from members of
our own race when your brother bran was
in this cave it was attacked by the
night king and the white walkers again
the night this cave was attacked they
killed the last of us living in the
north now ask yourself this Jon Snow
if the night King is our enemy just as
he is yours then why would we live north
of the wall where the night king and the
army of the Dead were hunting why would
we choose to live on this side of the
wall with the night King when he wants
us dead
because you felt safer living beyond the
wall surrounded by the night King in his
army of the dead then you did in the
South among the rest of your own race
says John
very good now you know something Jon
Snow says the child of the forest
sitting on the werewolf throne in the
center when bran left the north we began
losing more and more of our influence
over his abilities now you know why bran
is no longer the same brother you once
knew
he will only lose more of himself the
longer he is in the South it's not only
Bran who is in danger now all of
Westeros is threatened I know you must
have so many questions Jon Snow but you
should leave soon
as we said when you first arrived the
hour is late you must go south while you
still can John shakes his head in
disbelief he shuts his eyes as he
absorbs all this new information
I can't believe this is happening again
says John I thought it was over I feel
like I have been living in a nightmare I
can't wake up from
tormund Giants Bane throws his arm
around Jon's shoulder and says if you
must go south again you know I will ride
with you with his head in his hands John
says what should we do how do we finally
end this
we thought you might ask that says the
children of the forest we won't be
sending you out on your own we have
someone who will help you along the way
John the wildling woman and tormund all
look at each other confused who's going
to help us as John
me said a voice from the shadows in the
back of the chamber the sound of boots
scraping against the bones on the ground
startles ghost the direwolf jumps up the
glowing red eyes dart back and forth as
he looks into the darkness suddenly a
man steps out from the Shadow and says I
will be coming with you Jon Snow who are
you says John how long have you been
hiding down here in the dark I was a
good friend of your fathers my father
says John the man says you don't
remember me Jon Snow but I was there the
day you were born the man reaches out
his hand so he can shake John's the
episode ends right after the man says my
name is Helen Reed
the sun is just now beginning to set as
we see wagons full of new arrivals
entering the city King's Landing is
obviously still in shambles but now that
everyone believes things are stable in
Westeros again they're starting to
travel to the different kingdoms the
capital of Westeros is starting to look
alive again although it does still need
a lot of work we then begin to follow
one of the wagons down the street there
are men and women all over working on
making King's Landing a thriving City
like it once was there are men lifting
heavy Stones off the ground there are
women sweeping the street shaking the
dust out of their rugs as well as fixing
up some of the bait shops warehouses and
small markets the scent of raw sewage
and baked bread is in the air the wagon
stops in front of a building where a few
men are standing outside laughing and
drinking their wine a man and woman get
out of their wagon before they walk
inside there are half-naked women
dancing and sitting in the lapse of a
few men who are seated around the table
where drinks are being served there's
also a few young men lifting a new
barrel of Ale there's a woman sitting
alone fixing her hair it looks like
everyone is enjoying themselves we
suddenly hear a voice that sounds
familiar in the back of the room there's
three men sitting at a small table
drinking and sharing their War Stories
one of the men is Brawn the other men
sitting with him are from the Stark's
household guard whose sons are left
behind for her brother bran as Braun
drinks his ale one of the Stark men says
so sir Brown of the black water lord of
high Garden or whatever your name is
these days what's it like sitting on the
King's small Council well says Braun I
imagine it's about as boring as it is
working for the Stark's household guard
most of my days are spent sitting around
wondering how much longer I can stay in
this city I have my own castle now
gentlemen why would I want to stay in
this God forsaken hellhole the Stark man
says really you're not fond of the
capital let me ask you something else
how did someone like you end up in that
position anyway the same way I became
brunt of the Black Water says Braun
eventually the Lannisters do pay their
debts they all begin laughing Braun then
says why do you keep asking so many
questions anyway the Stark man says I
have worked for house Stark for many
years yet I can't figure out why one of
Ned Stark's children would allow you on
their small Council this is when bronze
stopped smiling he sits down his drink
stares hard at the man then says you
should watch your mouth I like drinking
with you fellas but don't let my new
fancy clothes and my new fancy titles
fool you besides I don't think King bran
does much thinking about me anyway in
fact I'm not sure he does much thinking
at all I like him I really do but
there's something strange about that boy
what do you expect says the star guard
most of his family is dead he has been
out Beyond the Wall surrounded by white
walkers he has seen things no kids
should ever see is that right says Brawn
like what all of my family is dead I've
been out Beyond the Wall it wasn't that
scary I saw a man die a slow death when
I was only five years old what of it
Braun finishes his drink then slams it
down when he stands up he stumbles a
little bit before walking away he
mutters something under his breath right
as he reaches the door after he walks
out of the Inn we watch him as he heads
back down the street in the direction of
the red keep right before the scene ends
we see a raven land on the wagon that's
sitting right out front in the next
scene of this episode we are back in the
north somewhere near Winterfell deep
beneath the ground We are following
three men as they walk further and
further into the darkness searching for
an end we should start back says one of
the younger star Guardsmen I don't think
this will ever end we have already been
walking down here for several days if we
don't find something soon we will have
to start rationing out the food the
young star Guardsman looks very nervous
as if he can send and something is down
here with them six days they had been
walking North and then Northwest and
then North again farther and farther
from winterfell's Crypt each day had
been worse than the day before the more
they walk the colder and darker it gets
the ground is still frozen the white and
red roots of the werewood are still
running along the ceiling although they
look more like the veins inside a man's
arm does the darkness frighten you says
the commander of the Stark Guardsmen
there's nothing down here except for the
icicles the darkness and one scared boy
you can run back to Winterfell if you'd
like but your Grace has given us orders
we are not the stop until we find the
exit the three men keep moving forward
into the unknown as their light bounces
off the wall we can see the ice crystals
glistening all over the ground as well
as the walls and the ceiling there is a
red sappy-like substance dripping down
from the roots of the werewood suddenly
all three of the star Guardsmen stop
when they notice something ahead the
underground Passage opens up into what
looks like a cave it almost looks like
the three-eyed Ravens cave the only
difference is there aren't any bones in
this one there isn't any werewood
Thrones in this one either the men walk
in a little further as they hold up
their lights we can see that the cave is
now connected to seven different
passageways all heading in different
directions the men look at each other in
disbelief in a low frightened voice the
young Stark Guardsman says what do we do
now how will we know which way to go we
won't says the commander we will just
keep moving forward and if it's a dead
end we will try another one the men move
on Straight Ahead as their lights Fade
Away into the black abyss in the
following scene we go back out Beyond
the Wall Jon Snow the wildling woman and
torm and giant Spain are walking back
outside of the three-eyed Ravens cave
all of the other wildlings are at their
campsite gathered around the fire right
out front the wildlings begin to stand
up as they see them finally walking back
out of the cave when they reach the fire
tormund addresses all of them by saying
this is where we will have to go our
separate ways now all of you can stay
here if you want or you can even make
shelter inside the cave but John and I
will be leaving to go south
I thought you weren't allowed in the
South says one of the other wildlings
well it is complicated says John I had
no intentions of ever riding South again
but my family needs me they will have to
understand I can't say that I'm sad to
see you go says the wildling man he
smiles then gives Giants Bane a hug he
then shakes John's hand before walking
back over by the fire John walks over to
the wildling woman who helped him find
the cave he says I never did thank you
for helping me it's alright says the
wildling woman if things go your way in
the South I guess I should be thanking
you John smiles and says I never did get
your name the wildling woman walks over
near him when she is standing in front
of Jon she holds out her hand then says
my name is Val John shakes her hand and
says thank you Val she smiles and says I
wish you good fortune before walking
away Jon watches as she sits back down
by the fire deep down he doesn't want to
leave but he knows he has to that's when
Jon feels a hard and heavy hand slap him
across the back right as torman says are
you ready snow she will be here when you
get back let's go Jon nods his head in
agreement then follows him back inside
the three-eyed Raven's cave they follow
the roots of the werewood further and
further down until they're deep below
the ground again there are even more
Ravens than before sitting on the skulls
scattered across the cave floor the
sound of Rushing Water can be heard
below there is flickering light bouncing
off the cave walls just ahead when they
walk back inside the cavernous chamber
John sees Helen Reed running his fingers
through ghost thick white fur the
direwolf's eyes are glowing red like
fresh blood Helen Reed stands up then
walks away after Jon takes several more
steps he suddenly stops in his tracks
when he notices something is different
right in front of them is where the
children of the forests are sitting in
their weirwood Thrones only now one of
them is gone the child of the forest who
was sitting in the middle was no longer
there this startles John they look so
old and interwoven with the branches he
did not think they could leave let alone
walk Helen Reed Fades away into the
Shadows behind the werewood Thrones Jon
looks around the cave but he doesn't see
anyone else there where did he go says
John why would he leave now the two
remaining Children of the forest don't
say anything at all they only stare at
Jon they're great golden Cat's eyes look
as if they're full of wisdom deeper than
the roots of the werewood that surrounds
them Helen Reed re-emerges from the
Shadows he walks over by Jon Snow looks
him right in the eyes then says you will
not see him again he is gone from here
Jon Snow Helen Reed then hands something
to John he had a werewood bow in his
hands carved with a dozen faces inside
the bowl is a white paste thick and
heavy it has dark red veins running
through it you must eat this said
Holland he handed John a wooden spoon
John looked at the bowl uncertainly what
is it says John it's made a werewood
seeds said one of the children of the
forest something about the look of it
made John feel sick the red veins were
only where would sappy thought but under
the light they looked remarkably like
blood he dipped the spoon down into the
substance then hesitated why are you
giving me this as John I'm not hungry
the child of the force says you have the
blood of the first men as well as the
blood of the Dragon Jon Snow the where
wood seeds will help awaken the gifts
inside you the gifts you did not know
you have we only knew one other man who
had the blood of the first men and the
blood of the dragon that man was Lord
Brendan Rivers who said in the werewood
throne above us he was once the Lord
Commander at Castle black just like you
but then he came to us and he became
something so much more you must eat it
Jon Snow you will need it for your
journey that lies ahead John ate it it
was bitter the first Spoonful was the
hardest to get down he almost wretched
it right back up the second Spoonful was
better the third was almost sweet the
rest he spooned up eagerly it actually
tasted of Honey of new fallen snow of
cinnamon and other flavors he loved the
empty bowl slipped right from his
fingers and clattered on the cavern
floor ghosts ran over then licked what
was left in the bottom of the bowl I
don't feel any difference that John what
happens next now we will leave says
Helen Reed he walks back behind the
werewood Thrones again when he
re-emerges he has something else in his
hands wrapped under a fur blanket John
notices that whatever it is it has a
strap around it allowing Helen Reed to
sling the object over his shoulder when
Helen is done he looks at them and says
let's go John and tormund begin to
follow him out of the cavernous chamber
right before they walk out one of the
children of the forest says one last
thing do not go back above ground Jon
Snow stay in the cave then follow the
roots of the weirwood until you get
further south we do not need horses down
here our way is faster
John is befuddled he knew the cave went
far into the ground but he did not know
it went South I will show you the way
says Helen Reed ghost runs off in front
of them he moves through the shadows as
if he knows where to go he moves through
the darkness as if he has been this way
before the scene ends as we watch the
men follow behind the direwolf before
they begin fading away into the dark
abyss in the following scene we are back
out at Sea the sails of house Stark are
high in the sky under the light of the
Sun the morning air is hazy from the
smoke of the coke fires as a dozen men
sat down to break their fasts beneath
the banners of the great House of
Winterfell Arya Stark emerges from below
she walks back out onto the main deck
then takes in a long deep breath of that
sweet morning air she goes over to where
the men are sitting down having their
food Arya grabs A Fistful of baked bread
before she stood over by the rail and
looked out across the sea at some
southern land she has never been there
are several small islands near the
Horizon from here it almost looks
beautiful the deep blue sea was
glistening from the sun shining down it
is a gorgeous day but it looks like
there is a storm ahead just above the
small islands that set off in the
distance she stands there for a few
moments looking at all of her
surroundings as she nibbles on the food
that's when Arya is interrupted when she
hears the sound of a seagull as it lands
on the rail of the ship she breaks off
some of her bread then throws it up into
the sky the seagull leaps off the rail
opens its mouth wide then snatches the
bread out of the sky Arya Smiles then
throws the rest of her bread onto the
deck as she begins walking away another
sound is heard only this one is from
above when Arya looks up a raven lands
on the enormous sail of the ship then it
let out another loud shriek that's when
Arya notices there is something
different about this raven she watches
as the Raven's eyes go from black to
white then back to black again Arya
suddenly has a feeling of dread wash
over her it's as if the Raven is looking
right through her Arya slowly walks away
until she vanishes below the deck it's
only a few moments later when she
re-emerges only now she has a bow and
arrow in her hand Arya watches the Raven
as she walks back over by the railing
its eyes go from black to white then
back to black again Arya Notch is one of
her arrows then draws the string back
hard she holds the arrow back as she
also holds her breath the Raven's white
eyes are looking right at her almost as
if it's challenging her to let the arrow
fly that's when Arya lets it loose the
arrow slices right through the morning
air but it misses by only a few inches
The Raven did not move Arya grabs
another arrow notches it then draws it
back as far as she can she looks over at
the Stark Banner flapping in the wind
waiting only a few seconds for it to be
in her favor the moment she releases the
string The Raven takes flight from the
sail Arya watches has her Arrow hits
nothing but the sky before falling into
the sea below the Raven lets out another
loud shriek as it circles above one of
the men who is sitting at the table says
I'm sorry my lady you almost had it Arya
doesn't respond she walks back across
the ship over to where the captain is
standing at his wheel when he sees that
Arya is approaching he bows his head
then says good morning my lady I see you
were sharpening your skills at archery
it's not so easy when a ship is rocking
back and forth Beneath You Arya says do
you know where we are the captain smiles
and says well of course my lady I would
not be a very good Captain if I did not
he holds out his finger motioning in
front of him though small group of
islands you see in the distance are the
stepstones my lady now if you look over
here to the West can you see that Speck
of land near the Horizon yes I do says
Arya well you're now looking at Dorn my
lady thank you cesaria she looks back up
into the sky right as the cat Captain
began saying something else but Arya
doesn't hear him she now has all of her
focus on the raven that is still
following them from above Arya watches
it for a few more seconds before cutting
off the captain's story Arya says I have
changed my mind I don't think I will go
to King's Landing confused the captain
says what do you mean my lady where will
you have me go Instead This scene ends
right after Arya says I must go to
Storm's end first in the next scene we
are back in the north inside the castle
of Al Stark Sansa is sitting in what was
once her father's High seat in the Great
Hall of Winterfell maester walcan is
seated at a right beside her on Sons is
left the seat is empty a large fire is
burning inside the Hearth the gray
Granite stone walls inside the Great
Hall were draped without Stark's banners
once again the air is hazy from the
smoke and heavy from the smell of
roasted meat and fresh baked bread there
is a Bard running his fingers along the
strings of a high heart while now
reciting the words from some ballad
Sansa once knew Sansa Smiles as she
looks around listening to the sounds of
laughter and a hundred different drunken
conversations it is so noisy that it was
hard to hear anyone who wasn't right
beside you eight long rows of tables
filled winterfell's great hall four on
each side of the center aisle Lords and
Ladies of the north were crowded
shoulder to shoulder on the benches in
front of her right as Sansa standing up
all of the noise inside Winterfell Falls
silent as everyone watches and waits for
their Queen to speak this is when we
will see a man walk over and hand a
letter to the maester Sansa raises her
drink in the air then says first I just
want to thank all of you for joining me
for this Feast I welcome you all to our
fires and offer you meet and Mead in
honor of our friendship it honestly
warms my heart to see this Hall filled
with all of the northern uniforms yet
again my father Edward Stark always said
a lord needs to dine with his men if he
ever hopes to keep them know the men who
follow you and make sure they know you
don't ask your men to die for a stranger
with that being said I must apologize
however because some of you nearly died
for Daenerys Targaryen I want to make it
known here and now the north is
independent like it should have always
been the only time I will ever ask any
of you to fight for me is so that we can
keep it that way everyone begins
slamming their cups down against the
table as they yell Stark Stark Stark
Winterfell Winterfell Winterfell Sansa
smiles and then she raises her drink
again silencing the Great Hall my Lords
and Ladies If you would look beside me
you will see I have left an empty seat
it was left this way for a reason my
father always had an extra seat set at
his own table and every day a different
man would join him so my father could
know him and he could know my father I
am asking each of you to do the same
Sansa then leans over and asks the
maester what does the let her say is it
from my brother bran as he shakes his
head the maester says know your grace I
still have not received any word from
King's Landing this makes Sansa very
angry then something is wrong says Sansa
our Ravens have went South yet none of
them have come back she stands up again
and says before any of you join me on
this evening first I would like to speak
with our master of horse we see a stick
thin man with brown hair and a brown
beard walking up to the main table he
then sits down next to Sansa Your Grace
how may I be of service says
winterfell's master of horse this scene
ends right after Sansa says I want you
to have horses ready when the feast is
over I will be sending some of my men
self in the next scene we go back across
the narrow sea in the city of volantis
Daenerys kenvara and the other
high-ranking members of relore are all
inside the Great Hall of the red Temple
we see a man who is dressed in a red
silk robe walk across the Great Hall
until he is standing right before Danny
holding in his hands is a wooden box
that has the Burning Heart carved into
its lid he gives it to Daenerys then
says this is a gift from The Lord of
Light it will help you against the
darkness where this Daenerys Stormborn
and it shall be your Shield against the
great other when Daenerys opens the Box
she can see there is a necklace laying
on a Scarlet robe of her own the
necklace has a great red ruby just like
the one Melisandre and canvara wore
around their throats as Daenerys lays it
around her neck the great red ruby
starts to glisten as if it were a fire
then she unfolds her new robe and throws
it over her shoulders in red and gold
stitching it has the Burning Heart of
Allure on the front of it across its
back it has the three-headed dragon of
House Targaryen thank you says Daenerys
kenvara now grabs dany's hand then looks
in her eyes and says you are the one who
was promised daenery Stormborn from the
great fires of relore you have been born
and you will remake the world you no
longer have a large army like you once
had you no longer have three dragons
like you once had yet still we must
leave volantis soon every day the great
other grows stronger but so shall we
Daenerys Stormborn what do you mean we
says Daenerys you will not succeed if we
sent you back to Westeros Alone says
canvara we all must make our sacrifices
we will be coming with you as well as
our fiery hand Your Dragon and our ships
are waiting for us outside where will we
go first Daenerys wants to know we will
go to harrenhal says canvara Jon snow is
already on his way there now the sound
of Jon's name made Daenerys nervous but
the thought of seeing him again also
made her very angry remember what I said
Daenerys Stormborn you and Jon Snow will
need each other you will not allow
yourself to be lost again the scene ends
as the red ruby on Danny's throat begins
to Glow even brighter than before in the
following scene we go back out Beyond
the Wall we're following Jon tormund
ghost and Helen Reed as they make their
way South through the underground system
below the three-eyed Raven's cave
they're now walking through a much
smaller passageway there are no longer
bones all over the ground but you can
still see the roots of the werewood
running along the ceiling like the veins
in a man's body ghost is several feet in
front of them leading the way John looks
over at Helen Reed who is readjusting
the large item that's on his back then
says we have a very long walk ahead of
us my Lord do you mind if I ask you some
questions not at all says Helen Reed
that's one of the reasons why I'm here
Jon Snow ask me whatever you'd like
before he says anything John thinks back
on what was said by the children of the
forest he thinks about bran and all the
strange things he said as well finally
John says if my brother bran is not the
same many more then how can I believe
anything he said you also said bran is
getting influenced or even manipulated
by the children in the self everything
he has said may have been a lie John
looks back over at Helen Reed you said
you were there the day I was born what
actually happened I was there the day
you were born says Helen Reed but I was
also there the day your father Met Your
Mother during the year of the fall
spring there was a great tournament held
at the castle of Herron Hall almost
everyone of significance was there that
day yet when the jousting began the day
belonged to your father rhaegar
Targaryen he would end up wearing the
same armor he would die in it was
gleaming black with a three-headed
dragon of his house wrought in rubies on
the breast
Scarlet silk stream behind him when he
rode and it seemed no Lance could touch
him Brandon Stark fell to him and
bronzion Royce and even The Splendid Sir
Arthur Dane the sword of the morning
rhaegar was Unstoppable and that's
because he knew that he must win if he
wanted things to unfold the way they did
as soon as he won rhaegar did not go to
his wife Elia Martel instead he laid the
queen of beauty's flowers in Leona's lap
I can still see it now says Helen Reed
it was a crown of winter roses as blue
as Frost but rhaegar had set all of this
in motion long before this one day
rhaegar found something in his Scrolls
that changed him forever
no one knew what it might have been only
that the boy suddenly appeared early one
morning in the yard as the knights were
donning their steel he walked over to
Sir Willem Derry the Master at Arms and
said I will require sword and armor it
seems I must be a Warrior from this day
forward your father knew many sacrifices
would have to be made this is when your
father became obsessed there was a
prophecy he wanted to fulfill he became
convinced that it would be his own son
who would do it rhaegar believed his son
would be the prince who was promised The
Song of Ice and Fire this is what drove
him to seek out your mother lyanna
she fell in love with him the very day
they met it wasn't long after this when
they both vanished we had found your
mother in Dorne and what rhaegar would
name the Tower of Joy your mother laid
there in a bed soaked with blood the
fever had taken her strength and her
voice was faint as a whisper but she
told eddard everything he swore he would
die with her secret and he did I found
eddard still holding her body silent
with grief I had taken her hand from his
otherwise he would have stayed right
there at her bedside forever John holds
his hand over his mouth while shaking
his head in disbelief everything has
happened for a reason says Helen Reed
there is a reason you're here with me
now Jon Snow there is a reason bran gave
you the little bit of information he did
when he did John says what do you mean
by that Helen Reed stops walking he then
sets his hand on Jon's shoulder and says
brand new what would happen once that
information got out brand new how that
would affect Daenerys Targaryen he had
seen it in his Visions since he was
still a boy Jon looks stunned as he
realizes what Helen Reed is about to say
the scene ends right after Helen Reed
finishes by saying brand new Daenerys
would burn down King's Landing yet he
did nothing to stop it brand new you
would be exiled back out Beyond the Wall
in the final scene of this episode we
will go down to King's Landing we are
back inside the red keep at the
beginning of the scene Brienne is
standing in front of the hand of the
King's new Chambers Tyrion Lannister
opens his door then says would you mind
stepping inside for a moment I would
like to ask you something before I leave
when Brienne enters the chambers she
says how may I be of service my Lord he
offers her a seat before taking one
himself Brienne sits down as Tyrion says
Samwell and I recently spoke he said you
were with him when King bran was
displaying some rather odd behavior I
was hoping you could tell me what you
thought or how you felt about it before
I go speaking with our King well he was
acting a bit different than usual I
suppose says bran at first he would not
answer his door even after I knocked
louder and louder but I thought maybe he
just did not hear me it was what
happened inside of his chambers that
really struck me as odd Sam handed him a
book about the legends of the long night
King baranga set there staring at it as
he ran his fingers over the drawing of
some horrible looking creature that was
on the front of it he looked almost as
if he was mesmerized by it then out of
nowhere he throws the book Into the Fire
then says Sam and I were dismissed now I
know I haven't known him for that long
but I have never seen him act like that
before our King has seen a lot and knows
a lot there's no doubt about that says
Tyrion he has witnessed all of
westeros's violent history I know I
would not want to experience the effects
that would have on someone anyways I
want to thank you sir Brianne I am on my
way to speak to King bran now I will
walk with you says bran as they stand up
and head for the door they suddenly hear
the sound of a very unsettling frantic
scream Brienne lays her hand on the head
of her sword then says it sounded like
it came from outside my Lord they run
across the room then look out the window
they can see someone standing below the
red keep with their hand over their
mouth in shock Brienne and Tyrion leave
his Chambers then Rush down the stairs
sir Davos runs across the hall to join
them did you hear that scream says Davos
yes it came from outside says Tyrion
Davos follows them down more stairs then
across the throne room when they shove
open the doors there is already a crowd
gathered around outside everyone looked
stunned a hundred yards in front of them
there are about 30 people standing
around in a circle all looking down at
the ground there are more standing off
to the side looking up into the sky at
the red keep Samwell then emerges from
the crowd who has gathered in a circle
he looks like he has been shaken up all
of the color has left his face as he
begins walking over to them he wretches
up some of his dinner onto the ground
Brienne Tyrion and DeVos all look at
each other wondering what's happened
they slowly start walking over by the
crowd gathered around when Sam notices
them he walks over to Tyrion lays his
hand on his shoulder and says I am so
sorry this happened my Lord before
walking away with his head down as they
get closer to the crowd Brienne began
shoving some of them aside only then are
they able to see what has happened sir
Braun is laying on the ground dead
surrounded by his own Blood and Bone
this is when Tyrion drops down to one
knee shocked he looks around at everyone
gathered outside wondering how this
could have happened Deva says I will go
find some help before he runs off
Brienne still has her hand on her sword
while she looks for anyone who could
have saw something radis Tyrion stands
back up he notices everyone is now
looking up at the red key as he follows
their eyes up along the castle all he
can see is the balcony to the king's
Chambers the episode ends as we hear low
voices say he fell he was shoved he fell
he was shot I saw it with my own eyes
in the very first scene of this episode
the sky is beginning to get dark as the
sun slowly slips behind the Horizon off
into the distance we can see there is a
gigantic castle on the far side of the
lake we're in a location we have never
been before we're on the shore of the
God's eye somewhere we have only seen
glimpses of in bran Stark's flashbacks
this evening is eerily silent the only
thing we can hear is the sound of the
red leaves rustling in the wind and the
water gently splashing against the rocks
in the middle of this lake is an island
known as the Isle of faces as we look
out across the lake onto the island all
we can see are the faces on the
werewoods a thousand blood red eyes are
staring back at us eyes that look as if
they're full of ancient wisdom and
secrets older than the land itself the
faces on these were Woods are different
than the ones we have seen in the north
they look frightening almost like
they've wet this to all of the
atrocities throughout the history of
Westeros there is something very
unsettling about them it looks as if the
werewoods are guarding the sacred Isle
of faces themselves there must be
hundreds of them standing side by side
surrounding the entire Island in a
circle the where woods look alive as the
red leaves dance in the wind suddenly we
start to see some movement there are
shadows shifting back and forth behind
the were Woods we can hear the sound of
branches breaking underneath footsteps
hundreds of small green figures begin to
emerge from the woods they're all
wearing helmets that are shaped like
antlers they're green and brown skin
looks as if it's made from the leaves
these green men do not look like the
innocent children of the forest who are
hiding out in the north these little
green men have a ghastly look about
their faces all of them are holding
dragonglass weapons in their hands
however they're not made from the black
obsidian we have always seen before
their dragon glass weapons are green and
some of them are are even red all of
them begin to stand shoulder to shoulder
on the shore of the Sacred Isle of faces
as the where would stand guard over the
island the green men stand there
silently watching over the werewoods
behind them it would be very difficult
for anyone to get onto this island
unless you are welcomed here in the
following scene we go back to King's
Landing where a crowd is gathered below
the red keep there are now men and women
everywhere the new city watch is
standing around SAR Braun's lifeless
body as they hold everyone back we see
bran walking around asking everyone
questions in hopes of finding out what
they all saw and heard her hand is still
resting on the hilt of her sword the
city watch Make Way for Samwell who is
holding his hand over his mouth while he
throws a blanket over Braun a few of the
Stark Guardsmen left his body off the
ground before they lay it down on the
back of a wagon the onlookers are still
shocked by their gruesome scene the
shape of bronze body can still be seen
on the the ground where he was outlined
by bits of his own bone and large
amounts of blood some of bronze hair can
even be seen on the Stone Street below
the red key Lord Tyrion is standing
there speechless as he watches his
friend's body get hauled away he finally
snaps out of his days as he hears a soft
whisper behind him say I saw what
happened my Lord I saw it with my own
eyes now Tyrion looks over his shoulder
wondering where the voice came from the
only one standing there behind him is a
short man dressed in rags he doesn't say
anything at first he looks over at Sam
and Brienne Sam is kneeling down looking
at something on the ground Brienne is
still standing there only now she's
speaking to one of the Stark Guardsmen
not knowing what this man will say
Tyrion doesn't want everyone overhearing
him when he sees that the others are
still busy he looks back over at the man
and says follow me they begin walking
away from the scene they don't walk far
before they find a building they can
slip behind out of site he grabs the man
by his wrist before asking him what did
you see I want you to tell me every
detail the man looks down at Tyrion then
says he was thrown off the balcony my
Lord I was standing right below the red
keep when I suddenly heard a few voices
shouting from above when I looked up I
saw three men standing there it looked
like they were arguing about something
it all happened so fast the next thing I
know the men began shoving each other
but only one of them went over the
railing while letting go of the man's
wrist Tyrion asks him who are the other
men do you remember what they look like
or what they were wearing I do my Lord
says the man dressed in rags let me show
you they step back out from behind the
building the man looks over where the
crowd is still gathered around he holds
out his finger in front of him then says
they look just like him when Tyrion
follows the Man's eyes and finger he can
see exactly who he was referring to
they're now looking at one of the Stark
Guardsmen reluctantly Tyrion says I was
a afraid you would say that now he steps
in closer to the man in a low whisper he
says did you happen to see anyone else
out there on the balcony someone that
might have been sitting down the man
suddenly gets nervous as he realizes the
gravity of the situation no my Lord I
did not see anyone else Tyrion now looks
away while silently letting out a sigh
of relief he looks back at the man then
says do not speak to anyone else about
this without speaking to me first do you
understand the man nods his head then
says of course my Lord he then throws
the man a small sack of golden dragons
and says that should be enough to buy
your silence for now what is your name
the man says my name is Damien my Lord
thank you for the information says
Tyrion I may need you again before all
of this is over where can I find you
that won't be very hard my Lord says
Damien I live in flea bottom in the only
house that's still standing the man in
rags then bows his head before or the
men go their separate ways now Tyrion
begins walking back over to where Berean
is standing he starts asking her what
she has heard what is everyone saying
about what happened Brienne says I find
it a little hard to believe but they're
all saying he fell on his own there had
to be someone standing out here that saw
something else very well says Tyrion if
that's what they saw then that's what
they saw this makes Brienne glance over
at him out of the corner of her eye it's
obvious she doesn't feel the same way he
then looks over at Samwell who is still
kneeling down looking at the ground he
watches as Sam grabs something off the
ground before standing back up Samwell
is holding something in his hand as he
walks in their Direction when he stops
in front of them he holds it up into the
air for them to see it's a black feather
that has blood dripping down from it it
was laying under bronze body Samwell
says nervously when Tyrion realizes what
it is his mouth hangs open as he looks
back up at the red key his eyes find the
balcony that Braun fell from it's no
longer empty bran is now sitting out
there alone staring back at them the
scene ends when Tyrion notices he is
staring right at him in the following
scene we are back in the darkness deep
below the ground somewhere in the north
there are shadows dancing across the
cavern walls as the flickering Flames
illuminate what lies ahead John goes
tormund and Helen Reed follow the red
and white roots of the werewood as they
make their way further and further south
ghost is still only a few feet in front
of them leading the way as the men
continue walking John looks back over at
Allen Reed then says there are still a
few things I need you to help me
understand you said brand new that
Daenerys would burn King's Landing
before we ever went South you said he
knew that I would be sent back out
Beyond the Wall how did he know I know
bran can see things but how does he see
them before they happen Helen Reed
begins running his fingers along the
werewood roots as he walks alongside Jon
he says your brother was given this gift
from the the oldest gods in Westeros Jon
Snow the children have gods of the
forest rivers and stone the old gods
whose names are secret their knowledge
and wisdom runs deeper than these roots
and where they go their eyes go as well
they are in harmony with everything
around us when the children gave the
werewoods their faces it gave them the
ability to see what they see but after
thousands of years they're able to see
so much more Jon Snow your brother bran
is one of their green Sears he began by
Looking Through The Eyes of the werewood
but now he can see so much more as well
Jon suddenly stops walking he wipes the
sweat from his brow as he gathers his
thoughts if you're right about all of
this then they know we're on our way
John says dreadfully how can we ever
hope to stop them if they're already
half a dozen steps ahead of us Helen
Reed sets his hand on Jon's shoulder
then says I won't lie to you Jon Snow it
won't be easy nothing ever is bran is
still in King's Landing right now
surrounded by your friend events as long
as we can reach him before he leaves we
still stand a Fighting Chance bran has
seen glimpses of the future in his
vision since he was a boy but he hasn't
seen everything he hasn't seen you when
the night King attacked the cave he
forced your brother to go south while he
was still learning how to use his new
gift the children of the South are now
fighting the children of the north over
your brother's mind they're like a virus
entering his body infecting everything
he sees the further your brother goes
south and the longer he's there the more
and more he loses of himself it won't be
long before he can no longer control his
own thoughts or actions hold on says
John you said bran hasn't seen me what
did you mean by that Helen Reed smiles
and says the old gods have your brother
now but they no longer have you not like
they once did you were resurrected by
the Lord of Light Jon Snow the same as
Daenerys Targaryen when bran sees either
of you in his Visions now he's looking
at things that have already happened
that's why he's still in King's Landing
the scene ends after Helen Reed says he
doesn't know you or Daenerys are on your
way let's hope that doesn't change
that's our only Advantage right now in
the next scene we go back across the
narrow sea in the city of Atlantis the
sun is sweltering on this afternoon as
it sits high in the sky above about a
dozen ships that are anchored along the
shore the black and red sails of House
Targaryen are dancing in the sky as the
wind slams against them throwing them in
the other direction it almost looks as
if the three-headed dragons have taken
flight we watch as gray worm and a
handful of other unsolidmen walk across
the deck as they make their way into the
city gray worm has a slight smile on his
face he only focuses on the enormous red
Temple of Allure as he walks further and
further down the street it's sitting
high up on its Hill looming over
everyone below
sitting above everything else is drogon
he stretches his wings far and wide as
he soaks up the Rising Sun everyone is
waiting for Daenerys Targaryen to emerge
from the red Temple the 1000 slave
soldiers of the fiery hand are standing
guard outside its massive walls eagerly
awaiting their new orders the crowd
below them has been growing thicker by
the day gray worm and his men remove
their helmets when they reach the city
Square they can see the main entrance
and its great wooden doors that are
engraved with relore's Burning Heart one
of the slave soldiers of the fiery hand
stops them from getting any closer they
wait and watch with everyone else
suddenly the large wooden door swing
open a man in a red silk robe emerges
from within the crowd erupts when they
begin shouting his name benaro banero
banero the unsolidmen look around unsure
of what's Happening as banero raises his
arms in the sky everyone grows silent in
a thunderous voice he says Daenerys
Stormborn is the Fulfillment of an
ancient Prophecy from smoke and salt she
was born to make the world Anew she is
Azor ahai returned in her triumph over
the great other will bring a summer that
will never end and death itself will
bend its knee and all those who die
fighting in her cause shall be reborn as
Daenerys was reborn before your very own
eyes darkness has fallen heavy over the
realm but that Darkness will Flay before
her on this day we will set sail for
Westeros and we shall not return until
the great other is consumed by relore's
great Flames there are six more red
robes that emerge from within the red
Temple as Daenerys removes her Hood gray
worm's eyes begin filling with water he
lets out a long sigh of relief Daenerys
begins walking down the long Stone steps
followed by Oliver's highest ranking
members when they reach their 3 the
fiery hand falls in around them as they
escort Daenerys canvara banero and the
others to their waiting ships drogon
lets out another loud shriek before
leaping High into the sky gray worm and
his unsullied men can only watch as
Daenerys is marched right by them as
Dany nears the shore of Atlantis she
suddenly stops in her tracks when she
sees the black and red sails of House
Targaryen among the other ships there's
at least 100 more ships docked each of
them displaying The Burning Heart of
velor on their sails and Banners
Daenerys begins looking through the
crowd wondering who brought them here
when she spins around her and gray worm
lock eyes now hers begin filling with
water they Embrace each other for a few
moments before Dany says I wasn't sure
if I would ever see you again how did
you know I was here I found out from a
man on the island of noth says gray worm
oh I see says Daenerys with grief in her
voice she holds his hand then says I
wish I could have been there with you
when you said goodbye I should have been
at your side when Jon Snow betrayed you
says gray worm if you will allow me I
would like to be at your side again I
will follow you until my last day your
grace I have nowhere else to go with a
smile on her face Daenerys says then we
shall sail together I still have
unfinished business in Westeros the
scene ends as Daenerys and greyworm walk
across the sand over to their ships in
the following scene we are on a
different ship as it reaches the
southern Shore in Westeros Arya Stark
walks across the deck as the men get
ready to drop its anchor they have made
it to their destination Arya watches as
the waves crash against the Rocks below
an enormous Castle she has only heard
about in Stories the wall is said to be
40 feet thick at its narrowest in near
80 on the seaward face within that
Mighty ball work the kitchens and
stables and yards sheltered safe from
the wind and wave of towers there was
but one a massive drum Tower windowless
where it faced the sea so large that it
was Granary and barracks and feast Hall
and Lord's dwelling all in one it is
crowned by Massive battlements that made
it look from afar like a spiked fist
atopped an up thrust arm as Arya looks
at all of her surroundings the ship's
Captain walks over and stands beside her
welcome to Storm's end my lady says the
captain it is said that this Castle was
built by the same man who constructed
your family's ancestral home did you
know that my lady yes says Arya it was
Brandon the Builder with the help of the
children of the Forest right Azaria says
this they hear a loud shriek from above
Arya has to Shield her eyes from the
Bright Morning Sun as she looks up into
the sky circling right above them is the
same Raven that has been following them
for several weeks when Arya looks back
down she says don't wait for me I thank
you for bringing me this far but I will
not be boarding the ship again I will go
to King's Landing by horse from here I
am sorry I can't be a further service my
lady but as you wish says the captain he
then bows his head before he walks away
this is when Arya notices several men on
horseback riding her way one of these
men is holding a banner that shows the
Stag of House of Baratheon Arya Smiles
then makes her way off the ship as she
walks across the sand only one of the
Riders approaches her while the others
wait on the other side of the beach I
saw your sails early this morning I was
wondering why there was a stark ship
this far south I was not expecting it to
be you my lady I thought you were
heading west says Gendry with a big
smile on his face I was says Arya I
changed my mind well I hope you changed
your mind about accepting my offer says
Gendry Arya cracks a thin smile but she
says no it's not that something else
came up and I may need your help oh
Gendry stopped smiling when he says this
sounds serious what the hell happened
it's my brother bran I think something
is wrong with him says Arya Gendry hops
down off the horse before asking her did
something happen to bran is he okay well
I'm not exactly sure caesaria it doesn't
make any sense but I think bran wants me
dead there is several more moments of
Silence before Gendry says this is very
serious what makes you think he wants
you dead the man who tried to kill me
said he did says Arya maybe the man was
lying says Gendry maybe he did lie
caesaria but what if he wasn't not to
mention that's not the only thing that
happened a raven has been following me
after several more seconds of Silence
Gendry says a raven what does that mean
well if you ride with me to King's
Landing you will see Cesario okay says
gundry I will go but what do you want me
to do once we get there I don't know
cesaria I don't know what to do about
this that seems obvious says Gendry the
fact that you're even here asking me for
help says that you don't know what to do
about this situation I know one thing
says Arya I need to speak with bran
myself I need to look him in his eyes
and ask him why if there is something
wrong with your brother and he does want
you dead then he might not let you enter
King's Landing so easily says gundry the
city will be guarded the scene ends as
Gendry says should I bring some of my
men with us my lady in the next scene we
go back below the ground somewhere in
the north we're following John
ghostorman in Helen Reed as they make
their way through the darkness further
and further south the red eyes of ghosts
are glowing in their flickering Flames
the albino direwolf Lee leads them
through the dark abyss with the men
following closely behind as they're
walking torm and giant Spain looks to
Helen reeden says when will this end it
feels like we have been walking down
here for days well that depends on where
you want to go says Helen Reed you can
access almost any location in Westeros
using this Cave System the children of
the forest dug these out thousands of
years ago even before the first men
arrived in their lands all we need to do
is keep following the werewood self we
will get there much faster than any man
would by horse when we do get there says
John what will we do we don't have an
army it doesn't sound like the children
of the forest want to negotiate they
already made the night King it frightens
me to think of what else they might be
able to do how will we stop them how
will we save my brother bran Helen Reed
doesn't say anything at first he just
keeps walking with his head down as he
slings the item he has been carrying on
his back over his other shoulder finally
after what felt like several minutes
Helen Reed looks over at Jon then says
we will have to make our sacrifices Jon
Snow as I have said before it won't be
easy
stopping these children of the forest
will come with a heavy cost we won't be
able to end this without Daenerys
Targaryen and her Dragon this makes Jon
think about when he last Saw Daenerys
when he stabbed her while they were
standing in front of the Iron Throne he
thinks about what that choice cost him
he looks over a torment giant Spain he
thinks about what it cost him when he
let the wildlings through the wall at
Castle black he then looks over at Helen
Reed who is adjusting the large item on
his shoulder again and says what
sacrifices have you made my Lord again
there are several moments of Silence
before Helen Reed says anything Helen
Reed looks into John's eyes then says
there were many Jon Snow unfortunately I
made a great sacrifice that has cost me
dearly with grief in his voice Helen
Reed says I had to sacrifice my very own
but before he can finish his sentence
some noises are heard in the distance
the hair on the back of ghost starts to
stand up as his glowing red eyes cut
through the darkness ahead Jon grabs
long claw unsure of what they're about
to face they can see there is some light
bouncing off the walls about a hundred
feet in front of them there are a few
shadowy figures moving behind their
light John looks at them with a hint of
fear in his eyes they're not able to
make out anyone's faces that's when he
shouts make yourself known before you
take another step who are you why are
you down here suddenly they hear a voice
shout back at them we are here on behalf
of our Queen Sansa Stark who goes there
this scene ends as John says I am her
brother Jon Snow in the following scene
we go back down to King's Landing a full
moon sits high above the red key we
watch as the hand of the king Tyrion
Lannister reluctantly walks across the
Great Hall there are hundreds of Ravens
all over the old throne room since there
is still a very large hole in the side
of the red keep the Ravens are able to
fly in and out of the Great Hall with
ease they all began shaking at Tyrion
who feels an enormous sense of dread as
he makes his way to King Branch Chambers
he knows this will not be an easy
conversation but he has to ask bran
himself what happened why did Braun die
so suddenly there are three star
Guardsmen standing outside of Brian's
door a few of them are the same Stark
men who were drinking with Brawn at the
end one of them says we have been
expecting you Lord Tyrion why would you
be expecting me as Tyrion as the Stark
Guardsman opens the door he says you
will see go ahead and step inside as he
walks into Branch Chambers the Stark
Guardsman follows behind him when
they're all inside they shut the door
Lord Tyrion watches nervously as one of
them locks it when he looks across the
room he sees Brian sitting there in his
chair silently gazing Into the Fire he
sees there is even more Stark Guardsmen
inside the room with him one of the
Stark Guardsmen throws something for
from across the room it lands in front
of tyrion's feet spilling out onto the
floor when he looks down he sees there
is a small sack with golden dragons all
around it when he looks back up bran is
staring into his eyes with a very
unsettling look about his face it makes
Tyrion feel uneasy as he tries to figure
out what's happening that's when the
Stark Guardsman near bran step aside
revealing there has been someone
standing behind them Lord Tyrion
immediately recognizes the man who is
dressed in rags it's Damien the man who
said he witnessed bronze death his hands
are bound at the wrist his face has been
bloodied and bruised even the front of
his pants are soaking wet finally Tyrion
aspiran what is the meaning of this with
a smile on his face bran says Where Were
You Lord Tyrion where was you at when
Brawn fell I was in my Chambers sir
Brianne was there with me says Tyrion
why are you asking me this Damien
flinches as one of the Stark Guardsmen
throws his arm around his shoulder this
star Guardsman says that's not what our
new friend has been telling us really
sisterion as he looks at all of Damien's
injuries he says he doesn't look like a
new friend he looks like a dog that has
had all the fight whipped right out of
him he then looks back at bran and says
what did you force him to say about me
the man said you gave him those golden
dragons to have sir Braun murdered says
bran this is nonsense Shield Tyrion why
would I want my own friend dead I gave
him that so I could buy his silencer
Grace we know you did says one of the
star Guardsmen you needed his silence so
he would keep your secrets safe we know
that now no yells Tyrion that's not how
it happened while looking at bran he
says I wanted him to keep your Secret
Safe Your Grace I did not want all of
King's Landing thinking the new King was
involved in murdering one of his own
council members before I could find out
out what really happened this entire
country has been through enough the Mad
King the drunken King Robert the
sadistic Joffrey my sister Cersei and
that was before Daenerys burned King's
Landing down to the ground I thought we
were finally done with all of this I did
not want everyone thinking we were back
to our old ways of backstabbing and
murdering each other I guess I was wrong
again
what has happened to you Brian I thought
you would be great for the realm King
bran has a haunting look in his eyes
it's as if all of his life has left them
the scene ends after brain says what
happened to bran
he died in a cave years ago he looks at
one of the star Guardsmen then says have
Lord Tyrion thrown into the black cells
he will be executed for the murder of
Sir bronify Garden
in the final scene of this episode we go
back to the Isle of faces all of the red
leaves on the where Woods are
illuminated from the full moon that
hangs high in the sky above the God's
eye the green men are still silently
staining their watch over the sacred
Island we won't be focusing on them in
this final scene however now we move
inward into the center of the island
where the woods are much denser than
they are on the shore of the lake the
shrieking sound of ravens can be heard
from the branches above in the very
center of the Isle of faces there is a
massive werewood standing over 300 feet
tall and nearly 30 foot wide and its
base the face on the front of it has a
mouth that's so big a grown man could
easily stand inside of it its eyes are
frightening as it gazes into the fire
before it surrounding the massive
werewood is a Grove of seven more where
Woods all facing inward at the fire this
is where the children of the forest
would hold their sacred ceremonies and
even their sacrifices to their gods
which they believe are the werewoods
themselves as the flames and the fire
crack and hiss very large Shadows begin
to move all around us suddenly there are
glowing blue eyes emerging from the
Shadows around the werewood Grove the
little green men are not the only ones
here this is when we see there are
dozens and dozens of white walkers
riding on the backs of giant Elks whose
eyes also have a blue glow to them there
is something slightly different about
these white walkers they don't look
exactly like all of the other ones we
have seen before they're gaunt and heart
is old bones even their armor seems to
change color as they move around on
their massive Elks one second they look
white as new fallen snow the next second
they were black as a shadow white
shadows in the darkness they have a sort
of Elegance to them only in a very
frightening kind of way these white
walkers are the children's chosen ones
who were selected to guard their sacred
Isle of faces no one knows what they're
capable of but they will find out soon
enough
there are several lights flickering in
the distance as seven Shadows move ahead
the roots of the werewood that are
running along the ceiling are thicker
here the red sap-like substance that was
dripping down from them is now Frozen in
the shape of icicles it looks like there
are 1 000 bloody knives hanging upside
down like bats this scene begins as we
see Jon ghost tormund Helen Reed and the
Stark Guardsmen Sansa had sent through
the secret passageway in winterfell's
Crypt John's albino direwolf is still
leading the way when he looks back at
Jon his blood red eyes glisten in the
light Helen Reed checks to make sure the
long item he has been carrying on his
back is still wrapped up in The Furs
after he secures it again he slings it
back over his other shoulder how did you
get down here ask John where did my
sister want you to go the commander of
the star Guardsman says we got here
through winterfell's Crypt Queen Sansa
wanted us to find out where this ended
we had been searching down here for what
felt like a fortnight we ran out of food
yesterday we're lucky we ran into you
when we did I don't understand says John
how did you get here through
winterfell's Crypt we found a secret
passageway says to the commander of the
star Guardsmen the lowest level of your
family's Crypt had been collapsed after
we moved all the dirt and Rubble we
found a hidden tunnel that let out into
here John looks at Helen Reed and asks
him the children of the forest Helen
Reed begins nodding his head in
agreement that's not all we found says
the commander of the star Guardsmen
there are some bizarre drawings on the
wall as well drawings ask John what were
they we will show you in a minute says
the star Guardsmen were just about there
before they take another step forward
Helen sets his hand on Jon's shoulder
then says I know you want to see your
sister but we can't stay here long we
must go south right away I understand
says John that's when ghosts vanishes
into the darkness that lies ahead after
they walk another hundred feet the Stark
Guardsman says it's this way he hold
holds up his light higher revealing the
hidden passageway that's on the left
when the six men enter they see the
small bright red eyes of ghost up ahead
the icy floor beneath their feet begins
cracking softly as they move forward the
direwolf is now sitting down as its eyes
study the wall beside him as Jon gets
closer he says what is a boy what do you
see when Jon holds up his own light he
sees the drawings that were left on the
wall thousands of years ago he sees a
man standing in front of a castle that
looks a lot like Winterfell only much
smaller he sees a giant werewood
surrounded by a Grove of more where
Woods that are all facing inward he then
sees a child of the forest holding the
head of what looks like another child of
the forest the commander of the star
Guardsman says Queen Sansa was wondering
what these drawings meant the maester
sent sketches of them down to the
Citadel but as far as I know there has
been no response he then looks at Jon
and says do any of you know what they
mean why would the children of the
forest behead one of their own Jon looks
at Helen Reed who doesn't say anything
right away he grabs the long item from
his back then slings it over his other
shoulder after sucking in a deep breath
Helen looks into Commander's eyes then
says we all have to make our sacrifices
he then looks away while wiping the
tears away from his own eyes Jon doesn't
want to ask him any further questions he
can see that the Lord is visibly shaken
he shifts his Focus back at the star
Guardsmen let's go find my sister says
John as the men enter the lowest level
of the crypt John notices ghost is now
sitting in front of a statue when Jon
walks over near him he says I always
wondered what was down here I have never
been on this level before but I've seen
it in my dreams he holds up the light
again now shining it on the face made of
stone he examines the man's features for
a few moments a sense of dread washes
over Jon before he looks away from the
statue's stern face he looks very
familiar Jon says nervously well he
should set storm in giant Spain he's a
stark just like you Joe John starts
looking behind the statue after he
notices it's been broken this is when
Helen Reed says he's not in there Jon
Snow this wasn't just any Stark this is
Brandon Stark the first Stark of
Winterfell who was the old king of
winter you're right says John there
isn't anyone inside the Statue but I
think there is something laying at the
bottom of it here hold this light John
says to one of the star Guardsmen he
reaches down inside of the broken statue
then grabs what was left behind the
Frost has it frozen and stiff but the
icy black leather still shines under the
flame Jon unfolds it then he holds it up
for all to see it's a cloak made of
black leather and black fur John's eyes
open wide when he suddenly realizes what
it is I've been looking at those all of
my life says storm and giant Spain
that's from the Night's Watch it is says
John who is now looking over at Helen
Reed again when I was leaving for the
wall My Father John stops then corrects
himself when I was leaving for the wall
lord eddard said the Starks have been
Manning the wall for thousands of years
Grace honor serving in the Night's Watch
the Starks and man the wall for
thousands of years
I wonder when this Brandon Stark was
there a very long time ago says Helen
Reed roughly 8 000 years ago Brandon
Stark was the Lord Commander just like
you he then looks into the eyes of the
statue's stern face the scene ends after
Helen Reed says he was the 13th Lord
commander of the night fort Jon Snow in
the next scene we are back in the South
right outside of the castle walls of
Storm's end the sun is shining the sky
is blue and black wings and white eyes
are seen circling above suddenly The
Raven lets out a loud shriek as it falls
from the sky when the bird slams into
the Earth its black feathers go flying
back up into the air we see a footstep
onto the Raven before we see a hand yank
and arrow free from the Fallen bird it's
Arya Stark who Smiles at Gendry as she
sees him walking over with a few horses
I don't want any Ravens following us
caesaria I will shoot down as many as I
can but will you rely the same message
to your men have them shoot down any
Ravens they see I think it would be best
if Brian doesn't know when we will
arrive I will my lady says Gendry and
stop calling me my lady Aria says
stubbornly genjury laughs and says I'm
sorry old habits are hard to break my
men are mounted and ready shall we leave
Arya gives a head nod then says we shall
Gendry hands over the reins to a brown
stallion before climbing on the back of
his own right over their shoulders is a
very large formation of men following
behind them there's maybe 500 or fewer
this is where the King's Road Begins the
banners of house Baratheon are flapping
hard in the wind there certainly isn't
the first time a member from Al Stark
and a member from house Baratheon went
down this road as they made their way to
King's Landing in hopes of bringing back
some sort of balance to the realm Gendry
looks over at Arya as they ride side by
side on their horses he says before we
left King's Landing you said you were
leaving Westeros and sailing west I
wasn't sure if I would ever see you
again I know these aren't the best
circumstances but I'm glad you're here
so am I caesaria while smiling what
should I do when we arrive in the
capital ask Andrew what's your strategy
will we storm the gates will we take
over the city like our father is before
us no says Arya well then good says
Gendry because we don't have the numbers
for all that I will simply demand to
speak to the king says Arya I still
don't actually know if it was Bran who
sent the Assassin to kill me I have to
keep reminding myself that the man who
attacked me might have been lying if
only the Raven wasn't following me I
know that's bran watching over me spying
on my every move but I just don't
understand why it sounds like your
brother may look at you as a threat says
Gendry Arya flashes a look of Doubt
gendry's way she says why would you say
something like that well says gundry you
did Kill the night King and bran had a
front row seat he knows exactly what
you're capable of that still doesn't
explain why my brother would feel
threatened by me says Arya we weren't
enemies I had no reason to fight him
Gendry looks scenario's eyes an ominous
feeling washed over him as he says
you're right Arya you had no reason to
fight him but now you do the scene ends
after he says I just hope you don't get
me killed in the following scene we go
back to King's Landing to see how things
are unraveling there the sun is sitting
high in the sky overlooking the red keep
and the city below there is still a
large crowd gathered right outside of
the Castle's walls the atmosphere in
King's Landing is charged with
electricity again everyone is a buzz now
that they're wondering how and why the
new master of coin went flying from the
balcony of the king's Chambers as you
can imagine rumors are already beginning
to spread across the capital Brienne and
Padre are outside together still
Gathering as much information as they
can we hear one man say he heard that
the little imp had Brawn killed after
fighting over an old debt that he owed
we hear a different man say he heard
Braun jump because he was heartbroken
Brienne immediately rolls her eyes she
did not know bronwell but she does know
that would be the last thing that would
ever happen we then hear an old woman
say she heard a thousand Ravens lifted
him up into the sky then dropped him on
his head I think we've heard enough for
one day Brianne says sarcastically thank
you for the information we will inform
the king Brienne then glances over at
sir Podrick and says let's go back
inside as they head for the Castle's
gate they are suddenly approached by
another man who has a hood down low over
his face when he gets within a few feet
of them he holds out his fist Brienne
grabs the hilt of her sword ready for
action but the unknown man opens his
hand dropping a crumble note at their
feet before walking off Brianne grabs
the letter from the ground then opens it
when she looks over for the hooded man
she notices he has already vanished
behind the crowd she looks at Podrick
who is just as confused as she is
Brienne looks back down at the letter
then reads it aloud it states the
answers you are looking for lie in the
hands of your hand this doesn't make any
sense as Berean the only thing in my
hand is this letter she crumbles the
note in her fist then drops it onto the
ground and walks away wait says sir
Podrick who is already grabbing the
letter and opening it again he starts
mumbling the words to himself the
answers you are looking for lie in the
hands of your hand it's just a stupid
riddle let's go Brienne says angrily
this is when Podrick says we can go but
we must find Lord Tyrion right away they
walk inside the red keep as they make
their way across the throne room dozens
of ravens begin shrieking over and over
again right where the Iron Throne used
to sit there must be a hundred Ravens
gathered around in a circle looking at
something on the ground when they get
closer to the steps they notice there is
some blood on the floor there is even
some blood dripping down the steps some
of the Ravens begin flying away when
they hear Brienne walking up the stairs
that's when she realizes they are
feasting on something the sound of
Brienne unsheathing her sword makes all
of the Ravens fly away at once there is
a lifeless body lying on the ground she
looks over at Podrick in disgust
unfortunately the Ravens have left this
man's face unrecognizable even his eyes
are missing the one thing she does
notice is the man is dressed in rags
that are soaked in blood his ragged
clothes are the only thing he has left
but it doesn't help them identify who
the man was follow me says Brienne as
she walks away with urgency they move
down the hallway before they ascend the
flight of stairs that lead to the hand
of the king's Chambers when they reach
Lord tyrion's door bran knocks on it
loudly the door must not have been
locked or fully shut because it slowly
starts to open as they step inside they
immediately realize Lord Tyrion isn't
here however someone has recently been
in this room everything is a mess the
bed has been knocked over and flipped
upside down the feathers that were
inside his bedding are scattered all
across the room and everything that was
inside the dressers have been spilled
out onto the floor someone has been in
here looking for something says Brienne
his Chambers did not look like this the
night we heard Braun scream through the
open window what scream a deep voice
says from behind when Brian Podrick look
back at the door they see there are now
three men standing there watching them
Brienne recognizes the men their
leftovers from the Stark's household
guard they're the same three men who
arrested Lord Tyrion Lannister inside
Branch Chambers Brian says where did you
get that armor the men smile at each
other before one of them says we are now
sworn Brothers of the kingsguard thanks
to your grace he gave us our white
cloaks then commanded us to find you we
will need you to come with us he's
waiting for both of you in his Chambers
everything inside Berean is screaming at
her to grab her sword she doesn't trust
these men and she knows it's written all
over her face she looks over at Podrick
who is hesitating as well after you my
lady says one of the Stark men while
stepping aside the scene ends as they
reluctantly follow the men out of Lord
Tyrion Lannister's chamber in the next
scene we are somewhere out at Sea it
begins with us seeing an enormous Shadow
flying over a fleet of ships drogon's
black scales are shining like obsidian
under the morning sun the dragon swoops
down low over the sails as he begins
Gliding Over The Water below Daenerys
steps out onto the deck of one of
rolor's ships she leans against the
railing before she looks out over the
deep blue sea all around them Dany
smiles when she looks at drogon who
seems to be bigger and stronger than
ever right over her shoulder are dozens
of more ships some of them are flying
the banners of the three-headed dragon
while the bulk of them are displaying
the banners of the Fiery Heart all one
thousand slave soldiers from the fiery
hand are sailing with them as well as
many other followers and high-ranking
members of relore greyworm suddenly
appears from below the deck when he
spots Daenerys leaning against the
railing he walks over to her he has
vowed to never leave her side again the
rest of the unsullied men are on Danny's
old ships following right behind them as
they make their way back to Westeros
thank you for joining me says Daenerys
when gray worm stands next to her he
bows his head before saying Your Grace
Daenerys and gray worm both look across
the ship on the other side of the deck
as they see canvara walking their way
kenvara is joined by a very large man we
have never seen before he stands well
over six feet tall with skin as black as
drogon and hair as white as snow on his
face and forehead are tattoos of red and
orange Flames the black man's red
Scarlet robe has satin orange flames on
it as well in his right hand is a six
foot iron staff with a dragon's head on
the end of it he looks spectacular in a
frightening kind of way as they approach
Danny and greyworm kenvara says your
grace I would like you to meet makaro as
he looks at Dany with his shining dark
eyes he says in his deep voice the Lord
of Light has shown me your worth every
night in my fires I Glimpse the glory
that awaits you canvara then reaches out
and grabs gray Worm by his arm as she
squeezes his muscles she says I hope you
and your men are ready because as
Darkness awaits us we are says gray worm
he looks in Danny's eyes and says you
still haven't said who we will be
fighting kenvara Smiles then she says
why don't I show you instead she reaches
down and grabs his hand greyworm follows
her over to a burning Brazier in the
center of the ship look into where
Laura's great fire and behold everything
that is ready to strike us down the red
and orange Flames reflect in greyworm's
eyes his mouth hangs open as he stares
into the fire in disbelief after a few
more moments of watching a sudden anger
flashes across his face gray worm slams
The Brazier down spilling hot Embers all
over the deck of the ship we see three
slave soldiers of the fiery hand rush
over and begin stomping on the Embers
before the wooden ship catches fire with
a look of shock on her face Dany says
what happened what did you see whatever
it was best believe you will see it
again says makaro grayworm looks at
Danny his eyes are now filled with a
hatred the scene ends after he says I
saw Jon Snow he was riding on the back
of drogon in the following scene we are
back in Winterfell ghost John torman
Helen Reed and the Stark Guardsmen
emerge from below the castle there is so
much activity in the courtyard no one
even notices them at first Jon can't
help but crack a smile when he sees how
alive the castle is again there are men
drilling with wood and steel swords in
the yard there are Cooks tending their
vegetables in the glass garden there's
Restless dogs running back and forth in
the kennels and there's even some women
gossiping beside the washing well it
almost made him feel at home again but
he remembers what Helen Reed said they
cannot stay here for long suddenly he
hears a surprise voice from up above
John is that you Sansa who is followed
by maester walcan Rushes down the stairs
to greet him the yard grows silent and
everyone watches as John and Sansa
Embrace each other what happened at
Sansa why did you leave Castle black
John looks at her with a bit of sadness
in his eyes he says we have a lot to
discuss he then looks around the yard at
all the watchful eyes staring back at
him Sansa finally notices everyone is
looking at them the silence ends and
everyone immediately goes back to work
now that they have Queen sansa's
attention maybe we should go speak in
the godswood says John as they begin
walking ghost starts out in front of
them when they reach the godswood ghost
is already there sniffing the ground
around the werewood John notices that
right away but he focuses on the task at
hand Your Grace I would like you to meet
Lord Helen Reed John steps aside while
Helen Reed bows his head you were
friends with my father said Sansa I
remember hearing stories about you when
I was younger Helen reads Smiles then
says I Was Your Grace your father was a
great man it would be an honor for me to
serve his children what brings you all
this way as Sansa why are you with John
did you join the Night's Watch know your
grace says Lord Holland we're here
because of your brother Brian he's in
grave Danger John has agreed to help me
save him or so we hope sansa's eyes fill
with fear as she looks over at John what
does he mean as Sansa why would bran be
in grave danger our enemies have been
defeated he is surrounded by soldiers
and guards day and night I made sure of
that myself I left behind some of our
own household guard Brian joined his
kingsguard not mine who would harm him
there are things in this world that are
difficult to explain says Alan Reid
Brian isn't the same brother you grew up
with anymore I know says Sansa bran said
the exact same thing to me when he said
he was the three-eyed Raven I need you
to explain it to me help me understand
so I can help you the children of the
forest did not disappear says Helen Reed
your brother met some of them in a cave
Beyond the Wall they did everything they
could to help him defeat the night King
but it wasn't enough to end the Great
War there are more children of the
forest hiding out in the south on the
Isle of faces they were helping the
night King and his army of the Dead all
along they are still working against us
as we speak and they have now entered
your brother's mind he will continue to
lose more and more of himself the longer
he stays in the South not only is your
brother in danger but so is everyone
else around him Sans is befuddled she
says what do they want there is a long
moment of silence before Helen Reed says
Valar morghulis Your Grace all men must
die we're living on their lands and they
will do everything in their power to get
them back we have to get brain out of
King's Landing before it's too late how
do we know bran hasn't left King's
Landing already how do we know bran
isn't with the children of the force
right now as Sansa there's only one way
to find out says Lord Helen Reed he
looks in John's eyes then looks at the
werewood and nods his head in its
direction you were given the bowl of
wearwood seeds for a reason Jon Snow
go set your hand on its face look
through its eyes and tell us what you
see Jon slowly looks over at the white
and red werewood he remembers what
happened when he leaned his head against
one and fell asleep
he can see ghost is still underneath it
sniffing around at the ground he walks
over next to him then kneels down this
is very reminiscent of when John knelt
in front of the werewood Beyond the Wall
when he set his Night's Watch vows he
takes in a deep breath then lays his
hand over the face his head snaps back
and his eyes roll in his head he's
immediately thrown into a vision the
first thing Jon sees is a massive
werewood standing taller than any of the
other ones he's ever seen before it's on
an island surrounded by a Blue Lake a
very large Shadow soars over the water
and right behind that seems to be
another very large Shadow he sees seven
children of the forest standing in a
circle on a beach right behind them
above the Rocks is a castle it looks a
lot like Dragonstone he can see bran
sitting in a werewood throne like the
one in the three-eyed Ravens cave Bran's
eyes are rolled back in his head he can
see Braun arguing with three star
Guardsmen on a balcony overlooking a
city he then sees Braun falling from
that balcony he sees gray worms standing
in front of him he looks enraged now he
sees the streets of King's Landing right
where the old SEPTA Baylor used to sit
bran is sitting there in his wheelchair
Brianne Podrick and Lord Tyrion
Lannister are there as well but before
he can make out everything that's
happening he snaps out of the Visions
John's hand drops from the werewood's
face he's now gasping for breath
everyone rushes over to him Helen Reed
bends down and throws an arm over his
shoulder are you okay ass Lord Holland
Jon looks around at his surroundings
remembering where he is he slowly
controls his breathing then says I'm
fine help me stand up Helen Reed and
torment giantsbane helped Jon back on
his feet Sansa looks a bit stunned she's
never seen anything like this before are
you able to tell us what you saw says
Helen Reed yes says John I did see bran
he's still in King's Landing good says
Helen Reed we still have time I don't
think we have much time John says
doubtfully bran had his master of coin
thrown from his balcony why says Sansa
that doesn't make any sense I don't know
says John but I think he's trying to
wipe out his entire small Council Sansa
is even more shock than before she says
what makes you say that John what else
did you see the sound of grief comes
from John's voice when he says Lord
Tyrion Lannister has been arrested I saw
him kneeling Over The Executioner's
block Helen Reed immediately stands back
up when he hears this he says we must
leave now everyone begins leaving the
godswood but Jon stops them before they
make another step that's not all Jon
says loudly I also saw Brienne and
Podrick they were standing right behind
Lord Tyrion there is dread written all
over sansa's face after a moment of
silence Sansa nervously says what
happened John
the scene ends after he says they had
nooses around their necks in the final
scene of this episode we go back inside
the red keep of King's Landing we're in
King bran Stark's Chambers on one side
of the room bran is sitting there
surrounded by his new sworn Brothers of
the kingsguard on the other side of the
room Brienne and Podrick are standing
there searching for answers is
everything all right your grace ask
Brienne in a flat voice Brian says what
would make you think something was wrong
well something is wrong says Burien you
throw samwell's book Into the Fire I
know I don't know you that well but
that's not like you sir Brown if I
Garden Fell from your balcony there is a
bloody dead man laying in the old Throne
Room Lord Tyrion seems to be missing and
his Chambers looked as if they have been
ramsacked I'm just trying to understand
what is happening around here Brian
stares at her and looks right through
her with his unsympathetic eyes he says
it sounds like there is a Ghost Inside
the red key Brienne stands her ground
not allowing Bran or has meant to
frighten her maybe it was a ghost or
maybe it was a wolf in sheep's clothing
whereas Lord Tyrion bran cracks a thin
smile before saying he's sitting in the
black cells he has been charged for the
murder of Sir Baron this is nonsense
shoutsbury in I was with Lord Tyrion in
his Chambers when we heard the scream we
ran outside together we discovered
bronze lifeless body laying on the
street below your balcony together I
know for a fact Tyrion Lannister did not
do this brain stopped smiling one of his
new kingsguard members says Lady Brienne
cannot be trusted your grace she has
always favored the Lannisters rumor has
it she has even laid with a Lannister
Berean looks at the man with eyes as
cold as ice she says I have no love for
the Lannisters denied all you want says
bran I seen it myself that sword says
you're a liar did you know that sword
was made from my family's ancestral
sword after the Lannister's bastard seed
butchered my my father bran now shifts
his Focus over to Sir Podrick he says
you're a lion as well you was once the
Squire for Lord Tyrion Lannister and now
you stand here beside another what
should I call you anyways Lady Brienne a
lion in sheep's clothing Brienne looks
into Brand's Sola size then says
whatever treachery you think I may have
done sir Podrick had nothing to do with
it that's enough says the man of the
kingsguard I think they both should hang
your grace in a low voice brain says who
are you loyal to Lady Brienne who are
you sworn to guard with your life Lord
Tyrion of House Lannister or your king
you must choose here and now which house
does that Valerian steel really fight
for what are you asking of Me Your Grace
Asbury in after a few moments of Silence
bran says Lord Tyrion is to be executed
for the charge of murder I want the
lion's head mounted on my wall will you
take it for your king or die next to him
you must choose take that sword and slay
the Imp or be hanged for a betrayer the
sword or the news brienne's eyes fill up
with water if she wasn't frightened
before she is now finally brain sucks in
a ragged breath and says I will not make
that choice there was another long
silence after this Brand's new
kingsguard members look at each other in
disbelief this episode ends after brain
says hang them
there is a full moon in the night sky
sitting directly above the massive
wearwood at the center of the God's eye
Its Reflection can be seen on the lake
giving us just enough light to see
what's standing on the shore no
different than any other night the green
men are standing their silent watch over
the ancient werewolves while they stand
their silent watch over the sacred
Island the black green and red dragon
glass in their Spears is glowing under
the moonlit Sky everything in everyone
on the island is silent except for the
thousands of red leaves Dancing In The
Wind the faces on the where Woods are as
frightening as ever their blood-filled
eyes are staring back at us as a red
like substance strips down from them
onto the ground we then begin to make
our way into the middle of the God's eye
all of the white walkers who were once
here riding on the backs of their giant
Elks are now gone there is still a very
large fire burn turning at the center of
the island where westeros's largest
where wood sits surrounded by seven more
where Woods that are all facing inward
at the orange and red Flames the face on
this mass of where wood looks horrific
its mouth is so large a grown man could
easily walk right through it without
ducking as we stare into its blood red
eyes that are full of secrets and
ancient wisdom hundreds of ravens
suddenly explode from the werewood's
gaping mouth their black wings fill the
sky and their loud shrieking brings an
end to this Silent Night this is when
the children of the forest begin to
emerge from the woods their great big
golden Cat's eyes are now glowing in the
shadows the sound of branches breaking
in leaves crunching can be heard as they
make their way to the center of the
aisle there are seven of them each
holding dragonglass weapons of their own
one by one they begin jumping into the
mouth of the massive werewood sitting in
the middle of the Grove as we follow
them inside we immediately notice the
werewood's mouth is filled with hundreds
of skulls of those who were once
sacrificed to the old gods over the
centuries the inside of this giant
werewood drops down into a Cave System
like the one we have seen out Beyond the
Wall only this one has more light
allowing us to see much further into the
dark abyss the seven children of the
forest begin ascending down deep into
the Earth the scene ends as we watch
them vanish into the unknown only they
know what lies ahead but you will find
out soon enough in the following scene
we are back in the capital of Westeros
the sun is slowly starting to rise over
King's Landing as the city begins to
wake up there are men and women opening
up their small shops and markets for
business there are wagons full of new
arrivals entering the city every day
their small children running through the
streets as some older kids are chasing
behind them once again the scent of Rawl
sewage and freshly baked bread hangs
heavy in the morning air there's about a
dozen black Ravens circling in the sky
above the red keep as Samwell and Davos
emerge from within the castle they begin
walking over to the main gate where
there are some men of the city watch
standing guard Davos began saying
something to Sam but he doesn't hear
what he says because he's busy looking
over at the ground where he remembers
seeing sir Braun's lifeless body the
dried blood that was once on the Stone
Street has been washed away but Sam will
never forget what he saw that day he
suddenly stops walking then looks over
at the city watch to make sure they are
out of earshot before he interrupts
Davos by asking him have heard any new
developments regarding what happened to
Sir Braun has anyone found out what
actually happened I wish I could give
you that information says sir Davos but
I'm afraid I do not know I was about to
ask you the same thing what about Lord
Tyrion says Samwell have you spoke to
him about it wood that I could says or
Davos but I haven't spoke to him about
it either as a matter of fact I haven't
seen Lord Tyrion since the day we
discovered Braun had fallen from your
Grace's balcony Sam nervously looks into
davos's eyes then Whispers I'm not so
sure he fell sir Braun would have no
reason to be in King Branch Chambers or
on his balcony unless he was sent for
Davos slowly looks up at the red key as
he thinks about what Sam just said
you're right Davos says reluctantly the
balcony has a railing that stops anyone
from falling over so easily he fell
because someone shoved him Sam says
dreadfully they are suddenly interrupted
by the sound of riders arriving at the
main gate as Sam begins walking over he
shouts open the gates these men are with
me when the three Riders Dismount from
their horses the guards from the city
watch opened the gates allowing them
inside one of these Riders removes a
letter from inside his sleeve before
handing it over to Sam without saying a
word Sam smiles and nods his head at The
Men Who immediately began mounting their
horses again Davos looks confused by
this brief interaction Sam starts
walking away as he breaks the wax seal
on the letter wondering what just
happened Dava stops him demanding to
know who those men were and why they
hand delivered him this letter Sam grabs
him by the arm then walks him away from
the main gate where the men of the city
watch are still standing guard Sam looks
around making sure no one else can hear
them in a low voice he says it's from
The Citadel Davos is visibly unsatisfied
with that answer so he says well what's
it about what's with all of this secrecy
Sam takes a moment before he says when I
left the Citadel let's just say I
borrowed some of their books what do you
mean borrowed Davos says doubtfully Fine
says Sam I stole some books from the
Citadel but I had every intention of
giving them back once I was done with
them however something happened to one
of the books before I could do that one
of them was about the legends of the
long night I noticed something very
interesting on the front of that book so
I brought it to King bran hoping he
could help me figure out what it meant
but for some reason he threw the book
Into the Fire this is when I first
started thinking something might be
wrong with bran so I wrote a letter to
the Citadel asking them if they could
give me any more information on the
subject the only thing is I never heard
back from them that's when I started
thinking bran might be intercepting all
of the Ravens coming in and out of
King's Landing since the Ravens were
compromised I sent writers of my own
they hand delivered my messages then
brought me back the arch maester's
findings I don't know why but I believe
brand and doesn't want me to know the
answers I am looking for well I may
finally hold them in my hand Davos has
taken aback by all of this he shakes his
head in disbelief before wiping the
sweat from his forehead after a long
deep breath Deva says what does the
letter say sam stands beside him then
holds it up for both of them to read
we're not able to make out everything
the letter says but we do see a few
lines that are written down we can see
it says in regards to the book about the
legends of the long night then further
down the letter we're also able to see
it says the green men on the Isle of
faces now we focus on Davos am Sam Sam's
face as they finish reading the letter
Sam's eyes widen and his mouth hangs
open as he sucks in a deep breath we
follow his eyes as they leave the letter
they slowly look up at the red keep
above them this scene ends when Sam
notices bran is now sitting out on his
balcony staring down at them in the
following scene we are back in
Winterfell We are following Helen Reed
as he makes his way across the courtyard
the grounds are now flooded with how
Stark soldiers and bannermen of the
north it looks as if they're getting
ready for war dozens of men are getting
fitted for armor dozens of other men are
handing out dragonglass weapons that
were left over from the long night
battle While others are mounting their
horses Helen raid heads for the godswood
where Jon and Sansa are standing before
the werewood when he notices they are
still in conversation he stops for a
moment so they can finish he grabs the
large item from his back before dropping
it down onto the ground he checks to
make sure it's still fully wrapped up in
the fur after securing it again he
slings it back over his shoulder another
minute goes by then Helen Reed finally
says I'm sorry to disturb you your grace
but the men are just about settled and
ready we must leave soon Jon looks at
sanzo with a bit of sadness in his eyes
before opening up his arms and giving
her a big hug the air is thick with a
soul in silence Lord Helen Reed watches
as John Whispers something in her ear
when they let go of each other Jon looks
at Helen Reed and says I'm ready John
and Sansa began walking over to where
Lord Allen Reed is standing on the other
side of the godswood the leaves and snow
crunches underneath their feet with each
and every step Jon suddenly stops when
he feels something hard under his foot
he lifts his boot then reaches down and
grabs something that was half buried in
the ground as he begins to brush away
the snow he immediately recognizes what
it is Sansa says you're not the first
one to step on that I also found it
before but I wasn't sure what it was
from John looks over at Helen Ray who is
looking at the object in his hands John
says this was the night Kings I saw him
wearing this beyond the wall and then
again here in Winterfell it must have
fallen from his uniform after he was
stabbed by Arya this reminds Jon of what
else he found not long ago he grabbed
something he has had stashed inside of
his fur Overcoat slanza can't believe
what John is holding in his hands she
says is that Brands where did you find
that it was inside a cave out Beyond the
Wall it was where bran met the
three-eyed Raven the same cave where I
met the children of the forest and Lord
Alan Reed in one hand John is holding
the night King's metallic symbol that he
wore around his neck in the other hand
he is holding Bran's metallic Stark
choker that he wore on his neck he
studies both of them for a few moments
before Sansa finally grabs his arm and
says John I sent Ravens down to King's
Landing hoping I could speak with bran
when they were left unanswered I sent
men down there as well they still aren't
back from the capital
they won't be coming back Helen Reed
says ominously sons's eyes fill with
anger as she says what how do you know
that I'm sorry your grace but I did say
your brother bran is in grave danger if
your men aren't back yet then they're
dead already Lord Highland then looks
back in John's eyes and says we must
leave now the three of them silently
exit the godswood John and Helen's
horses are already waiting for them in
the courtyard as well as all the men who
are now leaving with them right before
they mount their horses Sansa stops
Helen Reed she says do you think this
will be enough men I've sent out more
Ravens but I'm not sure if they will
make it to their destinations Lord Allen
looks around at all of the men gathered
inside the courtyard and the men who are
mounted just outside of the gate there's
maybe 700 soldiers or fewer I won't lie
to you your grace I honestly don't know
if this will be enough but it's
certainly better than what we had before
we stopped here this amount of men does
help but it will also slow us down the
underground system isn't big enough for
this many men we will have to find a way
to make do what the circumstances we are
in your grace thank you cesssonza Lord
Howlin bows his head before knocking his
heels against his horse as John and
Sansa watched the men begin to leave the
courtyard she says one last thing to
John before he goes south this scene
ends right after Sansa says John I want
you to get our brother out of King's
Landing bring him home
as John and his horse were leaving
through winterfell's main gate he looks
back over his shoulder then says I will
in the next scene we go back out at Sea
where there are roughly 100 ships
sailing under the bright sunlight the
sun's reflection is bouncing off the
deep blue sea but it suddenly swallowed
up by a massive Shadow flying above
drogon soars across the sky as he
overlooks all of the ships down below
he's drinking up the morning sun as he
stretches his wings and Glides through
the hazy air the sails of the Fiery
Heart and the three-headed dragon are
flapping hard in the wind the scene
begins as we see canvara standing on the
deck of the ship and our long Scarlet
silk robe we can see the sun in her eyes
as she glares into the sky at drogon she
stares at the Dragon for several moments
but she finally looks away when she
hears Daenerys walking her way kenvara
notices Dany has a look of discomfort
written all over her face as she
approaches her kenvara says is
everything all right your grace no says
Daenerys I am still worried about gray
worm I haven't seen him since last night
he is still locked inside one of the
cabins with the man you brought with us
makaro kenvara Smiles then reaches out
and grabs Daenerys by her hand you will
see him soon enough Your Grace says
kinvara gray worm's flesh was kissed by
fire he is not as resistant to the
Flames like you have been before he let
his emotions get the best of him he was
foolish for grabbing the burning Brazier
before slamming it down onto the deck of
the ship there are no maesters on board
with us but lucky for him we have makaro
if anyone here will be able to fix gray
worm it will be him as she lets go of
her hand Daenerys says some of your
soldiers said they heard wild laughter
coming from inside makaro's cabin
laughter that was deep and dark and mad
later they said they heard him singing
some song in High Valerian canvaro
smiles again she says see for yourself
Daenerys Stormborn here they come now
when Daenerys looks over her shoulder
she can see gray worm and makaro are
walking their way Dany notices gray worm
is naked from the waist up his right
hand is wrapped in bandages but his left
hand looks very disturbing the other men
standing around the ship begin
whispering and trading glances as they
get a look at greyworm's arm is
everything okay says Daenerys after gray
worm and makaro stop in front of her let
me have a look at your hand says canvara
gray worm raised a charred and black and
tan it was Bloody all the way up to his
elbow even black smoke Rose from his
fingers a horrified Daenerys says I will
find you a maester as soon as we reach
Westeros that is not necessary says
makaro I have fixed his hand Your Grace
Danny then looks back at gray worm
waiting for him to say something I am
fine Your Grace says gray worm my hand
feels even stronger than it did before
it feels like there is a fire running
through the veins in my hand makaro
Smiles then walks away back below the
deck gray worm then looks at canvara and
says may I speak with your grace alone
of course says canvara who Smiles bows
her head then leaves as well when
they're finally alone Daenerys asks him
again are you sure everything is okay
yes your grace I swear my hand feels
fine but there is something else I think
we should discuss okay says Daenerys
with a bit of hesitation in her voice
what would you like to discuss it's Jon
Snow says gray worm I am worried about
what might happen once we land in
Westeros again this canvara says we will
need him but I don't know how much I
believe her he has already shown us that
he cannot be trusted your grace you have
said that we need to stop Brandon Stark
but that's Jon Snow's brother what
happens if Jon has to choose between
saving you or saving his own brother
what happens if brain attempts to harm
you would Jon kill his own brother to
save you because I don't think he will I
think the opposite is more likely to
happen Your Grace Danny looks out at the
deep blue see that surrounds them she
watches as drogon flies down low before
he skims right above the water after
another moment of silence Daenerys
finally says I do understand your
concerns I have some of my own some days
I walk out onto this deck look out at
the sea and wonder if I should go back
to Westeros at all sometimes I wonder if
I should risk my own life to save those
who may never love me on other days I
walk out onto this deck look out at the
sea and think about killing Jon Snow as
soon as we land in Westeros those dark
thoughts eventually fade away when I
remember why I wanted to take back the
Iron Throne that I thought was
rightfully mine I don't want to be
remembered the same way as everyone
remembers my father some of the anchor
starts to leave greyworm's eyes I want
to save those who can't save themselves
as Daenerys that's one of the reasons
why so many were willing to follow me if
I can't fight for that then it was all
for nothing Westeros and even the entire
realm is right back where we started I
have decided that if I am going to live
I can't live with that Daenerys begins
slowly walking away but then she stops
and looks back at gray worm she says but
then again words are just when if I am
being honest I don't know how I will
react when I see Jon Snow again gray
worm lifts his head back up he looks
over at Danny and there is a fire in his
eyes again as Daenerys goes to walk away
gray worm stops her he says your grace I
saw Jon Snow on the back of drogon when
kenvara had me look in her Flames if Jon
rides Dragon what does that mean happen
to you there is a bit of sadness in
Danny's eyes when she softly says I
don't know the scene ends right after
greyworm says I won't let you out of my
sight again your grace When we arrive in
Westeros I will kill Jon Snow myself in
the next scene we are back in King's
Landing we follow Samwell and Sir Davos
as they are walking inside of the red
key the sound of their footsteps scare
off some of the Ravens that are in the
Great Hall where the Iron Throne once
set as they are making their way across
the throne room Davos and Sam hold their
hands over their nose when they start
smelling a horrible stench the Ravens
have nearly finished eating the unknown
dead man who has been laying in the
Great Hall all week when Sam and Davos
look over at what's left of him all we
see is basically a skeleton dressed in
bloody Rags there is a raven standing on
the rotting man's skull watching Davos
and Sam with hatred in its black eyes
The Raven watches them until they're out
of sight when Sam and Davos finally
arrive in the small council's Chambers
they sit in their seats and wait there
is an ominous silence in the small
Council room Davos looks around at all
of the empty seats beside them we watch
them sit here in silence for what feels
like several minutes at last Davos
throws a glance Sam's way and says how
early are we they should be here already
said Sam we have our meetings at this
hour every week maybe Lord Tyrion is
running late says sir Davos it certainly
wouldn't be the first time Sam Smiles
nervously before he says no it would not
but that doesn't answer or four star
Padre and Brianne does Brienne strike
you as someone who runs late no she
doesn't says sir Davos now Sam begins
looking around the room at all of the
empty seats Braun is dead but Lord
Tyrion sir Podrick and bran and even
King bran are not at their scheduled
meeting that's when they begin hearing
the sound of boots walking their way
they eagerly stand up hoping to see
their other advisors walk in and join
them instead a man dressed in the golden
kingsguard armor stands before them
hello says Sam as he smiles the King's
Guard man doesn't smile nor does he
greet Sam back this is one of the same
men who arrested Lord Tyrion as well as
Berean and Sir Podrick follow me says
the member of the kingsguard but we have
a meeting says Sam we are waiting for
the others there will be no meeting
today says the king's guardman I'm only
here because your Grace said I would
find both of you here he gave me orders
to locate both of you then bring you
with me to join him follow me he's right
this way as the member of the kingsguard
begins walking away Sam and Davos look
at each other with confusion they don't
fully understand what's happening wait a
minute says Davos you will have to
forgive me sir but we have never seen
you before who are you and where did you
get that armor the king's guardman
Smiles as he slowly starts walking
davos's way until he's standing right in
front of him he stares long and hard
into his eyes but then he abruptly jams
the handle of a sword into davos's
stomach forcing him to fall down to one
knee as Davos tries finding his breath
the kingsguard member says your grace is
the only man I answer to now as I said
before follow me your king commands it
Sam rushes over helping Davos get back
on his feet after he finally catches his
breath Davos and Sam reluctantly follow
the kingsguard man out of the room then
down the stairs they both feel an
overwhelming sense of dread Sam's feet
feel heavier after each and every step
as they make their Ascension down the
stairs they begin hearing what sounds
like a large crowd gathered outside it
grows louder and louder as they get
closer to the doors Sam and Davos look
at each other with uncertainty when they
reach the main entrance of the red keep
the king's guardman swings open the
doors they are momentarily blinded by
the sunlight and the sound of a thousand
voices shouting makes them feel a little
disoriented Sam rubs his eyes as he
looks around at the crowd Gathering
outside
Davos holds his stomach as he follows
them around the side of the red key
Samwell and sardavos are shocked by what
they see up ahead they see bran sitting
on a very large platform about a hundred
feet away a few men are seen behind him
setting up the Gallows for an execution
right in front of bran is Lord Tyrion
Brienne and Podrick all of them are down
on their knees with their hands behind
their backs each of them have a gag in
their mouth as well standing right next
to bran are the other new members of the
kingsguard Sam and Davos rushed through
the crowd as they make their way up to
the stage Davos yells out your grace
what is the meaning of this why are they
bound and gagged however bran doesn't
answer him instead Sam and Davos are
immediately arrested by the new sworn
Brothers of the kingsguard one of Bran's
guards leans in close to Devos and Sam
he says don't say another word let this
serve as a lesson now enjoy the show Sam
and Davos are stunned by this shocking
turn of events suddenly bran lifts his
arms in the air silencing the large
crowd gathered in front of them when the
screaming and shouting begins to soften
Brian says it's very unfortunate that we
have to meet under these circumstances
but it seems there are some Rebels Among
Us Lord Tyrion Lannister your very own
hand of the king is guilty of murdering
his friend our master of coin sir
bronify Garden lady Berean and Sir
Podrick have always been on the side of
the Lannisters this is when one of
Bran's kingsguard shouts lady Boran even
laid with a Lannister she slept with sir
Jaime Lannister the king Slayer she has
also written lies about him in our white
book making him out to be some sort of
hero the crowd erupts when they hear
this we hear some of them shouting the
Lannisters have always been murderers
kill them all some of them begin
spitting at Berean While others are
throwing rocks at Lord Tyrion after a
few moments of this bran lefts his arms
again silencing everyone there he says I
gave Brianne a chance to show her
loyalty all she had to do was kill Lord
Tyrion show us that once and for all you
no longer favor the Lannisters but she
would not do this it seems that lady
Berean would rather die than to honor
her King well lady bran I will give you
one more chance bran gives a signal to
one of the kingsguard who then walks
over and removes the gag from brienne's
mouth I will ask you again in front of
everyone says Bran who do you fight for
lady Berean will you defend your King by
slaying this murderous line of Lannister
or will you die beside him you must
decide here and now the sword or The
Noose as the tears are falling from
Brian's face she helplessly looks over
at sir Podrick who has sadness in his
eyes as well he shakes his head no he
doesn't want Brienne to break her Honor
by giving him what he wants she now
looks over at Lord Tyrion who is covered
in his own sweat in urine Brienne looks
into Bran's eyes it seems like all of
his life has left them as he stares back
at her emotional
finally she says I will not make that
choice the crowd explodes into shouting
again then so be it says bran Your Fate
has been sealed he looks at his new
sworn Brothers of the kingsguard then
says hang them first bring in and Sir
Podrick are yanked up onto their feet
Sam and Davos are even more horrified
than before they know there is nothing
they can do to stop this the nooses were
slipped around their necks then jerk
tight one of the brothers of the
kingsguard looks at Brienne then says if
you have any other crimes you want to
confess to your Gods now would be the
time to say them when she doesn't answer
him he smiles then says you're the
strong silent type I see have it your
way Lady Brienne now let's see if you
can dance he yanked on a rope hard
before the floor fell out from under
Brienne in sir podrick's feet Brienne
immediately felt the hemp constricting
around her neck digging into her skin
forcing her chin upward it sounds like
Lord Tyrion is cursing at them through
his gag but not the boy sir Podrick
never lifted his eyes not even when his
feet jerked up off the ground Brienne
thought if this is some bad dream it is
time for me to awaken if this is real it
is time for me to die all she could see
was Sir Podrick The Noose around his
thin neck and his legs as they started
to spasm he was kicking choking and
dying her mouth opened she sucked the
air in desperately even as the Rope was
strangling her nothing had ever hurt so
much this scene ends right after Brienne
screams a word
in the final scene of this episode we go
back below the ground somewhere under
Westeros We are following seven small
shadows as they move through the
darkness that lies ahead one of them is
holding a light but we're still not able
to see enough to make out who they are
we keep following the seven shadows as
they move further and further into the
black abyss it's not long before they
spill out into a large open cave when
this happens their light reflects off
the cave walls revealing who they are
it's the seven children of the forest
who jumped into the mouth of the massive
werewood on the Isle of faces they are
now standing inside of a cave that has
familiar drawings all over its walls as
we see more and more drawings on the
walls we realize it's the same cave John
and Daenerys were in on Dragonstone
these seven small creatures walk through
the cave until they emerge out onto the
beach there is a full blood moon in the
sky the empty large Castle looms over
them as they form a circle near the edge
of the water all seven of them are now
facing inward each other that's when
each of them simultaneously grabbed
their dragonglass daggers before they
make a small incision on their hand as
the blood drips down from their hands it
falls onto the sand in a small wave of
water comes up to their feet the salt
water washes away their blood before
sucking it back out to the Sea now they
shut their eyes as they start saying
something in a language Unknown by man
it sounds more like they're singing a
song a song of the Earth this is when
something very strange starts to happen
dark clouds begin forming right above
them lightning starts to strike Thunder
begins to crack the sound of the wind
gets very loud as it throws sand all
over the beach suddenly a lightning bolt
strikes down onto Dragonstone leaving a
very large crack across the face of the
Stone Castle the seven children of the
forest begin chanting louder and louder
as the dark clouds above them get even
more violent the waves in the sea are
getting larger but they're not smashing
into the show or it's almost as if the
ocean water is lifting directly up into
the sky the children finally opened
their eyes all we see is white again
their chanting grows even louder as the
Thunder snaps and cracks like a whip as
the sea water begins moving faster in a
circular direction another bolt of
lightning strikes down right into the
center of the swirling water as soon as
the dark clouds begin to open up the
children's chanting stops but in that
exact moment it looks as if an explosion
goes off in the water millions of
gallons of seawater flies up into the
sky as a black shadow emerges above we
suddenly hear the ear splitting scream
of a dragon with their dark magic the
children have summoned Regal from below
the sea it's the most frightening thing
we have ever seen the dragon's eyes are
now red because it was decomposing in
the salt water for so long some of its
scales are slipping right off of its
Bones the large holes in his neck and
chest allow us to see its fire burning
inside of him at all times the episode
ends as the dragon disappears into the
night sky
in the very first scene of this episode
we are back in King's Landing there is
still a massive crowd gathered around
outside of the red key all of their eyes
are focused on what is happening up on
the center stage in front of them
Samwell Davos as well as everyone else
who is standing around them are watching
in silence as Brienne and Sir Podrick
are cut down from their nooses as soon
as their bodies hit the ground they
immediately start gasping for breath
Lord Tyrion Lannister's head Rises From
The Executioner's block he looks behind
him shocked by what he heard Brienne is
slowly getting back on her feet but it's
not easy while her hands are still bound
behind her back when she looks over at
Tyrion all he can do is shake his head
no there is sadness in her eyes again
but only for a moment now she looks away
as one of the members of the kingsguard
begins walking over her way he's holding
a small blade in his right hand he grabs
and by the shoulder then moves her so he
can free the Rope that's wrapped around
her hands he does the same thing for sir
Podrick who is now standing up on his
feet as well Sam looks over at Davos
unsure of what will happen next lady
Berean says a voice from the other end
of the stage everyone looks over at
Brian Stark who has a member of his new
kingsguard standing on his right and
left side Laying across his lap is oath
keeper brienne's Valerian steel sword
lady Berean says Brain again as he lifts
up her sword in the air he says I
believe you are asking for this the
sword is yours and you and Sir Podrick
will be free to go but first you must
slay Lord tyrion's head at my feet
remember the sword or the news I will
not ask you again says bran the member
of the kingsguard walks back across the
stage he is then handed berean's
Valyrian steel sword Sam and Davos watch
as the man walks back across the stage
again now holding the sword out in front
of him every one of the onlookers in the
crowd are silent as a [ __ ] the king's
guardman stops when he is standing
before Brienne he hands her the sword
then steps off to the side Brienne grabs
a firm grip around oathkeeper's handle
with both hands she looks over at bran
as well as the other King's guardmen who
are standing at his right and left side
then she looks over at sarpodrick who
has ever so slightly shaking his head no
Brienne extends her arms out in front of
her the reflection of the sun bounces
off her sword she begins resting the
blade on the back of Lord tyrion's neck
as she takes in another deep breath the
edge of oath keeper is so sharp you can
already see a drop of blood on the back
of the neck where the blade is resting
bran slowly raises the sword high above
her head Lord Tyrion shuts his eyes as
his body begins to involuntarily Shake
as soon as the blade begins to fall from
the sky Brienne does a side step then
swings the sword around with her arms
now fully extended in one swift motion
oath keeper slices all the way through
the neck of the King's Garden men
standing at her side his head goes
bouncing off the stage into the crowd a
thick rope of blood shoots out of his
neck six feet into the sky the crowd of
onlookers below erupt into absolute
chaos the king's guardman who is
standing at Bran's left side begins
rushing forward as soon as Berean sees
him their blades come crashing into each
other the sound of Steel slamming
against steel can be heard echoing
throughout the city Square sir Podrick
runs over and grabs the sword from the
headless body laying in front of him he
immediately starts cutting the
restraints around Davos and Sam's hands
when Davos is set free he grabs the
small blade from The Headless
kingsguardman then he helps Lord Tyrion
with the Rope around his hands and feet
brienne's sword smashes against the
other member of the kingsguard sword
again only now it knocks it free from
his hand before his sword even hits the
ground Brienne drives her own right
through his stomach and out of his back
as soon as she Yanks it back out his
lifeless body collapses Brienne then
drops down on one knee hoping to find
her breath everything happened so fast
it's almost as if everyone on stage is
in a daze Davos Sam and the others all
look at each other stunned by what just
happened half of the crowd standing down
below begins to leave now that the show
is over the other half finally goes
silent as they wonder what will happen
now suddenly Berean stands back up on
her feet she then begins walking back
and forth across the stage looking at
everything and everyone around her after
several moments of this Brienne finally
says where is bran there wasn't anger in
her voice that none of them heard from
her before they all begin desperately
looking around the stage somehow bran
must have escaped after the fighting
broke out Burien looks at them in
disbelief this scene ends after she says
he couldn't have gone far in the
following scene we go right outside of
the city we can see King's Landing in
the distance maybe only a few miles away
it looks as if there are hundreds of
ravens circling above the castle Arya
Stark suddenly stops her horse Gendry
does the same before he says why are we
stopping here we're almost there there
Arya looks up into the sky above them
searching to see if any Ravens are
following when she doesn't see any Arya
says I don't want us marching 500 men
right up to the gates we don't want
everyone in that City thinking we're
here for a fight we gotta find my
brother Brian before any of his guards
find us first we also need to find a
boat I know of a way we can get into the
castle undetected Gendry Smiles then
says I'm sure you do go find me the
commander cesaria I will need to speak
to him before we leave genjury whistles
then motions for one of the men who is
standing at the front of the line Arya
and Gendry hop down from their horses as
the commander steps forward Arya says we
will need you and all of your men to
wait here Gendry and I will head into
the city first if we need your
assistance we will give a signal we will
be ready when you are says the commander
we follow Arya in genjury as they walk
down the hill behind them before they
begin walking along the bank of the
Blackwater Rush the Sun in the sky is
slowly starting to hide behind the
horizon there are several men fishing on
the other side of the shore but neither
of them notice Arya or Gendry they end
up walking one and a half miles before
they find a dock that has a boat without
hesitation Arya grabs her dagger slices
the Rope securing it to the dock then
jumps in Gendry shoves the boat away
from the dock before he jumps in himself
the fast-flowing water dumps them right
out onto the Blackwater Bay within
minutes they stay right along the
shoreline until they're directly under
the red key once they're under the
castle Gendry hops out and brings the
small boat up onto the beach after Arya
gets out her eyes shoot back out across
the Blackwater Bay Arya is shocked when
she suddenly notices something
unexpected there is a massive black
dragon filling the sky up above and
right below it on the bay is what looks
like 100 ships heading their way
gendry's eyes are now filled with fear
he says we must hurry my lady those are
the banners of the Lord of Light they
have somehow taken over Daenerys Dragon
I'm not so sure of that Arya says if
that's drogon then I'm afraid Daenerys
is with them you were there when the
Hound killed Barrick dondarian the Lord
of Light brought him back right before
our very own eyes if they somehow have
daenerys's body she's alive Gendry knows
he has seen a resurrection before but
he's still shocked at the thought of
Daenerys coming back on her dragon look
again caesaria gendry's eyes follow hers
back out onto the Blackwater Bay they
can now see the banners of House
Targaryen flapping above some of those
ships when Gendry looks back at her in
disbelief Arya shouts let's go the scene
ends after Arya in Gendry vanish into
the sewage drain in the following scene
we are suddenly on the other side of the
city in front of its main gate well I
should say this is where the main gate
was it's no longer there since drogon
blew it wide open with his dragon flame
there are about a dozen Masons finishing
some stone work before it gets dark but
there's still a big hole where the
city's main gate used to be there is
also several men of the city watch
standing there on guard one of the men
from the city watch begins walking
forward after he sees a large Force
heading his way right in front of him
are Jon Snow Helen Reed and tormund
giant Spain who have arrived at King's
Landing as well almost every main
character who is still alive are now
here now unlike Arya and Gendry Jon has
brought all of his men with him to the
city there are several hundred soldiers
standing behind Jon and the others this
is exactly where Jon stood moments
before the Battle of King's Landing
begun as the man from the city watch
walks forward Helen Reed stands beside
Jon then Whispers she's here John looks
over at him before he says who is here
my Lord Helen Reed diverts His Eyes to
the Sky as he looks off into the
distance see for yourselves says Helen
Reed John's eyes look out across the
city at first all he sees is the red
keep on the other side of King's Landing
but as he looks up further above the
castle he suddenly notices black wings
in the sky Jon now has a dreadful look
on his face after he recognizes drogon
flying in front of the moon in the
distance he remembers what he did to the
men who murdered him he wonders if Dany
will want to do the same thing Jon
suddenly finds himself reaching for a
sword but he shifts his Focus once the
man from the city watch stops in front
of him what is the meaning of this says
the gold cloak why are there hundreds of
soldiers standing outside of our gates I
need to see the King right away says
John I don't think so says the man of
the city watch you can't just show up
here like this and expect to see the
king whenever you want I would suggest
that you and your men go back but the
man is interrupted by Dorman giant Spain
before he can ever finish his sentence
this is when tormund says we did not
March all of this way to ask you for
permission we are entering this city one
way or another now you can either step
aside and let us in or I will go through
you myself we're not here to fight with
you says Alan Reed we're here because
the king is in danger we want to help
him then Helen Reed lifts a finger into
the sky and says besides I would be more
worried about that than I would be with
us when the man of the city watch looks
over his shoulder his mouth hangs open
in shock once he sees a dragon circling
above the red key he says nothing as Jon
and all of his men begin walking forward
into the city the scene ends as we watch
them head right for the King's Castle in
the following scene we are now in the
dungeons of the red key Arya Stark and
Gendry are making their way into the
Castle's dark underbelly when they walk
out of one of the black hallways Arya
notices the dragon skulls up ahead we're
almost there says Arya follow me they
walk over to where there are a long
flight of stairs leading up to the main
level of the castle they slowly and
silently walk up each step Arya grabs
her dagger as they emerge from the
Shadows then out onto the main floor
after a few moments she looks back over
her shoulder at Gendry in disbelief
there's no guard says Arya that doesn't
make any sense it almost feels as if the
castle was empty they stay against the
wall as they walk on the other side of
the hall now they enter the Hall that
was once the home of the Iron Throne
there are still a few Ravens walking
along the floor Gendry motions in the
direction where the Iron Throne once set
there are some bones scattered across
the floor as well what in the seven
Hells happened here Gendry wondered this
Castle has become a graveyard they exit
the great hall now they walk across the
small Council room then over the map of
Westeros that's on the floor there is a
full moon up in the sky above them but
it vanishes after drogon flaps his
massive black wings in front of it let's
go cesaria as they begin ascending the
stairs they suddenly hear the sound of a
voice they can see Bran's door is
slightly open before they even reach it
Arya immediately swings open his door
with her right hand while she holds her
Valerian steel dagger in her left hand
once they are inside the room they are
unexpectedly greeted by Sir Davos Samuel
Berean sarpodrick and lordarian they're
all stunned when they see Arya walking
through that door lady Arya says Brienne
why are you back in King's Landing I
thought you were leaving Westeros for
good so did I say says Arya that was
until an assassin was waiting for me in
the cabin on my ship I wasn't sure if I
should believe the man or not but the
unknown man said that bran was the one
who hired him to kill me I'm here to
find out what's wrong with my brother I
guess he wants me dead you're not the
only one says Lord Tyrion he wants all
of us dead he would have been successful
if it wasn't for Brienne saving our
lives where is Brian at now ask Andrew
we don't know says Davos one minute he
was here then the next he was gone we
need to find him right away says Arya
bear suddenly interrupted by a
thunderous sound that only could have
come from a dragon the sound of dread
can be heard in Lord tyrion's voice when
he says what the hell was that you know
what that sound was cesaria you were
around the dragons longer than any of us
it looks like Daenerys is back from the
dead she has a hundred ships right
outside of the city walls everyone looks
a bit shaken up by the Revelation no one
says a word for a few moments finally
Davos says well the fact that we're not
all burning alive right right now might
be a good sign that she's not here for a
fight if that really is drogon above us
we would be dead already if that's what
she wanted davos's words ease some of
the nervousness in the room but Arya
doesn't look so sure about that Arya
grabs the burning torch at a gendry's
hand before walking out onto the balcony
of the king's Chambers she begins waving
it back and forth in the air giving the
signal to the men waiting outside of the
city when Arya walks back inside she
says well we're about to find out
exactly what Daenerys wants if it is a
fight that she wants we will give her
one Gendry let's move Arya in Gendry
exit the room before heading back down
the stairs unsure of what to do next
Brienne Sam Davos Tyrion and Sir Podrick
follow right behind them all of them
walk across the painted map of Westeros
then throw the small Council room before
heading down the hallway that leads into
the Great Hall where the Iron Throne was
once located after they enter the Great
Hall they suddenly stop when they hear
the sound of loud footsteps walking
their way Arya and memory and reach for
their weapon one of the Ravens lets out
a loud shriek before it starts circling
above their heads near the ceiling
finally there are shadows that emerge
from the darkness on the other side of
the Great Hall Arya Gendry Brienne sir
Podrick Davos Sam and Lord Tyrion watch
as they slowly walk their way Daenerys
Targaryen has officially arrived walking
in front of her is gray worm as well as
several of his unsullied men they
already have their weapons in hand on
dany's right and left side are kinvara
and makaro walking behind them are about
a dozen slave soldiers of the fiery hand
Lord Tyrion Lannister has a fearful look
in his eyes he almost looks as if he'd
just seen a ghost the silence is
interrupted by a thunderous scream as
drogon lands on the roof of the red key
the ceiling begins shaking as the dragon
walks over to where there is still a
large opening in the castle wall the
Moonlight is glimmering off of his shiny
black scales his dark red eyes never
leave Daenerys as he watches over his
mother in the Great Hall when they reach
the center of the room gray worm and his
unsullied men step aside as canvara and
Macaro step forward in a loud booming
voice that Echoes throughout the hall
mokaro says my friends we are here on
this night on behalf of our Lord of
Light he then looks over at Arya when he
says unfortunately a darkness rises
again it has fallen over Westeros
already yet it threatens our very
existence as it sweeps over the entire
realm the great other has your brother
as we speak we must act fast will you
stand beside us as we bring the light
back into all of our Lives again Davos
Brienne Sam and Tyrion all look at each
other in disbelief I don't understand
cesaria I killed the night King I
watched as his army fell right before my
very own eyes what are you saying
makaro's dark shining eyes study
everyone in the Great Hall as he says
the night King was simply an instrument
of the great other just as we are simply
an instrument of the Lord of Light what
do you think your brother tried to have
you killed there was aware awareness in
arya's voice as she asked him how did
you know about that makaro smiles before
he says I have seen this and much more
and more lower sacred Flames he then
looks back at Daenerys and says the Lord
of Light has shown me Daenerys
stormborn's worth that's why we stand
beside her now every night in my fires I
have glimpsed the glory that awaits her
is that right Arya says angrily did this
Lord of Light show you what Daenerys did
to this city I saw that with my own eyes
as well I was down there in those city
streets watching as her and her Dragon
burned innocent women and children is
that this Glory that you speak of now if
that's not Darkness falling over
Westeros then I don't know what is the
lady Arya is Right whispered a voice
from the Shadows there was a Darkness
within Daenerys and even her dragon as
she burned the city to the ground it was
the same darkness that lives within your
brother Brandon Stark now who said that
Astoria do you know where my brother is
a moment goes by before The Man Behind
The Voice steps out of the Shadows my
name is Alan Reed my lady I know where
your brother is and I know what is wrong
with him I'm afraid the great other has
him now and all of us must leave soon if
we want to live some of the anger leaves
arya's eyes as she says you're friends
with my father I was my lady says Helen
Reed Arya looks at kinvara and makaro
then back at Allen Reed before she says
both of you speak of this great other
yet I don't know what that is who are
they where are they and what do they
want with bran well it's just as he said
says Helen Reed your brother is simply
their instrument no different than the
night King was before they created the
Nike after all and they were living
inside of his mind the same way that
they are inside of brain's mind now
there is an island not far from here
known as the Isle of faces some of you
may know it as the God's eye on this
sacred aisle lives some of the wisest
and eldest living members of the
children of the forest they have been
living there since before or the first
man ever stepped foot on westerosi soil
they are extremely dangerous and their
veins have been filled with hatred for
thousands of years they want the same
thing Daenerys wanted they want what
they believe is rightfully theirs they
won back all of the land that man stole
from them and they will stop at nothing
unless every last one of us are dead
Lord Tyrion who has been standing behind
everyone else finally steps forward a
hint of anger flashes across Danny's
face after she sees him so they have
been inside of Bran's mind making him
kill all of us says Tyrion I'm afraid so
says Helen Reed after a moment of
silence Lord Tyrion Whispers why do you
think I came all this way this
immediately gets the attention of Arya
Sam Davos Gendry and Brienne they all
remember hearing bran say that right
before he was named King he knew says
Tyrion he knew exactly what would happen
after I suggested we name Bran as our
new king he said why do you think I came
all this way it's as if everything
happened exactly the way he wanted he
knew we would defeat the army of the
dead after a sadness fills his eyes Lord
Tyrion looks at Danny then says he knew
Daenerys would burn King's Landing he
then sits down after suddenly feeling a
bit dizzy finally Danny says did they
orchestrate everything while she is
looking at Lord Helen Reed yes they did
set a familiar voice from the shadows as
Jon Snow emerges from the darkness he
says everyone was exactly where they
were supposed to be that was the very
last thing bran said to me right before
he shipped me off to spend the rest of
my life at Castle black when drogon sees
Jon again he lets out a thunderous
scream so loud it feels as if it shook
the very foundation of the castle the
Ravens that were circling around the
Great Hall immediately scatter into the
wind it looks like the wind has been
knocked right out of Daenerys after she
sees Jon for herself gray worm and the
unsullied ready their weapons
immediately Arya and Brienne do the same
when kenvara and Macaro noticed this
they step in front of Jon hoping to
avoid any Bloodshed just yet your grace
Jon says nervously I'm sorry for what
happened I did not know then what I'm
beginning to understand now Lord Tyrion
is Right Bran or I should say the
children of the forest knew exactly what
would happen they wanted all of us to
destroy each other I finally understand
why Brian said I was exactly where I was
supposed to be he knew you would burn
down King's Landing he must have seen it
in one of his visions and he knew that I
would execute you for that now I see why
he so easily sent me to the wall he
needed me out of the way but only after
I did what he knew I would do Jon then
looks at Arya and says that's why he
sent an assassin after you he saw you
kill the night King he knew you would be
one of his biggest threats he had to get
rid of you the same way he was getting
rid of all of us once they had the Iron
Throne they know no longer needed any of
us don't you see that now
I'm not really
you died in that cave
you're a man
almost
I'm sorry I wasn't there when you needed
me
you were exactly where you were supposed
to be
if we choose you
will you wear the crown
[Music]
why do you think I came all this way
go through all of that and
make your way home again honey to find
something in the world
I can only imagine chaos is a ladder
the Great Hall is suddenly as silent as
a crypt everyone is looking around at
each other in disbelief but also
realizing what has been happening all
along Daenerys begins walking forward
out from behind all of her guards gray
worm goes to stop her but she lays her
hand on his before shaking her head no
she walks out across the Great Hall
until she is standing in front of Helen
Reed and Jon Snow Danny looks in John's
eyes for several moments as she thinks
about everything that has been said she
looks over at Helen Reed then says I
guess now there is only one thing I want
to know how can we defeat them once and
for all the scene ends right after Helen
Reed says well we will defeat them the
same way they were using you and your
dragon to kill everyone in their City we
will burn them all in the final scene of
this episode we are back on the shore of
the Isle of faces this scene Begins by
us getting a good look at the full moon
that is sitting above the God's eye
there are hundreds of ravens circling in
the sky above all of the island sacred
where Woods we watch as Shadows shift
around in the woods no different than
any other night the green men are
getting ready to stand their silent
watch as they guard the Isle of faces
thousands of Little Green Men begin
emerging From Within the Woods as always
all of them are holding weapons of their
own their weapons are made up of
different dragonglass some of them are
black green and even red the faces on
the werewoods behind them are somehow
more frightening than they were before
they have hatred in their blood red eyes
they all have been sitting here silently
watching and waiting for thousands of
years it makes you wonder how many
horrific sacrifices they have seen over
those several Millennia as soon as all
of the green men are standing in a
circle around the whole island something
else begins shifting in the shadows the
sound of branches breaking and the
leaves crunching under the footsteps is
very reminiscent of the sound of bones
breaking the little green men are not
the only ones watching and waiting on
this evening suddenly what looks like
one hundred thousand glowing blue eyes
begin emerging from the darkness within
the forest this massive Army is made up
of nothing but white walkers who are
still riding on the back of their giant
Elks only these white walkers look
slightly different than the ones we've
seen before now as frightening as they
look they also have a bit of Elegance to
them sort of like a haunting Beauty all
of them begin surrounding the sacred
Island as well they're ready for
whatever is heading their way now we
begin to move to the center of the
island where the largest wearwood in
Westeros is located once again we see
the Grove of seven werewoods that are
all facing inward at each other right in
the center of them is a massive wearwood
with a very large open mouth on its face
there are bones and skulls scattered all
around the were Woods on the floor of
the forest this is where the episode
will end the final thing we see is
what's inside this massive wearwood the
episode will fade to black after we get
a glimpse of of Brandon Stark sitting in
this mouth of Madness like the
three-eyed Raven before Brandon Stark is
entangled by the roots of the werewood
it looks like the children of the forest
have made this his new home
a home that he will never be able to
leave again
in the opening scene of this episode we
will see a massive Army marching along
the King's Road all of their footsteps
sound like the beating of a drum there
are thousands of soldiers made up of the
different armies throughout Westeros and
even essos the soldiers of the north are
Marching at the front of the line as
they are being led by Jon Snow ghost
Helen Reed giant Spain Brianne sir
Podrick sir Davos lauritarian and
Samwell right behind them are the
bannermen of house Baratheon led by
Gendry Baratheon and Arya Stark
following right behind them are what
remains of the unsullied Army as always
they are led by greyworm and right
behind them are the 1000 slave soldiers
from the fiery hand who are led by
kinvara and Macaro at the back of the
formation we can see there are about a
dozen small boats being held by some of
those slave soldiers each of those small
boats might be able to hold about 30 men
the sun is shining down on all of the
them but not for long as the sun is
resting high in the sky it is suddenly
smothered by a massive black shadow when
drogon fully extends his enormous black
wings in front of it his dragon scales
are glistening as he soaks up the
sunlight right on the back of drogon is
Daenerys who leans over on her side when
the dragon makes a hard left off the
King's Road as they begin heading for a
large castle that is sitting off in the
distance the thousands of men below make
a left as well we go back to the front
of the army where Jon Snow and Holland
Reed are riding on Horseback the large
item that was on Helen Reed's back has
now slung over the side of his horse
it's actually bouncing off the horse's
leg after every step it makes this is
when Jon Snow will ask Alan Reed what he
has been hiding under that blanket Helen
Reed flashes a faint smile before he
says you will see soon enough Jon Snow
it is a gift that I have brought for you
Jon doesn't know whether to be happy
about this or not I'm not sure if I like
the sound of that says Jon who shows a
thin Smile as well right off over John's
shoulder we can see Samwell on his horse
making his way to the front of the line
he rides up beside John and Helen Reed
right as Jon begins asking him something
else Jon looks back over at Lord Howland
then says how many of us do you think
will actually make it out of this alive
do you really think we will be able to
save bran Helen Reed doesn't answer him
right away he looks into the sky and
drogon and Dany flying off in the
distance when he looks back at Jon he
says well it's as I've said before what
will you be willing to sacrifice Jon
Snow now as for your brother bran I will
not make any assurances that you will
get him out of here alive but that
doesn't mean you can't help save
everyone else I know you want your
brother back believe me I do but you
also must remember his life isn't the
only one at stake Jon silently looks
away he looks in front of him at the
castle that grows larger with each step
they make he watches as drogon and
Daenerys fly in a circle above the
castle it's five long fingers reaching
into the sky AI finally John looks back
at Helen Reed and says what was your
sacrifice my Lord when I met you out
Beyond the Wall you once said you made
the greatest sacrifice of all what did
you mean by that there is another long
silence before anything is said Helen
Reed looks in John's eyes and says my
own flesh and blood I sacrifice my very
own son Jon Snow this new revelation
stuns Jon but before he can follow up on
what he said Samwell rides up alongside
them with a letter in hand I was hoping
I could have a moment with you before
the battle begins says Samwell this was
sent from The Citadel before you arrived
in King's Landing I wasn't sure what to
make of it at first but I have a feeling
you will know what it means soon enough
here I want you to have it Sam reaches
out and hands John the letter before
falling back into formation John's eyes
open up a little wider as he unfolds the
letter there is an image in the center
with a few words written above it the
only thing Jon focuses on is the drawing
of what looks like the face of a
werewood he studies it for a few moments
when Jon begins folding the letter we
will see that this werewolf's face is
surrounded by fire lord Helen Reed says
we're here when Jon finally looks back
up he sees an island surrounded by a
large Blue Lake Jon Snow Helen Reed
Samwell Davos Brianne and all the others
begin hopping off of their horses Arya
Gendry and Lord Tyrion Lannister walk up
behind them everyone stands near the
edge of the water as they look out
across the lake at the sacred aisle of
faces it doesn't look like anyone is
here says Gendry it will not remain that
way says Helen Reed not one night falls
John is resting his hand on the head of
his sword when he says then we better
get everyone over there before that
happens have the Men start dropping the
boats in the water the sun will be
setting soon drogon and Daenerys are
still flying above harrenhal they drop
down over the God's eye but when
Daenerys looks down onto the island
she's not able to see anything through
all of the heavy brush having a bird's
eye view isn't really helping them at
least not yet it doesn't look like there
is anyone on the Isle of faces from up
above either when Daenerys sees them
dropping the boats into the water she
lands her dragon on the shore of the
lake we don't have enough boats for
everyone so make sure they are sent back
across until we get all of our men over
there on the island says John one of the
northmen nods his head before stepping
into one of the small boats himself
Helen Reed grabs the large item from his
horse then he slings it back over his
shoulder Lord Tyrion Lannister walks
over by Sir Podrick who is helping
Berean with her armor he greets them
with a thin smile before he looks at sir
Podrick and says I have something I want
to give you when he looks at Berean she
nods her head freeing him of his duty he
then follows Lord Tyrion who walks
around the other side of his horse he
watches him with uncertainty unsure of
what this is all about after another
moment Lord Tyrion emerges from behind
the horse and in his hands he is holding
a sword when he stands before him he
says this was my brother Jamie's sword
it's no good in my hands I'm not sure if
you will need it but I can't think of a
better man alive that should have it my
Lord this is Valerian Steele says sir
Podrick it is says Lord Tyrion it was
made from how Stark's ancestral Valyrian
steel sword Brienne has one half and now
you have the other here he reaches out
and grabs the sword from his hands when
he holds it out in front of him the
fading sun glimmers off the ripples in
the blade thank you my Lord says sir
Podrick Lord Tyrion Smiles then he walks
away we then see Daenerys loading gray
worm and the unsolid man on the back of
her Dragon the small boats are making
their way back across now John motions
for Samwell and Davos they follow him as
he signals for lordarian as well Jon
says I want you three to stay over here
now I don't mean to offend any of you
but if we don't succeed without you I
don't think three extra men will make
that much of a difference I'm hoping we
are back before Sunrise Jon then
abruptly walks away ghost follows right
behind him he stops one of his northmen
as he makes his way back near the shore
Jon says make sure you unload the wagon
full of dragon glass now there is more
than enough to fill one of these boats
on its own John had hundreds if not
thousands of dragonglass weapons brought
down from Winterfell they were what was
left over from the long night battle
against the night King the Northman bows
his head before walking away Jon's eye
suddenly looked for the sky as he hears
the sound of a hundred screaming Ravens
from above the Isle of faces it is a
dreadful sound that reminds him of why
he is here kinvara and makaro Fallen
next to Jon as he walks alongside the
lake kenvara's glowing red eyes find
Johns she says your brother will be
waiting for you Jon Snow but he is no
longer the man that you think he is the
where Woods have corrupted his mind only
the purest death will cleanse his soul
now anger flashes inside Jon's eyes he
grabs canvara by the throat but he lets
go immediately after her red ruby burns
his hand why would you say that John
says angrily we are sorry Jon Snow but
this night will be dark and full of
Terror says kinvara only the fire will
burn them all away now Jon runs over to
the shore then signals for everyone to
get inside the boats he looks at Helen
Reed then yells we must leave now Lord
Alan Reed jumps in the boat then gives
them a shove off the shore when Jon
looks back he sees kinvara standing
there staring at him her bright red ruby
glowing all the while the rest of the
dozen or so boats are filled with the
slave Soldiers overlore the ends of
their weapons are now lit up with a red
and orange flame this section of the
lake almost looks as if it's on fire the
sun is Now setting there is a full moon
sitting above the God's eye on this
evening as the Darkness Falls the sacred
Isle of faces finally starts to come
alive the shrieking sound of Ravens are
now heard from the forest in the center
of the island this is followed up by the
sound of ominous screams that Echo
across the Silent Lake all of the
soldiers that are standing in formation
on the shore of the Isle of faces began
looking at each other with a hint of
fear in their eyes the moonlit sky is
suddenly blackened as drogon and
Daenerys circle around the island again
Daenerys watches from above but she
still doesn't see any movement from
within the center of the forest Gendry
walks over by Arya then says do you feel
that feel what Astoria the werewolves
says Gendry do you feel them looking at
you because I do Arya looks at all the
different werewoods that surround the
Isle of faces all of them are looking
back at them with hatred in their eyes
the faces look nothing like the face on
the werewood back at arya's home of
Winterfell Arya knows she is not welcome
here but she moves forward anyway all of
the 1 000 slave soldiers of relore have
finally arrived on the island they began
standing in formation waiting for the
signal gray worm as well as his
unsullied men are lined up beside them
all of gendry's Bannerman and the men of
the north are now here also only a few
of them remain on the last of the boats
with Jon Snow and Helen Reed who are
Landing ashore now when Jon ghost and
Lord Helen Reed jump out they grab their
boat and drag it up onto the beach they
walk around all of the soldiers to the
front of the formation as they watch the
final Boat Land on the shore as soon as
kenvara and makaro step foot on the Isle
of faces a massive Shadow falls from the
sky before unleashing a blue Fireball
onto the lake the black shadow vanishes
back into the night sky as the entire
Lake goes up in blue flames everyone who
is standing on the shore of this sacred
island is left feeling stunned by how
fast this happened Daenerys looks up
into the Sky Thinking whatever it was
dropped down from above her Jon looks
over at canvaro with a sudden rage he
thinks that she has somehow done this
since it happened right after she
stepped off the boat makaro notices this
so he walks over to Jon and sets his
large hand on his shoulder then says it
has begun Jon Snow there is no escaping
this now they don't want us leaving here
alive the Isle of faces is now
surrounded by a massive blue ring of
fire the reflection of the Flames are
seen in the blood red eyes of ghost the
white direwolf begins looking into all
of the eyes of the were Woods in front
of them we suddenly hear what sounds
like the screams of a thousand dying
Voices From Within the Woods Jon Snow
ghost Helen Reed Arya Gendry gray worm
as well as everyone else begins
descending on the center of this island
in search of Brandon Stark black Shadows
begin shifting throughout the woods all
around them while Daenerys and drogon
are scanning the area from above Dany
suddenly notices a massive fire start
from within the middle of the God's eye
Dany does get a glimpse of small black
Shadows dancing around the orange and
red Flames everyone on the ground is
walking very slowly dreading what lies
ahead when Jon and the others look up
they see hundreds of ravens sitting on
the branches watching them with their
white eyes as they move inward all of
them ready their weapons as they see
more and more Shadows shifting around in
the woods Dragon glass arrows start
raining down on them from above dozens
of soldiers began falling down all
around them where are they yells giant
Spain they're up in the trees Brian
shouts back everyone suddenly looks
above them they're not able to see who
they are or exactly what they are all
they see are yellow and golden cat's
eyes glowing back at them the slave
soldiers are the fiery hand rush in the
end of their weapons are lit up on fire
with orange and red Flames they hold
their weapons near the bottom of the
trees catching them all on fire the
island begins burning from within then
in an instant the little green men jump
out of the sky with their dragonglass
weapons in hand Landing all around them
everyone starts hacking and slicing at
the small green men in front of them and
now behind them Brienne lops off one of
their heads with her Valyrian steel
sword their great big golden Cat's eyes
are still glowing as their heads go
bouncing off the ground one of the green
men sticks their dragonglass spear into
the back of gendry's leg but he spins
around and slices off its head in one
swift move Helen Reed Falls as an arrow
goes into a shoulder and and back he
lets out a scream as his body hits the
ground ghost dives through the air and
sinks his razor sharp teeth into the
face of one of the small childlike
soldiers we watch as its golden and
green eyes Fade to Black as its life
leaves its body when one of the little
green men jumps on torment Giants Bane's
back he reaches behind him and grabs it
by its throat he smashes its head
against a rock while screaming like a
madman Arya grabs her Valyrian steel
dagger then jams it into the ear of one
of the green men dropping it instantly
sir Podrick slices another one of them
in half before dropping another one from
running up behind Berean daggers and
swords rise and fall then rise and fall
one after another until the Forest goes
silent again the little green men were
no match for thousands of soldiers
dressed in armor Jon helps Alan Ray get
back on his feet he still has the arrows
in his back and shoulder Giants Bane
walks over and Yanks them out he can
still move on his own Gendry is now
limping from the injury in his leg but
everyone all seems to be fine for now
all of them began moving forward again
even slower than before after walking
only a few more feet John and the others
begin hearing something else shifting
around in the dark woods in front of
them in the matter of moments there are
suddenly very large Shadows all around
them Jon raises a fist signaling for
everyone to stop where they are Everyone
Falls silent as they listen to the sound
of leaves crunching and branches
breaking in the darkness the slave
soldiers of relore hold out their
weapons in front of them hoping to see
what's out there around them as their
Flames drive away the Shadows Jon's eyes
have a sudden look of disbelief when he
starts to see blue eyes faintly glowing
all around him their eyes look at the
sky when they unexpectedly hear a
thunderous scream from a dragon ring out
across the island the resurrected
rhaegar drops from the sky Daenerys is
so horrified by The Sight and Sound of
rhaegal she nearly falls off drogon but
she holds herself up by one of his
spikes rhaegal immediately lets out his
blue flame but drogon dives through the
sky in order to dodge it Samwell Davos
and Lord Tyrion are still standing near
the water on the other side of the lake
they begin running for the castle of
harrenhal when they see rhaego emerge in
the night sky everything lights up with
a red and blue flames as the dragons
unleash their fire on each other one
after another back on the ground John
and everyone else form a line as they
see the glowing eyes move in for the
kill some of rhaegal's blue Fireballs
begin striking the island lighting up
everything around them they suddenly see
what's heading their way there are
dozens and dozens of white walkers
riding on the backs of giant Elks the
slave soldiers of relore Rush in to
deliver the first blow One By One The
White Walkers begin snuffing out their
flaming weapons as each of the soldiers
lifeless bodies slam onto the ground as
the forest burns down all around them
Daenerys can finally see what's
happening on the ground below her from
her view we can see there are roughly
100 White Walkers closing in on everyone
down below Dany watches as gray worm
throw is his dragonglass spear
shattering one of the White Walkers and
the giant Elks it was riding on the
unsullied men move in their weapons give
them a slight Advantage here since the
white walkers are now high off the
ground they form a shield around
everyone standing in the center as the
white walkers Rush forward they all
thrust their Spears out at once
shattering several of them before they
can break their wall now when some of
the other white walkers see this they
start charging on their giant Elks this
begins knocking most of the unsullied
men down as they run them over smashing
some of their skulls beneath their feet
dragonglass weapons are flying through
the air everywhere White Walkers shatter
again but not all of them some of the
dragonglass messes and it unfortunately
hits a few of their own men dropping
them instantly when one of the white
walkers sees Jon it jumps down from the
elk with a nice sword in hand Jon greets
him with his own sword in hand the White
Walker swings its glowing ice sword
right at John's head but it misses by
only inches after Jon bends down to
avoid it right as Jon launches back up
he brings his sword with him but this
White Walker raises his own ice sword to
block it their swords smash into each
other in the air when the swords meet a
shattering sound rings out throughout
the forest the white Walker's ice sword
is fine it was actually John's Valyrian
steel sword that shattered you see these
white walkers are unlike the ones we
have seen before they themselves can
still die by Valyrian steel and
dragonglass but their ice weapons are
much stronger than their last ones the
children of the forest at the Isle of
faces made sure of that while Jon is
standing there in disbelief holding
nothing but his sword's handle the White
Walker brings its ice sword high above
his head moments away from delivering
his fatal blow as soon as the White
Walker brings his sword down sir Podrick
drives his own Valyrian steel sword
through the back of this white Walker's
head shattering it before it can kill
Jon after only a few seconds Jon finally
gathers his senses then he grabs a
dragonglass weapon from the ground
before entering the fight again the this
is when the resurrected rhaegal will
drop out of the sky unleashing his blue
flame on dozens of unsolid men standing
on the ground another one of the white
walkers riding on one of the giant Elks
comes rushing through the field a
handful of gendry's bannermen dive out
of the way before they get ran over
canvara suddenly finds herself standing
there all alone before she can move the
massive elk lowers its head driving its
rack of antlers right through her body
out her back when makaro sees that
happen he lets out an agonizing scream
he immediately raises his six foot long
iron staff high above his head on the
end of his staff is a dragon's head as
he continues to let out this booming
Scream the dragon's eyes begin to Glow
green he suddenly swings down the staff
in a slicing motion and when he does
this the dragon's head spits out a green
flame that ignites everything in front
of it dozens of white walkers and their
Elks go up in Flames instantly we can
hear the sound of crackling ice as white
walkers let out a scream of their own as
they burn alive this allows Jon and
everyone else to finally move forward
again most of the Iowa faces is now on
fire there are red orange green and blue
flames everywhere Davos Lord Tyrion and
Samoa are horrified as they watch from
below the castle of harrenhal all
they're able to see is fire from where
they're at it doesn't look like anyone
will make it out of there alive as
everyone else is moving through the
woods Helen Reed stops Jon before they
go any further wait says Helen Reed
there is something you will need if
you're going to end this tonight Lord
Helen Ray drops the large item from his
back John has been wondering what this
is as he unfolds it from the blankets
and Furs Jon suddenly sees the
reflection of fires in the steel I know
Valyrian steel when I see it says John
where did you get that its name is dark
sister it was once Lord Brendan Rivers
he gave it to me years ago and he said I
would one day give it to you when the
moment was right you no longer have a
sword of your own I guess now is as good
a time as any John holds the sword
firmly in his hands then he nods his
head and rushes forward into the Flames
The Grove of seven where Woods is right
up ahead but everyone has suddenly
stopped when another wave of white
walkers and giant Elks head their way as
Jon looks behind them he can see the
biggest wear what he's ever seen in his
life he fixes his eyes on the enormous
mouth at the base of it as he looks
inside he instantly notices bran is
sitting there with his eyes rolled back
in his head bran John Whispers he says
the name again only louder bran everyone
looks at Jon who then sticks out his
sword in brain's Direction they all see
him sitting in the werewood now as well
Arya grabs her dagger with her left hand
before throwing it out in front of her
the dagger slices right into one white
walker shattering it immediately but the
dagger continues flying through the air
until it hits a white walker right
behind it shattering that one also the
fires on the floor of the forest begin
spreading all around them Makara raises
the iron Stephanie there again shooting
out another green flame from the
dragon's mouth The Grove of where Woods
in front of them began to go up in
Flames Jon screams out no we must get
Brian out of there however the werewoods
all around him are now burning locking
bran inside a green ring of fire John
and Arya run in to get him but the
massive flame stopped them from moving
any further they run around the circle
of werewoods looking for another opening
but they don't see one white walkers are
still descending on their location
Gendry grabs Arya by her shoulder he
yells if we don't leave now we will die
here Brienne and gray worm are still
fighting off the enemy sir Podrick is
rolling around on the ground some of his
armor is melting while his uniform is on
fire it's absolute Madness on the Isle
of faces Helen Reed finds Jon again he
screams Jon's name before he says get
back to the shore now Daenerys needs you
your brother Brian is inside that Dragon
you cannot save him but maybe you can
save her right as Alan Reid says is that
a white walker shoves his eyes sword
through his back and out the front of
his belly Jon looks at Helen Reed's eyes
as he drops on his knees with blood
running out of his mouth this snaps Jon
out of his Haze now before the White
Walker he moves the ice sword from Helen
Reed's lifeless body John angrily shoves
his own sword into the white Walker's
neck after it shatters Jon runs back to
where they first landed on the island
everything is burning behind him there
are red green orange and blue flames
everywhere the dragons vanish as they
fly through all of the smoke that is
right above the aisle of faces only
drugon and Daenerys emerge on the other
side they do a couple circles around the
island looking for rhaegal but they
don't see him neither does Jon Daenerys
and drogon fly back into the black smoke
again only now when they come out the
other side rhaegal is locked on to
drogon's Wing the undead dragon is
biting and scratching holes and Drug on
side the dragons are now spinning wildly
out of control until rhaegal releases
and vanishes back into the smoke John
starts waving his sword hoping Dany
notices it she lands the dragon near him
anyway when Jon runs over by her Danny
yells down drogon is hurt badly Jon
looks at the holes and drogon's Wing
then he shouts back will he still be
able to fly I think so says Danny
although I don't know how much longer
Jon yells out again let me go up with
you let me help you now before Danny
answers she looks into the woods where
there are now White Walkers running
their way get on shouts Daenerys Regal
drops back down out of the sky one of
the white walkers grabs his ice spear as
Jon is climbing on Dragon's Back right
as Jon sits down behind Danny drug on
lifts from the ground the White Walker
throws his magical ice weapon missing
drogon only by a few feet as the dragon
soars into the sky rhaegal Dives down
behind him following them into the smoke
Jon yells out I need you to get above
him why shouts Danny what will you do
after a few seconds Jon says I don't
know
drogon ascends further into the night
sky Rising higher and higher they stay
inside of the thick black smoke for
several moments almost as if they're
hiding from rhaegal as soon as Dany sees
the resurrected Dragon down below them
she has drogon dived down hundreds of
feet he slices right through the air
like a speeding bullet then as sudden as
a thunderbolt a shrieking drogon Dives
onto rhaegal locking his fangs around
the other dragon's neck the Dragons Were
now locked together as they begin
falling out of the sky the lake was
suddenly rushing up at them with
Incredible speed as the dragons fall
further and further Jon Snow stands up
on drogon's back with the Valyrian steel
sword Dark sister in his hand within the
blink of an eye Jon launches himself off
dragon's back as he is flying through
the sky he raises dark sister high above
his head Daenerys is horrified as she
watches this when Jon falls down onto
rhaegal he drives the Valyrian steel
sword through the dragon's eye he shoves
it in with so much force the end of the
blade drives out the back of rhaegal's
throat the resurrected Dragon lets out
an agonizing scream that can be heard
throughout the Isle of faces Jon hangs
on for dear life as the dragon drops out
of the sky half a heartbeat later
rhaegal struck the lake sending
thousands of gallons of water up into
the sky Daenerys looks down and watches
as the dragon slips beneath the water
the like boiled with dragon's blood and
then was still Daenerys immediately
lands drogon on the shore of the God's
eye Arya ghost Brienne and Gendry come
running out from the Blazing woods
behind them every single one of the
werewoods are now on fire Dany screams
out at Arya there is dread in her voice
Jon went into the water with rhaegal
says Danny silence Falls over the Isle
of faces everyone's fearful eyes look
over at the lake hoping Jon emerges from
below ghost begins running up and down
the shore searching for Jon's body the
episode so it will fade to black as we
see air bubbles breaking on the surface
of the water
in the early morning hours of the
following day we begin with an overhead
shot of the God's eye everything on this
sacred Island had went up in Flames the
ancient were Woods that once inhabited
the Isle of faces are nearly gone the
ones that are still standing will never
look the same again all of their red
leaves have vanished their faces are now
blackened by the Ash and smoke even
their red eyes now look black there are
still some small fires burning around
the island there are thousands of dead
bodies littered all over the forest
floor some of them are even still
holding dragonglass weapons in their
hand right on the shore of the God's eye
Arya ghost Gendry Brienne Daenerys and
gray worm are standing there looking out
over the lake none of them are saying
anything they're just standing there
hoping Jon Snow will emerge from below
the water deep down Arya Stark knows he
has been under the water for far too
long on the other side of this Lake we
can see Davos authoritarian Lannister
and Samwell walking away from harrenhal
as they head for the shoreline as the
sun is rising over the horizon Something
glimmers In The Water Arya begins
walking forward when she notices this
the inside of her boots instantly fill
up with water as she walks out into the
lake after only a few steps she bends
down then grabs something from below the
surface of the water when she lifts it
up into the air the morning sunlight
begins reflecting off the blade after
looking at it for only a few moments
Arya says this is Valerian steel whose
sword is this Danny sucks in a breath
when she recognizes what it is that's
the sword John shoved into rhaegal's eye
before they slammed into the lake says
Danny its name is dark sister says
Gendry I saw Lord Helen raid give that
sword to Jon during the battle arya's
voice cracks when she says I will hold
it for him before she slides dark sister
behind the belt around her hip Daenerys
walks away greyworm and Berean follow
behind her they begin walking through
the smoking Forest on the Isle of faces
as they make their way into the center
of the island we see nothing but death
and destruction all around them drogon
begins flying around above them as they
move further and further into the Forest
right up ahead then lies what was once a
Grove of seven were Woods surrounded by
one massive werewood and its Center bran
suddenly stops when she hears a voice
whisper her name she runs over when she
notices sir Podrick is still alive
laying on the ground most of his uniform
has been burned off of him she helps him
slowly get back on his feet she then
grabs his arm and throws it around her
shoulder so she can help him walk away
Arya and Gendry are walking their way
now Brienne suddenly notices someone
else as she waits for them Giants Bane
lies only a few feet away he is
unfortunately dead he must have been
killed by one of the white walkers since
it doesn't look like he died by the fire
Brienne kneels down next to his body She
lays her hand on his face before
shutting his eyes she stays there
kneeling for a few moments until Arya
and Gendry walk right by them without
saying anything Arya is walking to the
center of the island she wants to see
what happened to bran for herself
Daenerys and gray worm are already
standing there by what was once a
massive wearwood when Daenerys looks
over her shoulder and sees that it's
Arya walking over she drops her head
down then walks away Arya stops when she
is standing in the middle of the Grove
of burnt warewoods there is black smoke
rising out of the mouth of the giant
werewood bran was sitting in when Arya
bends down and looks inside its mouth
she sees there are hundreds of bones
inside some of them look very small even
some of the skulls are childlike when
she looks further into the center she
does see a set of bones that are much
larger the roots of the werewood are
wrapped all around them there is water
in her eyes when she walks away without
saying a word Gendry follows her in
silence everyone is ready to get the
hell out of here what should we do now
says Lord Tyrion when Danny sits down on
the back of dragon she says you will
have to figure that out for yourself I'm
leaving Westeros for good everyone seems
a little shocked by this I thought you
might want to come back to King's
Landing says Lord Tyrion Lannister gray
worm looks over at Danny waiting to see
what she will say after only a few
moments Daenerys says it was all I ever
thought about not long ago I thought
that's what I wanted but after seeing
most of the Seven Kingdoms I have
realized this isn't what I want not
anymore gray worm Smiles right as Danny
goes to leave on drogon a voice shouts
wait Arya walks over near her Dragon
when she looks at Danny she says how do
we know you won't come back and burn
everything down again with your dragon
well I guess you never will says Danny
right before her and Dragon launch into
the sky everyone stands there watching
in silence as the massive black dragon
gets smaller and smaller above them
finally Lord Tyrion looks at Samuel and
Davos then says well what about you guys
I don't think so says Samwell I want to
go home with my family I don't think I
will be back in King's Landing either
says Lord Davos I have a home of my own
Lord Tyrion Lannister left standing
there alone as Samwell and Davos walk
away Lady Brienne and Sir Podrick walk
over by where Arya and Gendry are
standing will you be making your way
back to Winterfell says Brienne I am
heading that way myself I thought maybe
we could go together no says Arya I
still have no desire to go home but I
wish you good fortune on your journey
Arya shakes her hand then her and Gendry
walk away as we watch most of these
characters head in different directions
the screen will suddenly Fade to Black
but only for a few moments when the next
scene begins it will be several weeks
later the very first thing we see is the
red keep in King's Landing we see the
Great Hall where the Iron Throne set for
hundreds of years this enormous castle
that once housed many different Kings
over the centuries now sits vacant the
following thing we see is Samwell Gilly
little Sam and their newborn baby boy
John they are now at samwell's Family
Home in Horn Hill they're all sitting
outside overlooking the gorgeous
landscape little Sam is sitting on
Gilly's lat while Sam is holding his son
John they're all much happier here the
next thing we see is Sir Davos standing
at the front of a ship that's out at Sea
then we see Lord Terry and Lannister
riding on a horse we watch as he arrives
at his family's ancestral home of
casterly rock this is the home that his
father said he would never get for
himself in the following scene we see
sons of Stark sitting at the head of the
table in winterfell's Great Hall
standing directly behind her are lady
Berean and Sir Podrick they are now
members of Sansa Stark's very own
queensguard now that sir Podrick has
widow's whale and Brienne has oath
keeper Hal Stark's ancestral Valyrian
steel sword ice is back inside the walls
of Winterfell guarding Ned Stark's
daughter the next thing we see is Arya
Stark and Gendry standing at the main
gates of Storm's end as Arya looks in
gendry's eyes she says I want to thank
you for what you have done Gendry Smiles
then nods his head I really mean that
says Arya thank you for everything thank
you for always being such a great friend
don't mention it my lady says Gendry you
know my offer still stands Gendry says
next and what offer is that Astoria well
says Gendry the one I offered you back
in Winterfell I would love it if you
would however before genre is able to
finish the sentence Arya leans in and
gives him a kiss on the lips this moment
will end without us knowing what will
actually happen next maybe Arya stays or
maybe she doesn't after this we will see
Daenerys riding on the back of drogon
high in the sky we can see they are
flying over the old smoking ruins of
valyria it looks like Daenerys has a
smile on her face as her and drogon fly
off into the distance now during the
final moments of my version of Game of
Thrones season 9 we will go back to the
God's eye everything on the sacred
island has finally been overrun by the
Flames the werewoods are not even
recognizable anymore the only thing that
inhabits the Isle of faces now are the
dead bodies that were left over from the
final battle there is however one thing
still alive on this island sitting there
along the shore of the lake is Ghost it
looks as if he hasn't went anywhere else
in weeks the reflection of the water is
seen in his blood red eyes all he does
now is sit here and watch waiting for
any sign of Jon Snow it's obvious that
ghosts will die here before he ever
leaves John's side again this final
episode will fade to black as we see
ghosts still sitting there looking out
over the Lake of the God's eye
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]